Yeah. Yeah,
it's definitely,
uh.
Considering the speed I'm moving.
I'm sorry. Today's show is smoother.
Okay, looking good. We've got the new database for the Oracle,
so we can get that set up. And,
uh,
I'd like to thank all the people who come here.
So, I think that's going to be within the end.
So, that'll get us. Also, I just had to take that,
you know, and then, I'm going to take it and go with it.
Okay. So,
I guess it's once we get at least the baseline on what they're expecting
established. I'll let more from home once you're placed next week and sit in
my own office and pull out the air for a few years.
Yeah. Yeah,
I don't want to act so hard. It'll be interesting.
Yeah. Depends on what their expectations are.
Hopefully they're reasonable expectations.
Not ones that are outside of the, Yeah. Yeah,
but I imagine it's probably something similar
to what I've been doing in requisitions for a long time.
For nesting wire,
I'm going to have us add wire sizes and gauges in there,
and, uh, I'm going to just keep those in the same linear metric as,
as the round bar, that's, that's what we'll end up with.
Five minute strut,
that's where we'll get. Yeah. Interesting.
You'll have to put it in, the wire is.
What? Like, how many feet that you actually buy in a school or
whatever it is. Yeah.
Stephen, Stephen and Michael can buy all the way up to 3,000 foot schools.
But. Yeah,
we'll see what. See what it comes to when we get to that and
then, uh, yeah, Alan's gonna kick up shot average this morning,
so he's just gonna listen. Until we get back in here and
then we set it for our agenda today.
Disintegration, contracting,
leasing, and then electrical. Uh,
and then I think.
That's,
there's some light topics that need to be burned through really quick,
so, uhm,
we can take a look at. Production and look at our odds,
see if there's any adjustment they should make, uh,
make sure that they have the rest of the route set.
Uh, recordings and then,
uh,
I think we can still drop road back to the road.
I don't,
I don't feel, I don't need to tell you what you think.
I don't feel good at all about the estimations.
That's their labor. And maybe the total labor's coming out.
I don't know. But, uhm, it seems like that's what is being used.
But the rate limit is vastly different.
So, I don't know if that's a good I
mean, that's something we, we could always go back to,
or like, okay, yep, yeah, we need something else to do.
That's, uh. There is focus.
I may report, uh, honestly,
I do know that they're going to keep pushing. For us to have a
higher percentage, even though everything's been adjusted for 75% and we've never really
tweaked that. You only need to change the settings,
but on the default, when I submit a start rebellion,
it starts at 98%, and then the estimator can adjust down or up.
Yeah, and, uh, kind of tweak their numbers so that they're,
that we can, we can ask what people feel,
but. Are we going in the schedule at all?
Uh.
Mark didn't want us to touch screen. I'll tell you being here is the
last thing about it. Yeah. So, um,
tomorrow is a new year for. I feel like,
I feel like,
like I'm comfortable with the basketball.
Okay. So, yeah, you know,
I'm on my side,
but we're hearing and doing future production planning,
and I'm just- You know what, I'm out there and then you try to
forecast some things. So,
that was, and I am really tough to do with teacher forecasting.
Yeah, so, that'll be definitely a little bit of,
uhm,
just brief our shirt from me just reading with it.
. Yeah,
but you're using the projects, you know. Yeah. Are you telling me?
That needs to be in the production plate.
Yeah, the production planer, and then you get that on the plate.
So, I need to work back to- We haven't done that.
We haven't really full-scale,
Like, using the production planer?
Yeah, actually. Uh,
so, okay. Steps to using.
The production planer is the most efficient way,
uh, so that we can, uh,
between me and Alan, uhm,
if you- you should at
least be how to release work
on the power. I know we won't keep our own,
like, some projects can go on the side, and to forecast everything.
Thank watching. So
if we can get it there and we can justify that, it's just a
special. Yep. Yep. Yeah.
So, uh,
just to kind of make sure you're not in the spirit business.
Alright. Thank you.
You said it by me, you didn't read it today. Uuh.
Hold on. Hold on. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No.
No. Well, thank you.
I'm gonna lay it. Ha ha ha ha.
Sommeh ha ha ha. you do things, you know..lord I'm gonna switch in a
new t-shirt. Ha ha ha. And that's it. Cause like,
the storyline, you know, about 2050,
Phoenix, the beginning of the world. Good. Woah,
because it'd be so hot. Right.
I don't want that temperature. It's the loudest.
I remember 1.3. I remember when I was sitting out
and once said I'd become a years adult hack.
And that's right, I mean, I'm down here.
So I'm a high-summer for the record,
and I was mean. I remember one of the very ones that I don't
have a phoenix. Yes. I've been here for eight years
soon. You know what I'm gonna show you.
I'm I'm gonna show you. It's a shower.
I'm gonna film. Just,
just say it on me. Yeah. Yeah,
it's already hard, especially with, uh, uh. Bye.
All right, heads and stuff.
Yes, I will. I think my crew is here.
And, uh, what do the guys paint?
I mean, The paint just blushes me.
Yeah, it depends. I keep it in ice pockets.
Hm. . . And on the, uh,
try and eat and share, there is an internal area quite a bit and
then once it's dry out too. Good. Good. And then it will take a
little while to double him when trying to start slowing down so that they
can, they can. . I don't how to I don't know I don't know
how to I
don't know
My goal was to live in Durango in the summers.
Yeah. Hmm. You
I don't even see all the benefits.
So things to be on the level of other than my house paid off.
Ha ha ha, great! units. I'm gonna do
something eventually about water.
Yeah ha! Uh-oh. Okay. Oh, that port is already making me regret ever having
a new water. That's the,
uh. Bye.
The charging was the water treatment and the electrical water.
Good. So,
that's the joy of living out in states. and you next week's video. Thanks
for next week. Thanks for watching. We'll be right on the end of the
two. Breathe it. Four,
ten, nine, five, okay.
you So, well,
let's take a look at it. And,
uh, I don't know what that really is.
This one, and now it took me about 40 minutes. It's been awesome to
anybody that crickets on the road. But,
uh, it's about 50 minutes and we want it to be an hour to
a minute. We're going 10 minutes at night. Up.
We're going to have six-card message in about an hour and five minutes.
Come on. Go up there. Yeah,
I looked at it, so the department's out there.
It's definitely cheaper.
Thank you for having me. Yeah,
I just wanted to build up there and, uhm,
the miller was buying down rates, so I guess you're 0.7%.
I also, uh,
couldn't pass that on. you
. . Uhh, uhh, hmmm, hmmm,
hmmm, hmmm,
hmmm. We'll see in the next video.
Bye bye.
Hahaha.
That's what. Yeah, yeah.
Keeps at that. You know this one and, uh, ehm,
ehm. You I still want to match things.
Yes, uh.
But I've had any issues that- I mean, I've been on a spectrum,
uhm, with the audience, and special news,
and production tests. Here's-
Yeah, and it's a bad little shit looking for it.
Thanks for all those who either get the money.
All right. Well, well,
what's the weird amount of that means? Yeah, that'd be a shocker to the
weak, right? So, yeah, it was so weird.
the this argument in one place is you're already a spirit,
but vice-versa, you're running toward the best of your work.
But at least she's. And then we'll go to the next.
Yes. What I want
to happen to miss you now.
But that's like, eventually,
yeah. Sounds like they're going to be doing whole-minute service steps.
And the big . . Getting the company to . .
. completely redo our servers.
So, uh, and that . . . this key is our original ITA.
Bye. He built everything that's done on and on here.
And that whole strip of service that himself.
And, uh, and And, you know,
he's like, alright, y'all okay,
we can do this. Yeah. We're long grown out and we have so many
different companies here. We're trying to tie together.
Yeah. You need to pay somebody who knows how to tie this together.
Yeah. Yeah, so. Is it going to be- Yeah,
a lot of the sugar room on premise.
It'll be the- same area in the main office where
the current one is. Yeah, it'll just be a whole lot more beefy.
Yes, sir. Thank you very much. Thank you very much.
you very much.
It's, it's all slow when you first get in that round.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So, um, this thing integration discussion actually is here.
Well, we talked about this for a couple
of times. . . Yeah,
that's the main thing.
Thank you.
Yeah, okay.
So, that's, I guess,
please look at this. All right, I'm going to let her in,
you know, ehm, oops. this.
And that's it. Mm hmm.
They're on the whole business stop with it. Mm hmm.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. They'll have,
they'll have paper software for the county, obviously,
because this isn't a county software,
but they'll feed it, but. . . Yeah,
but, this is maybe, uhm, maybe it's all point for you.
Thank you.
Further in the last
time, uh, I'm trying to question the point.
Thanks. They wouldn't,
you know, get loose and you'll try it. So,
I'm going to be moving on. Alright.
Uh.
I'll see how that I guess the main thing would be,
which I can take notes here.
Umm,
this is an integral.
And I know I'm talking about the last 7 million and they're quite vivid
in the, uhm. No, no, regard some of your mission
problem. So I'm going to look at what they want.
So we have six in one,
all of our labor codes, to be-
I brought an estimate, pushed into production,
and then have our labor exported in the time-trapping way
that we- do in those time-trapping before it's with the labor codes associated,
pushed back into this. So,
we have to- uh, basically not doing that out in the early months,
uh. Well, we do all of our time-trapping in.
. . Everything that we export to Vista,
we export it in an Excel sheet.
That has each employees,
information, employee number, and then whenever we set up a project,
uh. Each sequence and a lot is actually your
phase code, so, uhm,
third. 39,000,
uhm, so, okay. We end up filtering our tabs down and cascading
it out, and- read mapping the,
uh, the sheets so that it can be put into a
system with this. Okay. You And this applies to 39,000
in the employee number and the hours associated.
And it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it.
So I'm actually- And then there you have it through that other good project.
Or so it's automatically set up. uhm,
we do that for every project. And.
I need to be over with the supports.
And it happens a little bit. And.
I'm just the exhaustion in the snow.
No. That took him. So,
there's the look at the best case scenario.
It's going to be fine. Bye. Uhh,
yeah. Essentially, like, all of our people,
we have that one week bus person.
So. Don't. It really is,
um,
slightly begun. So, we have two different,
two different kinds of things. Thank you. And we have the face recognition system
that's completely extra on its team, all of it,
each employee, foxy, interfacial.
So they have a sample when they come in,
and then when they're working on projects and youth,
they're also implicating those hours. That's it.
All right. All right. All right. And going to The this meeting So that,
umm, this one, hm,
hm, hm, hm,
hm, hm, hm. Bye-bye.
You can see, that's where I was coming here.
Yeah. I was coming back against the project.
And, you know, percent complete versus average use.
That's where we're going along. And this is what we reviewed in our Thursday.
So we'll see if we have a
moment. And Umm,
and we're not dealing with production stations or,
uhh, uhh. You trying to help our production stations and all of the,
umm,
contracting. I think it's not going to count in one more Is there a
daily labor report? Umm.
You Yes,
you know, uhm.
I don't know if there's a specific report that you can pull across all
projects because- it's project management side,
project management side, as a PAM report said,
hold across every single project management job.
Bye. Umm, but,
each day, I get an email from the chat meeting that
is- I don't know,
basically a recap from previous day of hours used,
what increased- umm, if we're at a negative trend,
with hours, this percent competes,
and so on and so forth. . .
So I get this report daily being marked, give it so that we can
start getting ahead of it, This is our weekly sheet
that we reviewed and go around Fridays,
which is essentially this. The production schedules that are in
each project sequence associated,
um, just to review. Thank you. Plus,
can you use whatever you need, whatever,
or send it to Sarah? You know,
I'm not even gonna get that from your evaluating projects,
but. Good. Over the county side, you know, always,
I acknowledge you being able to look at daily,
later period. We'll see the next period,
forget which job that's happening. Yeah,
I mean, I can go in at the time and drive the module 30
for better. I'm turning on our owners and we can pull.
Oh. Well, I haven't watched the interview today,
I guess. So, you know, I believe is,
I don't know what you're talking about. Do you try productive labor person?
Is that productive labor? Uhh,
I mean, direct versus indirect,
I guess it's a better way to say it like. Bye bye. Yeah, so
we knew that, uhm, indirect project for the year where guys can apply their
time to their mom and indirect. it. Uh.
Which would be our 1200. Uh,
this is all anything entered towards this project.
It goes, indirect, fast. thumbs.
Umm, but most of the time,
the situation is so aggressive, you're using this,
so. I don't Most of the time,
all of the time, you just have to get into the projects.
So. But. and go
time tracking summary.
I I can't even,
And
this will give me a summary of,
All the labor that I was entered yesterday.
So, there's a couple of guys.
I think this one needs to be adjusted. There's no way in hell.
I'm gonna eat yesterday in 37.2-5-9.
I don't know, I'm trying to hit the Monday,
uhm, so this would be where,
uhm, or T.J.
goes in. . Those are, excuse me, what I'm playing with this,
and then why in the world is this this playing,
we're not gonna get it. So, yeah.
But,
yeah, this is, this is probably the best,
best area for this. Yes.
So, and then, hey,
what you're talking is, each line item is a person,
or it's really the summation of.
Have a good one. Multiple people in that, uhh,
this is our entire shots. It's usually yesterday,
right? So, uhh.
. So yesterday, somebody, some group of people wanted,
you know, charge 37 hours, too. . Yes,
and we ended up going in the area, and they walked into the shipping
and seating department. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Now,
this is not the unit you should be receiving.
So why are they wanting to the handling?
Bye bye. Because shooting or receiving does
not handle our material force. They often trust.
That's it. So that's it. All right. Yeah. Mhm.
If it requires to be removed from the shot or pulled out in the
shot or space, you know, the front because it's completed or needs to go
from the finish station. In the wild station,
all of that is handled by a shot with release,
yep. So, we essentially- I'm sure.
Usually, from majority of our projects have,
well, annually. I'm going to,
So, uhm, those give percent complete mark-offs as they
go through the mark with the p-straching and- And,
uh, and to have some time to inspections.
Cause, uh, it's time to,
uh, cut loose, um, burry.
And, to, uh, cut loose as well.
And, uh, well, it is a,
well inspection. So.
So That's totally
gone bigger. But.
Bye. No,
no, no, no, no, no. Well, that's most likely not a very well as
well. Okay, cool. you Yeah,
what do you like when you know why?
Umm,
I guess, at least. Please.
With the VISTA integration,
it is to not have us pulling XL sheets
from my- I'm finding them so that they can be affordable for it,
and then having that extra step beginning.
Um, but I'm pretty sure heard from them that this integration is,
is an invoice out from a purchase version down the point.
Alright, take all on the purchasing side there.
So, and that, I mean,
for purchase it's viewing here and,
That's pretty much the extent of it with the exception of a few sub-replication
videos about it together. And,
uh, Go. Go. So, so with that,
I don't really see, because I'm sure with the VISTA,
with purchasing that. Yeah. Yeah. Maudable.
There's money associated with that. And it's not been a little bit innocent.
You do double work. So, I'm gonna spend- I'm gonna even still leave the
double work. So, it's just a, uhm, not a nice, it's a nice eating,
like, good investment. Yeah. I enjoyed it.
And friends. Have a good eating,
so. Uh-huh. That's it. Uh-huh, so I don't see them ever.
I heard Umm,
holding the contracting air on my goodness.
And all the reason I say it is because.
. . . Umm.
So, me do not do the contracting air.
So, ehm, ehm. Thank you.
I'll the next third thought is probably my last one.
But I'll get time instead of spending more- So I've got more people from
there, say anything. I don't know if I'm to get any of that.
Yeah. So why don't people not try?
The interface is a little clunky,
uhm, for the, I love the more use of, uh,
a panel software, uh, their, their touch,
touch, I mean, no more to do that,
rather than any. So. So, So, yeah.
Which definitely makes sense. Without definitely moving that statement,
we're going to our time.
I'm sure I can do the time tracking the input.
I think we're going here and it's easier
to see. . But, uhm, like, the notes section,
there's so many random notes here.
And we can't, I don't believe him. I just stay in there forever.
And, it is, it is.
One less. 7 8 9 9 9 9
9 10 minutes to put
an entry in. So, a lot of the guys will track it on a
sheet, give it to them all, and enter it in about 5 minutes here.
And it's done. So many people want
really good time tracking.
In here. Uhm,
and this is fun, so it's not there.
Uhm, and we definitely use it.
But, I'm actually considered,
like, like, my muscle has an actual exercise,
so sorry. Thank you. I'm actually considered paying you to do a better interface,
um, with some more controls and stuff around here.
So, if I were to get there,
I was pretty glad you said you were going to need to live in
it. Yeah. Uh, that would be,
that would be pretty house. So,
so what's the system of timing out your minute? Um,
currently, time is captured.
are going to a year tracking and production,
had sported out, and uh,
and then verified against our facial. We'll see in the one.
This is a recognition system.
And we have in the shop, we compare numbers to numbers to make sure
that they don't matter. You match. And then, uh,
and then we submit the actual Excel sheet from this,
uh, from TechLog2W.
. . So, our conditional recognition was installed when we used to have QuickBooks,
and I was using the same, uhm,
moving quickly. It was plugged in with their face,
and it clogged out with their face, and it would just send it.
But, uhm, that would give us the- Projecting and breaking them and what
they were working on. This could be the ability to know what product they're
working on if they don't have our own request.
If they a project that day, then the time you actually divide it up
between five persons. That's why you move both.
We need to implement the period with, Well, it's the work done during the
day, and they have the witness to trust us. Yeah.
Pretty much. Once they need it now,
anyone's a- I'm used to a planet that's about a ton of- I'll see
you in the head after. Because the guy puts in his face
code for everyone to do it. Childx.
Thanks. Workstation, you know, workstation and why.
And he may work for five jobs a day, but it's all system.
See, it's probably the- That's good. I'm trying to correct me
if I'm wrong. Hold on.
Well, eventually that, that's the thing from,
yeah, right, make sure that people are actually working.
Yeah. you And the same thing we're actually working.
It does not look in the checks. And,
but even then it is the, uh. Yeah.
Making sure you're coming in after having the document with somebody's
over that, and it's the amazing, uhm,
kiss, and ye- Here is, you can go in here and say you started
at 4 o'clock in the morning and it,
you know, it was there to verify that. Thank you.
I have got your face of animal monitor and it takes a picture of
you and you get in, uhm,
then, then there's kelle more kelle. It be a good you're in,
you know, yeah, because again,
it's like, where they need people to say if you don't want to talk
to them. So, so. So.
And that's the other side of us using this and that,
um, in the morning they walk by,
catch us their base. They can go off to the floor,
stop waiting. And when they have their eye bags on their cell phones,
and they can be suddenly right there.
you Up to the umm, one minute of this next product you can plug
in on this one because I'm going to do this one.
So, I'll tell you what to do now.
I would rather try to automate the work to,
uh, to report any of the ads.
That's it. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's something that I also live in, if well,
uhm,
and setting it up for a, It's just an uneasy tweak.
Um, the problem I get into that would be,
I mean, the call from the shop manager, he has a,
I'm doing their time for writing it.
I need you to hold off and then I have a report explaining that
to five people and I'm like, hold on.
Yeah, I see it's to be addressed for if somebody decided
to put 36 in the mirror instead of three or six.
Yeah, so, and uh,
but I think that that ain't me. And I say- hmm,
hmmm, hmmm. the spray shinkler
to get in.
I mean, there'd be a way to get down on the right floor,
and that should be needed to just be, okay.
Custom export. I don't know.
All the millions. That would be,
that would be definitely the, the, side is not having to go in and
cut. I think,
uh, I think all of my shit comes out very,
not that hard to what we need. If you want to look into that,
I've got, I'm getting the names of some people that can do that.
Okay. As I was by Chris from the Parks Center in the rooms,
we're going to get Here, twice time does that take a minute?
Uhh, I'm doing the time.
Thank you. Alright. Bye for the minutes.
Good. Good. Per day? I don't want it.
One day a week. One day a week. Yeah, that's all good.
Yeah, so. That's, that's been the biggest.
We haven't had too many,
like, custom points in here, dispersal reports going to get,
uh. Thank you. You can get spending,
you know, so you got a lot of different things that you want, and
you always get changed, and adjusted and on,
so. So, You know, I'm on a dozen per reserve on your own vacation
to somebody else's. There's other people that can do it,
uhm, in shock. One of the shock minutes were long because the
time tracking emails that he sent, uh,
he didn't do the exports, uh, marketing and assistance.
I'm gonna a look at community experience as well.
Giving you a food, ech, a farm guy. Is somebody else does the pain
guys? Uh, a pain system uses system.
What sort of thing are they been very anti-system
for a long time and now? Now,
We are pushing heavily for them to use it and,
well, being the leader of buildings at this point,
is- Very unward with it. So,
uhm, we're taking full advantage of having an advocate,
um, so. They say. Yeah,
and it's definitely,
you know. It's definitely came along the way. Me and, and, and.
Good. So,
uhm, okay.
So, thank you.
I guess if this is what I asked, how to do business integration,
what we can do as well. Integrate a few days ago.
Uhh, let me see if I need a language.
And
there's a bunch
of this. So,
this is Paul and Rose and she got it. See ya. It's going to
happen. So I am trying
to add a deep number,
obviously. See I'm going an e-document to it.
I got an e-order. Oh, it's a jintique.
And.
I don't know.
All characters are sad.
Uhm, I see that. You know what I hear?
This is some of the needs to hear it.
If you can send that mobile email, or it's,
this is something about how the game occurs.
Like, you gotta get this, uh, lovely,
uhm, uhm, uhh, So
you need to set that up locally. So we can see the preset maintenance.
Good. You can set that up right there and it just skids out there,
but rather than getting a big upset,
there's no- there's no- Are we sitting here? No, we're sitting We to wait.
The reason it should be an individual said. Um,
yeah. Yeah. As long as everybody has an older drive,
man, man. Yeah. Yeah.
Now, umm. Bye. Bring the gym everybody she has on our
butt mat that's in tight blood. It's just in front of me whether it's
good. I do have some reports because right now there's a place
where customer reports should be. Okay.
Umm, I like it.
And all of us are, we're made up by this last thing.
Umm, the reason I like that is because we want
to do it in. You more. He's got,
everybody knows exactly where to get a similar law,
so they'll, like, be able to. I've been a project manager for a lot
of things, something that happened on the job,
on the airport. What was it? Part of it was a review.
I think you should say, I think you should do whatever work.
They actually get a log input out.
With that, I'm getting your computer before I'm your log.
Oh. Oh. Well,
but yeah, you said that. Didn't add it to the bottom of the limits.
Everyone used to say it. All right. By the following,
everybody's going to have a checkbox and they're going to fall a bit weird.
Okay. So, now I'm going to try and receive- Yeah,
I'm getting out of close to putting all of
that on the server area. Good.
Good. Yeah,
I'll get the key. Would anybody have sneered a
burp? We want you to modify the, uh,
uh, or customize the report that's out of you.
Thank you. Bye.
Does that be able to customize it?
That'll just be customized in the end report.
Thanks for watching.
Yeah, and if I don't, if that's how you get up there,
it'll look right. Probably not.
Probably just gonna be a- I mean, if anything,
I'll keep the request, and then I'll do it.
So, uh,
we try again some more. Alright, let's month, okay.
So, anyway, that
now not gonna be as mobile at this point.
Yeah, but, if you didn't,
just set that. Get a poll.
Oh. I'll show you a good set, man. Yeah. Let me get it.
Sorry. Perfect. Thank you, man.
That is it.
Yeah. Cool. That
big tech, what do you do? I've been looking for that for a long
long time. I've been eating a little bit, finally, last year,
I called the month, but I'm like, work out in the meeting. Like,
I'm sure if I reply to this, you know, cause they were doing a
good thing. And people are like, well look at the girl and look at
that. I have to see the droplets. Awkward,
so I'd say. Yeah, I've had it.
I've had it. Yeah,
I've had I was- I've never knew when you get started.
Yeah. They grew up instantly.
Somebody's not crazy. I've had it. I've had it. had it. had it.
I've I've had I've had it. Just check over here.
Send a screenshot of this. Make sure you get it next.
Still. Nah,
it's the- . . . Yeah, I think that's the- I'll make the adjustments
so that everything's uninserted, uhm,
is that a fee? Okay,
uhm, I think.
Again.
Back to whatever this will
be. Please. So, this is their new- the master of the urban-based
code guide. Which most of what I mean now
it is. lives. Oh, it's an infinite choice.
39.
Oh
So, this way,
it's kind of a construction building on us,
to use revenue. So, we're located 39,
it's actually the same building, 39, 1,000.
Okay. Yeah.
Which is, uh, typical, 39,
it's for company 40. Uh. So,
uh, company 40,
division 39, I and then the activity levels is what they break in.
next one. Okay, I'm So,
each, so 39 this pad, yeah, 39 is in it,
in the structure of the patch. You Ah, so.
And then, quite cool,
simple, okay, as everyone, as everyone.
Hey. So, so everybody is 40.
Then, you'll be on,
uh, face codes. And It's associated with each trade and area of
the work, or what. So this thing goes all the way through load.
Yeah. So if you- I'd rather look at company,
whatever. You would see very,
uh, same consistency for the shop and the building.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
anything the same thing. Uh, you could be honest,
not sure much of how blooming fields were.
No, I, I get it. I don't either. . Yeah,
this is the laundry.
The, uh, standard fees towards the building. One more supply.
As I would need, uh, a,
a, a, a specialism. So,
followed by with your other,
stops, and if you're reintegrating in,
um, or implementing this later,
dot unquote crap. The,
The best sh-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m-m.
the one who said,
Doc, you can grab that one if they want. You can grab that one
if you want. You that one Doc,
you've got it here.
No procedure. Here's what we're doing about it,
why is people don't make an option. Yeah,
otherwise, it's masking.
No, you have to have it. And, uh,
I think one of the things here is flow charts and descriptions
for everything. I mean, heck,
when you do an ERP upgrade, if you don't have it,
people think they know what it is, but they have no idea what it
would be. Yeah, yeah. I learned that one hard way last year.
Uh,
so if you're, if you're using- I don't if I'm starting on codes.
Uhm,
I don't see, uh,
the issue. Thank you. But I was thinking that we were talking
about the carries from the,
the beam. You might be one to the people on the house.
It seems how,
the one plan, the product, see what we're into.
Here. Thank you. And it might be a different one for
another type of sibling. Yeah.
But I don't see those. All guys. If you please have their spare.
I don't see that I'm getting sealed.
Umm, so this one's this one's most of the time I'm gonna check with
you. Our typical face cut off for labor and when
I get multiple sequences or multiple- histories of work to in the thirty-nine one
thousand, dot zero one, oh,
this is the- this joke labor? That's just- We'll see Peace.
We'll see you later, vote out later in the thousand. Material is zero,
eight, three thousand, and there has been, as usual,
the one that we initiated- I'm just kidding. You can skip with that.
Uh.
Bye So,
we usually take plain angles,
channels, beams, everything long, it's not up, it's huge. That one,
okay. So. I'm gonna go And see you Bye.
So, so you're telling me that,
ok, I have a piece of pipe.
Bye. I like I use in a structural project.
It would be that o 8 3 0.
But, if I use a piece of pipe on a rail.
It's so, it's still going to be a great video.
Yeah, it's uhh,
most of the time they don't end up getting into the material.
We're going to aim this. I'm breaking out of that thoroughly.
Yeah, they usually keep it or they need to have structural skill bucket.
The only time we will see that- That number to differ is if we
have multiple interior buckets for areas of work on the project.
Okay. So let me- We can make- so that we can have
one of the best ones all after they gave you the- the base of
the extension. Here we go. And back we said,
ah, that's easy to do. What else?
I'm sure you think what else. You might not want you if you start.
That's more info. Now you could basically,
or have to say, every single line, I didn't want that face good,
I'll give you that material. Um. You But if all material should go on
the same thing as good, that's easy. If we can send it up to
the estimate, just the pH should be at the end of the estimate.
Here it is. Oh. Oh. Here's all the things we can associate across.
Uhm, so that would be simple to do.
On the back view, to the end. Okay.
You can put the, you get it on the PX as well.
So it would, it would be a mirror. Come on. The bottom hat,
um, now,
you're playing for, if you're in.
Yeah, that's, that'll be worth it there, right? Yeah, and then, I mean, even
if we were. Bye bye. Even if we put it in the home material,
it's over eight, three thousand, and then we did have one is most
of the- time it's gonna be that, plus,
whatever connotations are gonna differentiate it from the area of work,
if the project's- that large, uhm,
outside of that, then it's- it's basically that would be our governing
code for the material. real. So,
a lot of times, uhm,
depending on the project engineer,
he and team I'm working with for the field.
Sometimes I get that same phase code as I have written on the
speakers for, PC forums,
product release forums, uhm,
how we do the technical side of things,
how we expect projects to come in. And, and everything.
And so, aw man. Let's go.
Where's that at? you I shouldn't worry, you've written all those procedures.
Where's Gotta? Umm,
I have to see where it's located in the- the hour time at
this point where you can change your eyes.
But, uhm, I have to We certainly
link next week or something, but I appreciate it.
Yeah, yeah. I'm going to read that. Yeah,
uh, procedures. on us for any procedure or
form of creativity for anything that we have in shop checklists.
Yes. So,
this is the form I created for when somebody released the project to us.
Isn't the project not- I don't remember any days on safe day requirements manager,
uh, I'm a manager, engineer, customer, um, client. Thanks watching,
and I'll see I have information, shipping address,
um,
delivery site, who's handling it,
coding specs. That's better. Umm, well enough,
PDE, a quarter of any of the vitamins are hard here,
and the specific project in and so we need to if the engineer pre-ordered
any of the materials and the PDE is associated with it.
And a lot of times, we don't. Umm,
so they'll send us the phase code for what they had,
so this is the chain order, so they end up at 18-39.
you 1,000-changer in number 9, and they had 63 hours estimated,
so at this point we would then look at it,
and- and we'd try and do our own breakdown,
just based upon the view in the print, and then,
uhh, as soon as- let's look at it, so we'll have a good day
for you. Yeah, and I'm pretty certain it's not estimated
even. That's what it is.
Hey, I- . .
So the estimate does
give you that very good.
Yeah. But it seems like they take the total and then do their.
. So, a lot of it is,
um, cause all, all the-
it sometimes keep an eye on my own,
umm, just like,
burn in um. Bye bye. It will be this hour of many hours,
and then I'll take those hours, look at the burn time,
and I'll fill up my thronest. And I'll take a little later of the
runtime, and then I'll assume it after our version in 15 minutes,
or low in 15 minutes. But I'll load depending upon the scale of the
parts that are on there. And so,
burns one and we see a lot of adjustment on.
From what Tappa has for doing the perimeter of Vermont for the
time calculated in here versus what my latest- the time is saying,
plus we factor union loading normally.
We need to fix that. That's a period of simple- please call the thing
to do. So if you're constantly interested and you know what you want
to adjust the thing, that's easy to fix.
Cheers. Assume that it fits and it is what I would do so that,
that everybody's going to have to re-escalate after this and it's,
you know, me and that having the- I didn't know that right would be
another question I would have, you know, so,
you're best. That was one of the issues.
Cheers. What one day was,
okay, we're starting to see it, okay, how do we know what work we
need to get this to? Nope. We're bringing that off the t-perk
cannon from the shot, so, you know, I know if that means that was
the only one at a place. This is because what happens is they
go through the hours, they use them under the hours,
and if they have a character they want to keep it as before.
So they just tell them,
oh, we're going to post it, they have extra time I was doing this,
but at that time, I was going to do it.
And that's quite a bit. Yeah,
so, yeah, we can fix that.
And people are having a minute meeting with me and playing all this,
uh, ninja tips it out. No one really got my face getting cheated.
Yeah, so. What We can bet we fix that.
Who else can we since change order?
Umm, this one.
One. One. One. One.
One. One. One.
One. Well,
they're not really estimating sack leather.
Estimating the off the field in some little spreadsheet,
I sure can get. I'm sure to. So,
that's why it's not intact. I deal with it a lot. I don't know
if you're going to have to be able to use tail. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Next slide. Has the end goal and,
and so unless one of these,
uhm, B or D not- I'm gonna reach out to go out and walk
for myself and get us to still work.
It has, but this is- Thank This has been an estimated,
uhm, more than likely this one was not estimated in total.
Are you useful at happening from up here?
But, what is that? That they're actually having access to check within the field?
I have not seen that. I don't know if I go and see if
they're in shock. Bye bye. Sure. Uh,
yeah. Yeah, of course. They do it and they have field access to it
and the guys know how to use it. If they hand it on the
tube, they're just- you there's no more- there's no private care here in Phoenix.
That's one of them. They've got a good field purchase.
All good group access. All good girls. Hold I'm a member of the board.
Here's the chair of SHUT UP on site. Here's the chair.
I was right there today. So, yeah. I need to be- You is that
happening? You know,
there's probably- Indeed.
10 people that are so stuck with it.
And of this giant list of estimators,
umm. This is an online area,
and these are not a few test projects.
Umm, I estimated in your office the nights in the-
Guys don't even know how to use that, but that's a little training exercise
to get that in. Okay. We'll We'll see you next week.
Bye. Bye.
Bye. Okay,
so here, if I
was here at this point now and it's here again, I will, could I
have them to use the- I have them to be fortunate in fact.
I will learn it in the next way or if you can do ?
?
I was asking, what everything's gonna be right in the back.
I was asking, what can there be a bunch of estimated in here this
week with me? Oh, I'm not even gonna remember.
I'll do an expunctive adjustment. So,
you know what? So, where's the best place for me to go on the
monitor? And it's just, you gotta use your video.
We'll see guys in the show. Uh,
yeah, we're listening to this here for a second,
and everyone's got to stand up if a place is so mad.
Uh. Bye-bye. Uhm, but it's, we're on the supership.
I get that said, um, shit. You figured out how to let me know,
because I'm going to be able to say, because we're all on you to
do it. This guy seems to be the reason they're in a damn street,
having him say, hey, I'm gonna do this business.
Yeah, you know, I like that, so. Yeah. you Yeah,
working with kind of, uh, well,
we're gonna say we're past the days of the,
uh, basic training. Hey. That's it. Okay. That's it.
Except for when there's a bunch of people that aren't usually,
so when you need it, that's it.
That's it. That's it. That's it. That's it.
That's it. That's it. You That's it. That's it. That's it.
First, they have to come
to you. They should also come to one person and say,
well, let's learn how to do spec- Bye-bye.
That's where
we repeat that with lots of issues. It is, uh, we have new estimators
that are coming in. And, you know, just doing a lot of takeoffs of,
uhm, well,
in the system. Yeah. So, coming in.
Good. Good. Going into, uhm,
this lower portion down here. But,
not the wrong with the additional labor and,
and that. You I don't have any of this to it,
but the main layer kind of set up, I'm here at the coast,
but I'm gonna use the cobia on the back. Well, uh. And so,
those capture so much more than just any well.
Should have been captured can be- But the holes in it,
the clips, silencing. I've seen it as the better news.
I've just kind of estimated myself.
Yeah. It's insistent. So. I'm going to get out of that sentence.
And then he knows we're getting out of here. I'm trying to get next
to me. I'm going to puke. Okay. What's happening?
I'm building. You know. So,
in that, that's one area that we've been uhh,
nice to meet us. The job is better, and one of the reasons that
they're allowed would not be an award-driven project,
and one of our year-days is that we're so different from the- some of
these windows and ears that have come down, they're coming in and doing a
lot of well-ticked ops when more of our scene in this community.
I'm using labor codes and then using additional labor to fill in a gap
where we need additional bullets or so much.
And so forth, how many instructions on this lane is that played?
Yeah, they're actually using tech.
Uh, just, I should move it to green.
Three that are dedicated estimators,
so they're also capable to come up, and,
yeah, come up, visit, and unbox.
Also, with Jesse,
um, I think he has to be able to have a certain,
you know, to read and learn to be. . . So,
if, if he estimates himself, it's probably forever being heavy bit,
and he's probably more estimated in the.
. . Okay. If you look at the portion of it, anything fat,
it's associated with Jesse, the department usually is Tristan Crowe,
her arms are, And we'll see your estimator.
And, uh, where do you listen to it? But they get it in the
giver. They have a fourth floor. I'm I'm just I'm this.
A third floor. So, I'm gonna third floor.
But I'm gonna be especially. I'm gonna keep coming here all week.
And then we go all the last week. Now I'm gonna be here.
Yeah. Okay, I'll sit with,
like, a fishbowl set of officers, Jesse,
and one of those with a PSN outside of his office. I'm going go
ahead and I don't think that's even the first word.
Is that an image of a visual of a lot for somebody who's done
it if you can get a normal word or other one? I don't know.
I don't know. So,
I'm all in.
I keep going back to the, ah, I think I'm in.
Yeah, we can- doing this integration stuff. That's not a big deal.
Umm,
I swear they were having been very well spent.
We'll see in a minute. Yes. Yeah,
I agree with you. Yep. Uh, uh,
I think you're getting more by and improving your audio.
I'll skip the hours from now to the early this week.
Uhm, I-I think we've had-we-we'd be better
off. Well, I'm doing this now. We can make these labor hurts too.
Exactly, but, uh, that endling.
Go ahead. You can't
think that the world's government.
We can make this exactly that if you want. Go. That's, that,
that would be a hell of a lot better.
I love watching, doing a bunch of night to figure out.
That is, and that's another area where we have confusion is the layout
of the handling, the layout of the fit.
Good. Most of the time it goes in the fit,
and then, um, but we also have the fit of category and U,
so category. I wish I had five hands up,
and we're going one category, and then we got weld,
and then we have clean material handling,
and, but. So, if we simplify these labor groups
out to basically what my P***** has on it,
yeah. Uh, with the exception of needing to add burn to this,
then we're going to keep getting the consistent rate.
So, are you in the basket of this tone here?
Yeah, so why not fix it?
Yeah. So, um,
I'm hoping to, uh, uhm- I think what that would be flash there
should be, we don't know. This, this, this integration,
act, act with the fix is, then we- We can set it and set
it up relatively quickly through,
which is giving you the breakdown of the Halloween.
Bye, thanks again too. You want, right?
We're bringing all this and I'm just gonna have it.
So, um, so, I'll just suggest.
Just. Here, you just, then, you know,
stay on the bottom and then we'll bring you back and go back and
donate these. Right? All right.
I'm glad you did. If you can't get me filled, you're late.
I haven't seen it. I've seen it. it. I've seen it.
I'm glad you did. I'll next video.
And we'll see Okay. I
think it's gonna be, it's gonna freak out on your dad's.
She's gonna have to be in bed. So. Heh.
Heh. Heh. also able to return it here that we just have everything
to do with cutting was 1-3-9.
Things are pressed for- 1-3, water jet,
1-9. Everything to do what's fit out was 10-19.
Everything to do- with welding. So,
we just had things in groups of 10. Because somebody wanted- sometimes somebody would
say, well, I want welding. Thank you for us today. For this and welding
for that. It was made within a century.
It was made within the same family. Yeah. That's just the way I'm used
to- doing it, not having it all over the place.
And then when you make the routing, the routing,
and blow it through the shop. Thank you very much.
I believe, by the way, uhm,
what's the activity on this production?
Good production. It,
it, it has one effect in the instrument,
uhm, specifically,
like, if you don't.
You know what about your, your, your, your, uh, just a separate care? You
just get that, right? Good. Yeah, I think it's really hard to include it
in all of it. Uh, yeah, I think the most part is just the
ones with the auto clips. Yeah, and my, uh, uh, like,
H and I are very common ones that we use.
I've been telling them that it really has been a second.
Okay. . And then,
10 minutes, and then And we have,
in there, type H, quarter, H, type H,
5, 16, type H, pattern,
3, 8. So, as the.
So, The filler, it says increases, umm,
you can just plop that, leave it good and just cool.
I'm cutting. Hallelujah. I'm not gonna question your cutting.
Umm, so you got plate plasma cutting,
but you've also got, plasma shape cutting.
And then you got softening.
So, size-
What is plasma cutting complete? Perfect. What is plasma cutting shapes?
Thanks. Still sucked.
So, how do you differentiate the time it takes to socket something versus
burst? I'm gonna cut the shape. So,
with, with that,
uhm,
I guess we got it really, We haven't really broken that out,
and that's another area where we've been trying to fine tune this.
I'll pull the, uh, pull the reports.
We're on land tech, and see what their runtimes are,
and anything. Thank you.
Associated with that, all the separate colors of
this Azure ACPC time, associated with this. Subs.co.uk for running
channels and needles. And uhh,
that's always stuck into our pocket.
Uhm. Um Because if the ACPC goes down and it's just more
common than I like it can ever be, uhm,
I think it just goes past it. So. on. And if you still have
fun, if you still have the minutes, or whatever,
you can't see me as far as that.
All right. I have time for you to invest in my view,
regardless of what, what is,
what do you think of this, but, this is so awesome.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, all those, uh, that kind of notion,
ah. But what would you, what would you see normally in the shop if
you have different cutting centers? We'll see you in the end of your front
toes. Most of the balance you've got to know if it doesn't matter how
to cut it. But they're not driving it.
You spoke to me about estimating it,
and I had something that was twice as fast as something else.
My ball would be- Yeah,
and they're not making that decision all day, so when it's morning, when it's
morning, when All right. And through this, you're to go and it can be,
it's just so important to me to take this,
this amount of time. When it goes by,
unfortunately that's about a slack. Yeah,
that's about one. Okay, um, I mean,
I can see huge differences in the time of
the job. No. No. Yeah,
but I have to show you the editing time. But,
you know, most of the time, about 40 or 20 years will be cut
on one machine. Alright.
I kind of believe in my, this channel's on the right,
and they don't have any jig that's peeps, so they're all kind of a
bit more self-made. I guess I'm tired. I can't big buy out,
you know, but often it was simply buy out,
you in front of somebody that doesn't be minding that.
They don't tell it. When they get to be minded,
we can cut, transfer, put holes in it,
and mark. It's grabbing me. Last year.
you You know, year alone,
we spent $700,000 in selling our beans.
And, uh, it was a cheap and a bean furniture.
Like a wipe-down, with a wipe-down axe.
I have no idea what it was supposed to be.
Bye. Well, you can, uh, build a little more.
It's very expensive. Yeah, nice. Now I don't achieve it.
But I won't believe it. I'm a bit death-cated problem.
around. But I don't believe that I would get it to 7 I would.
I don't think we're long term in. What? Where? We'll see you ever do.
I think I might be five years from now.
If I think I might need the full system,
uhm, uh, soft. You know, a drill, a giver,
yeah. And I'm going to buy something that can be part of the system
that I can add to you know. You've got to play with it.
But, unfortunately, it's a full system thing.
Yeah, I-I want it better. I want it,
uh, automation of the movement of the,
I don't want to go out of the jinglish neighborhood and stuff.
So that man, I want it to sit and that works.
Yeah, it's, uh, uh,
we a- you don't buy that much. That's it.
I'm a real. I've crossed it out.
Portland, Fyster, Fythonx. Thanks.
Yeah. I've priced him out. Yeah.
He's about how he turns the week you want to do.
Hey, Justin. Really? Hey, do this. This is,
i
And
probably the same with barber mitzel oil.
Go. I'm
sorry. Open the margin, man. I'm not gonna get care. Let that.
We'll see I
think next week I'm gonna go get over. . . I'm just thinking that
you monitor yourself a little bit and see what I'm doing.
I'm going to do that and it's hugely active today.
I'm going more of a minute, maybe finish this, and that's my next thing.
I'm a lot of time in that practice.
I'm going to put a little bit about five minutes. Or, you know,
it's there. And the first one,
you know, like, I'm going to get a boxing turn like something,
okay? And then I'm bleeding, you know. you won't be I take the 3-7
o'clock to get married and that's when people start to straw in it.
You lose a gun, people come right after me, don't you?
You used to be an idiot right about showing up in six.
Okay. I'm going to do a tour of you.
Don't blow it nearly up. You're playing.
I'm going to move over to the big corporate office at eight o'clock straight.
That was the one on the board to think about everything.
You know. I want to. I'm going to tear it once. You know,
you probably want, uh, since,
uh, your, since cravings will be in here,
the end. You want, uh, clean at the paint,
as well. Boom. Is that material handling
of that label there? Is that what is the material doing with that?
It just allowed another file. By the way,
newer is it? No, that one we can wrap up in just update to
just clean. Uh, but that's,
that's more- one area that I'm not alone with.
One area of confusion we've had on the past,
since we haven't seen very good sort of material. Two y'all.
Umm,
so, but we can address that, uh, so that it's- ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm. keep up with the full panel,
do you have fun with the partial panel,
fun for the basic world? Okay, uhm, everything doesn't mean to talk about the
boxy, everything doesn't mean to talk anywhere,
I'm just going anywhere. Okay, now I'm gonna be sweating out.
It doesn't have any water to drink. Hah,
hah, hah. That's a good point.
If we come up there, if you have water to buy it.
We're not in these things, aren't in order, like, for those,
like, yeah, all of a sudden,
you know, water can gather to start a loop.
That's why I used to it. I mean, yeah, that kind of makes sense,
you know, I've got to work with them, and he's in the long run
for a nice and career to say, you know,
I've got to start a few years ago. My last year,
uhm, uhm, I guess,
you know, click, click, click, click, click, click, click,
and it'll be fun to see them. I see that group on,
click, click, click, click, and it'll be in.
Oh, is that right? Just leave the plane in the landing room. Oh, okay,
so that would be You don't see that in the afternoon.
They're going through, it's like, in these options.
The main thing we're getting right now is when they pull up- with their
estimate summary, all of these descriptions are available
to get out of these different- I have to go running up across so
we need to put them on here on the box or do they haven't.
Either on the box, they have to be there,
they have to show the- but they already have both of them on the
paper side of it. Yep. Now,
this one's- this one's given to us by a technical guide and be- you
know, I think we've really done, I guess,
maybe any custom ones in there. Umm,
but we got- Thank you. So that's
one of one of
our forests.
on own. I will have a and ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm. in the United States, but I'm happy to get an understanding
of it last time. I mean,
go ahead and read what you can ask. I'll do that shit.
Yeah. That's, I've done it,
you know, they said all the other things. And it's like,
it's one of my stuff that I used to have a time I used
to do, you And for me, it's amazing,
it's, ah. I'll, I'll kill. I can say two clicks,
I don't know if it has a lot of numbers. Yeah,
yeah. One thing I-
Of course, do not have that in it. If I have a little committee,
then you have to have to make sure all of this.
That's what happened. I'm big, tic.
Good. I want to give a global man of,
uh, uh, uh, the Family,
uh, so you can see every bite and all that.
Go. Yeah, because I never seen an email and get me a drink.
So I don't want to dust everything at all.
Now I'm not a chance. And it's a very- You and
intindically, it's last, cause now I'm like,
3 foot of well, and then there's ehm,
or 1. But, uh,
I mean, it's-
From the detail or from the type of testing.
Okay. I was happy to hear from the detail I would think that I'd
see my thing, because you're more pending.
You can do some model of your application. No,
that would be a real question. But I think,
uh, the detail I can turn the level off on the head,
Umm,
yeah, no, there's no one. I submit a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a.
Yes, ma'am. I take one hit. We have to have a little bit.
Yeah, and they see, believe it, from a movement.
Cause that one's ruining her clip, believe it.
. So you open, click, believe it.
Cause you can't even go in and highlight all of them.
And believe, you have to go one, one.
Bye So now we can, we can get them in and joint everything
to the new box. And then we'll come back in.
We can just leave the rest of the crap out.
And then we'll have a much more simplified. So,
you get our operations to do that. I think we're like a re-
hmmm. So, this is where we just want to get it going to the
right area. So, this is a little bit tedious.
Yes, well. So,
uhm, it might be easiest to say,
like, sort my, uh, labor group here.
you And then just re-point the groupings.
Check where we're going to go. If you need that,
send it out, come to th- I know that it will say,
we don't. That time,
so I'll get rid of these and ask them again. I think there is
no- I don't want me to get in the,
uh, time, and then we need to swear. Hmmm.
No,
I think we can just, just,
is that- Right now, anything in quality control-wise is- there's
a separate, empty bucket that's added to every project.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, so you can just add some kind of tune- I think
it will- You've got to check it, every moment- you've seen everyone be saying
it individually. And so you go, yeah,
I'm gonna check this one out and check it out. Well,
then see how the park is. I mean, the fidders should be going their
own checks. Yeah. So, uh,
most of this check time gets fun to go around with that time.
But, let me check it done by the end.
Yeah. I don't know if you were a shot that was doing nothing
but the thousands of operations. And going to that we don't have you to
have a couple of things, but when I see a gear it's more,
it's like, I'll check, a B. Thank you. Yeah,
yeah.
Sometimes the only spot to lean on the spot shape that we're going to
get into games. James. When you go to check, I'm going to be on
that. I'm trying to get a good one. Well, I walked a couple of
them a couple of days ago,
and I could see marks on. Yeah.
Umm. Like somebody and put a clip on and
then groundly off properly or whatever. Thank you very much.
Alright.
forward.
What purpose?
Yeah. I could send it out to you by the way.
But if he just said it like you. Get good then.
Yeah, I don't know if the music can do it. So,
I mean, if you get what I said, I said, I mean.
It does the uh, he works a chat,
but it's worth it. He does all of the hardware and hardware controls for
the Christmas money, son. And that makes him PC,
so he's a part of his car, so he's like,
I have to remove me in the van, isn't it?
Yes. See guys soon. He's actually looking,
you know, more of their dad, so I can get him a bike at
risk to try to get him in, uh,
integration. You know, that would be super sweet,
but yeah, yeah, well, so, obviously we've got those in the system because of,
uhm, it's here, and maybe- I've got a new update,
and I'm just following all of the settings,
and I have a meaning to put it into my stuff, because they don't
offer any sort of, uh, guide my- I don't know.
I don't know if you can read about April Permanual,
but it means the feed rates, but it means cut qualities,
and it's- It's fine. I know how to do that instead,
and you train me how it's gonna go as well, but yeah.
But if I'm fine,
uhm, I'm- She's back in the room.
Yeah. By my location, and you're gonna call hangout train,
I'm on a 360 stainless right now.
So, thank you. Don't- Good bye. . But,
uh, I'm doing a- I'm doing a website for support.
I guess it's perfect. And I'm gonna have a spot in the head.
More than more than I will have where clients can get
together and talk about this at ACPC. I'm going a motion that I can
get to ACPC. Here's why I'm sure we're going to be about to get
this out, and I'm going to just show them that all there,
sort of. Yeah. Yeah. Having me,
uh. Yeah. The chat boards for us.
The chat boards for us.
I'm going to have, like, monthly web hours.
You just go through where I'm from. I'm to try to get some of
these guys to come all over the same. Let's listen to you play,
because it's even better to say what they're playing in it. Umm,
yeah. Yeah.
I'm definitely interested in that. Because, uhm, I'm s- I mean, not only am
I, I mean, once you're in the industry, you're in the industry.
Yeah. So, uh, in the minority of us,
you're there. It's awesome. Yeah. It's a, it's a normal institute.
So, so, you should, or do you decide
on that or do you want to do that? There. Uhh,
this one we will put into the art.
So, I'm gonna say we put on a check. Thank you. Okay. I will
read.
Because they need to do that.
I want to follow me. A
bunch of you like it. I can't even know.
So, you're, so it really is.
The quality guy is not responsible anymore.
It's just the better this was possible.
So, the better it is, checking if it's required.
water. And then the QC comes over with a thumbs up inspection report.
So, QC is still.
The ring, the check. But,
you see the rest of our track on the separate code on the Anderson
part. . . Okay. So, you see those where to put their time on
the project. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, it's the only order,
the only order to get this premium. Umm,
this project schedule, which you can see me,
this is a renovation time in here. Umm. I will see Bye.
See you next You know, I'm It's the same code for every single project.
But, I'm just a man without that, I'm trying to say her to me.
in the In the first generation of this two topics would be just- probably.
Yeah, we would see the behavior. So,
yeah, where's failure? See guys next I have some expected them all to get
your troubles away 0-1-14-0.
So. Go.
I don't think they would call about all this weekend's about 3-1-4-0.
Okay, we're going to move on to the next and I cannot normally get
it in here so that people can say it wasn't that I mean.
Otherwise, I've done this for 2-2-2-0.
You have very common good, and then you can paste it there rather than
have to be able to click through and find it.
What do you think about how you call
it? Enjoy the video. Have a good one? I don't know.
You
can also look at it from the leg and group on the leg.
I have to, it'll stay on, check in with you so I can sprawl
up you. Thank
I'll
tell you, I'm gonna stop that, please.
Like, I, I got some sickness for a little bit.
Thank you.
Ehm, ehm,
You
I can't be very fast today.
I'm gonna stop stepping down. Let's do that.
Totally, I was trying to leave the same house. Let's let's go. That's very
good, and it's modest. Thank you.
Thank I'm
going to take part in my ability to grab things to go inside and
apply to that. Alright. Let me see,
just don't get
it and get it.
.
I it's a little quick because I'm drinking a lot of the fish because
I didn't. Ah, I'm thinking I'm certain that I have migrated.
Have a great day.
So, have you heard or are you aware that the goal
is to have all estimators or all of some of these people?
That's the goal of the way I understand it.
So, uhm. I know.
Okay. I can't really tell if
some people are, but it looks like there's some here.
Church. Well, some might be in cattle shops,
and might be in the same thing as you leave between beer and gilbert.
Church, gilbert.
You k. Morning, libr. Orange. Okay.-gilbert.
G. And that is run by the guy in float.
Cause they go. So, I'm all up to Denver.
See, like, the lead estimators in there. This is what I've heard.
I haven't been verified either. We'll you in the next video. The facility
in Great Falls is empty.
It's like, it's only about that. Well, we'll see that's for the overhead
cranes, but there's hardly any more people. They're the facility of
low field. You know, there's oil field skidders.
There's a lot of this. I don't know if you know all these places.
Nice. Ah. I'm researching hard to
be people that run trip reports,
you know. You come on, come on.
Anyway, place in Casper and I have no idea what they did that.
you Hey, I'm trying to
pull data from these facilities.
Like, who's been there when?
In the different parts of the complex,
I don't know what the language is about.
I don't know anything to say. I don't know what to say. I can
walk in or falls in it. Then I can see that so I can
either say, I now know what we can do here.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
I'm amazing, Bye.
Ten foot shear, ten foot prospect,
and then you have two stairs here and there, and they have this little
invitation name on. You can do their spare And they're not really
set up to do structural,
like, calls baby soon. The rest is what it is. We'll see you next
week. He's saying, you know, we say it all around in my house.
Okay. Oh, doesn't become any more of the sterling dust.
I know, but I don't think I
don't think so. They're trying to get to this point to where they're doing
one with the in-house. We're good at the joint.
One of these shops
have been in these states. Okay, so I think you and I have been
sold. all the time. very similar thing.
I just want to get in terms of where it's best and if I
can't find facility that we don't.
That's the best. They might be getting my day of time where we can
buy it out. It's not good. Okay.
I think we have a very similar question. But coming,
yours is coming for John Snow. Yeah,
mine's coming from Jeffrey. But I think that it's so neat.
You know, he's the same thing that John is a very bad actress.
Oh, really? Yeah, he's eating vocal.
He works from Paul, and he's here today. Oh,
he's here on Monday.
He'll be here on Thursday. I don't know. I wonder if you should do
anything. So he's my little boss.
. . . for a decade, we work,
uh, yeah.
shop is crumbling, uhm,
because most of us have left, because that's for whatever reason.
Some is rebuilding. Little bit. They've taken seven of our guys over there,
and they're putting up 65,000 square feet.
New facility. a little bit. One big time,
one big thanks,
one big special. Please get one of our girls personal service. You got it.
it. It's good. It's good. It's good.
Around this area of data, in most organized ways,
is still that. I have bad.
I have not been still bad. I've heard of it. But yeah. So you
know in this facility, but you guys are the next day of steel.
And yeah, I did not know that. Right,
guys, we're at next door. And the end is,
yeah, do the servo on the side. So we're right there.
And then we'll go. Okay. And then they move here.
A.S. deal has expanded. Yes,
they have. They've never done that, but.
But you have. A.S. deal with the people that upper level
benefit over the densities.
I've looked at that for sure. Yep,
I had the three big three about me.
. . . I give the power that the three had dragged, and then
me, and then brought up soon after me. And then I laughed at the
three, like most people were not stupid. this. They only lasted a year or
two. It's something along the door.
It's super scary. What I am being here,
they said. Yeah, yeah,
that's better.
And it's better.
just jump up then
on cusses where everybody will they go.
. And if there is, there it is now.
I think it's easier than that because I didn't knew that one.
It's not my head except for it. Let's see if it's your word.
That's great people. But this part is
the shot really, you know. You It is that it's really good.
It's made out of really good equipment.
One more week shot. Go. Yeah.
There can be one. Yeah.
One kitchen's going to be utility for them to build.
Yep. Yeah.
That's nice.
Yeah.
I heard this week that are up now in 800 times,
and I'm sure it'll flow a little bit. Okay, I'm gonna do that in
a minute. So, we're ready to quit. Let's- But I'm gonna add,
the candy house is based on the theme of opportunity.
And it's not a suitable- So you gotta add,
or you're a machine, you gotta offer a,
you know, a big bag. And, they have- and move them up here,
y'all have to say hello to us. You know,
that's the front of the head, but I wonder how many times you think
about any of the concerns. They're going pretty business.
Yeah. Well, the question is do all these shops stay
busy? Thank you.
It's really expanding because the semi-con has been talking about you money here.
Yeah. I think it's, that's a temporary thing.
I swear that I'm undivin' it.
You. It's- Umm.
For you,
it was actually releasing such a process. Okay,
that was an artist. is Well, good.
I didn't think it
was. Hey, my question. You said it's a terrible thing when they look at
that and change up these birds. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Good bye.
Good bye. Well, it only changed over more than loads,
so I mean, I can go into, uhm,
and- How about a kick
It's
fine, I love I'm sorry. No,
no, no, no, No,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Thank you, Mr. President. you Thank
you, Mr. President.
ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm.
ehm.
You
If you have to conclude, I won't Thank
you.
I didn't even know that.
Right, right over the corner from your house. I'm gonna try and stay there.
Stay in town now. It's you. Oh, that's just fine.
Bye. Thank you, George. I'm pretty good back here.
I don't need to ask myself. Heh, heh,
heh, heh, heh. That was it. It's
just having it spread out all the way except we just create some other
issues. Yeah. You Umm,
that's the main issue in Sydney in Brooklyn,
right? Yes, in Sydney or not?
Bye. Yeah.
Yeah.
And I'll see you in the next video. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm kidding, I'm pregnant.
. . . .
I think I have three addresses. Oh,
the same one. Oh, Well,
we're around one leg, leg, and I'm going to put this on the floor.
Yeah. That one's going to be fair enough that I'll do two of you.
See?
It's gonna be a little, I think, a lot of customers are going to
get out of the house. You know, it's gonna get out of time.
Yeah, but it doesn't usually sit there. You do.
Uh, uhh. It's gonna be. It's gonna be.
It's gonna it's gonna be. It's, uh,
unless you put time, be in the labor center. Thank you.
It's gonna be. It's gonna It's gonna be.
So
here you go with the lens on this camera. What? Look,
the sound is gonna last as loud as, you know, the rest of my-
I'd say I've seen it, but I had much to say otherwise,
and it's an operation today. But by the sound,
they've already attended a 50-gling. Thank Yeah,
it can work. I don't have facility either.
But, uh,
okay. Thank Uhh,
data center skids, you know, it was 40 billion.
And the option bar just was 10. But
this will work at least a few.
I'll show you it. Still work.
Uhh, the skits are immigration,
so the skits, the skits don't see jobs,
obviously the skits don't look as good.
But you really suck. Now that we've got our talks of mothers and adults
and veterans. That's what we want.
We're still like 30% nearly 30%.
It's all right.
Okay. I don't know what to say.
All right. You don't like to go on the pumps and all that stuff.
You know, uh, electrical, you know,
if it's certified and it's just basic.
Isn't it? Stuff. Yay.
So, if you burn on that and you burn on it,
that way I'm up. Oh. You know, your holes, uhm,
the cut, uhm, excuse me,
the punch. Thanks for watching. Really?
Hey, uhm, we need to go look at that.
So, go up to make the testing. And maybe,
later, right, it's, uhm, punch.
And due to the problem at the top,
the touch-pot statements, at the end.
Amen. Where do you want home storage?
And you say, oh, be basically a cat for the process and makes it
look like. Yeah. So then just chill.
Yeah. You even have punch mysterious,
you punch husband. Ah,
I didn't see any much. Any heat, you can exchange that time with a
luscious. They got cut and drilled.
It might be a pharma process. They're jammed.
It's, they need a site.
Good. The whole management, the whole management is going to be there.
And then it breaks you. You take what you want.
So, yeah, they're terminal.
very well. It is all over here or should. They need to change it.
I guess people serve soon to have all of them that are starting to
hear like, I don't- Punch it, man. Why don't you do the punch?
When you be into a drill, I'm uh,
I don't- know. It's not sitting in the air before- really touching.
So they get a drill as well. They good maintenance,
estimating labor maintenance and drill.
building. Same meal,
but I'm going to have to talk and drill talk about maintenance and change
rates. Thanks. Thank you.
Well, you can change it to, like,
it's all hard cutting. Yeah.
So, once you and your learning is not hard cutting.
Later. Thank you. Okay.
Yes. And
you know, here's what we've got to know.
Right. I've been on show about
this. .
So. So, uhh, uhh, hm. So, hm,
hm. So.
so I'm also to begin also to maintenance.
Umm, where do you go? Yeah,
the link. Umm, sure. I'm going to leave the link. its main. Uhh, it's
estimating labor maintenance labor.
Get a job out of the top of the labor maintenance
and m- So here's my other places where it is going
to be said. Clean goes- I'm going to ensure
that I know this. And here's what's
all splicing. Probably not being used,
but he came with a splice on his lip,
but it didn't, you know, on his You know what I Okay.
So, I don't think it'd be well,
but if it's placing things together, it would get something that's not correct,
but it would have been a beautiful, old display. What this place? A little.
But the front of the shot, it doesn't make sure the beam might have
to strike and put a spike to the moment. A spike wouldn't be well
enough if you don't have a ball. It's a lot of times I'm aiming
to be pulled into the field and it's escalating.
I'll show you where it is. See, see, you'll be better than before.
Don't come right back to labor maintenance,
splice. Uhh,
ehm, column splices. This is, So you can,
on a labor kit, you can say,
use this splice, this, I'm not used by the law,
and it's just a lot of average. So,
for your most people don't use it, yes. Thanks.
They don't put any material in themselves,
and they don't put labor to it. And the labor gets,
and most people don't use this, but, you know,
there it is. It
just doesn't give you a breakdown of what it is.
It's that kind of almost that hole. 3 4 4 3 It's that,
it's that actually putting it on there or what it is.
It's just doesn't give you a breakdown. So,
let's get cleaned up on these events. So,
that's it. .
I think we have clung med,
med, med. Alright. Okay. So
maybe we'll lay them down, then get us that hours for peace,
though. It's so,
. But I'm really trying to help you with people too much anyway,
but, erm, it's used too much,
but, I want to be with that.
I say I'm keeping my mother just because I know that we are blind
when somebody's ending your- I think we should have
you re-
in the corner of the right,
but it's uhm, so you can probably get back in to leave the other
ones now and- I
don't- I don't know what this is
today. I don't think again. I don't think- I'm going down four to five
in the morning is gonna start thinking about my Deerell March.
You know that's- And it's so,
So, to be fair.
All right.
Perfect.
Okay.
Okay. I don't
know if it's used
somewhere by the same. Thank you. Umm, ehm,
ehm, ehm,
ehm, It's
perseb Aurited, it is perseb Aurited,
crushed by forty two 20- bars.
Yeah,
I I'm trying to get the other facilities to say that.
The stuff is kind of unfair to the people at the most.
And yeah, look at that.
I think there is. Uh,
yeah, that is going to camber. Do you want that in camber and press
right here against,
It's good.
Camber's probably the thing that is to keep their honesty and camber tight together.
It'll be equals. We'll see you in a minute. Okay.
Just shy of the pencil. You may never use it.
So, because they look like just the client.
Time to pop in third bit. You know, actually,
we had just a little bit better because they used to be like the
energy from eight men. and most of our camera deals are working on more
than, you know, three hours. So if it's anything outside,
we have these in my machine. So I had some,
I mean, it would be over. It's a murky camera,
isn't it? Yep. Um, so the two hours is about to facilitate the monitor.
and then we'll see a few hours you want to sit. Yeah,
I'm about to go. It's not a statement. Twenty-five,
right, and then three years. We'll in the next one. Okay, good job.
Somebody else. I can't remember. You know, they're collecting dust and stuff.
I can't remember. It's a team.
We're about to be in flight. But,
uh, I'm at 48.
I have a stress break. Umm.
you Yeah,
this one
would probably be more on their fit.
Just because they're- I don't know if they're willing to be fit,
I don't know if they're fit,
Okay. We'll see I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know. Here's what I've been. It's on the circuit
and it's the key. Yeah, bending is definitely- It's me,
you know, and- sometimes I can be an argument, but there's been an evolving
is the same thing, but- Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, you
Well, we thought of good.
We put the first three time when we can, when we can, when This
really is an inherent workplace.
Uh, possibly generally, but after it's been the process.
And a lot of times, we need to be.
. . .
Yeah, I mean, we can keep it that way.
It's s for anyways.
Anyways, I'm,
Yeah, that's just gonna be another area where we
release it for handling cut fit well.
Go on. vern So,
you still have visibility to the time regardless of how you can make it.
Yeah. You know, it's not, it's not. Yeah.
So, yeah, instead,
you're running for a day to be.
You know, it's not.
Now, that was sort of a separate category, but it was to be in
the total one out. Oh.
Almost, and then from there, that's the fabrication
shop project miniatures expression.
Thanks watching! . . I'm going to write that guys to put this toy's
handling, because we took the time to put it here,
or ehm. You this is going to go to fit for tracking purposes,
and then you'll be with the operator, and then you'll be able to for
others to break the display. Later. This is your boat making your floorovers to
the end. And then I've been getting time tracking,
you know, add gnolls, break the rest of the-
So, gambling, uh,
it will have a burden. I can learn even more about this type of
location. Ehm, I can learn even more about gambling, too.
Okay, that's really good for gambling. Thank you for,
there's a lot of things to talk about.
It's right up here. Yeah. That's what, that's what I said.
I think that we're going to be achieving care, kind of, like,
all processes. Holes and cows,
and I'm going to get a code meeting with this. is Okay.
Yeah. I hate it fast.
We used to have a category fast and everybody put everything.
you Well, yeah, actually, they did, yeah.
And it was, yeah, then we went to fit up and,
well, that became confusing.
Thank you very much. It,
yeah, it depends on how you're going to shop. If you want to know.
Oh. Our fillers can dwell on our owners to fit it.
So. No.
As we moved away from the,
I have seen a lot of other figures.
I love that. You mmm, that was only kind of there,
right? I knew something freaked out for a deep minute.
You know what that is? I don't it.
This one I don't understand. I don't know how to do it in San
I've never done all that in this three-game opens.
Yeah, that was it.
That's not something that we're in traveling this election. Oh, that's, I mean, it
is. I love the food. I mean,
that's, that's just a weird one though. I don't think that's, it's all in
the mood. You it doesn't even make up for the,
for a way to give it the hospital. It's what it is.
Okay. It's, It is a cabin for a gal who doesn't cost.
And they, and this will be, like, uhm, uhm,
and be- Thanks watching!
So, that makes sense to me. And then they're just, so, move, we would
switch. with. You know, all of you guys run
a system that has galvanizing and pain.
Thank It's the job this year.
Me. I mean, a lot of that's great environments.
Great environments. Yeah.
Yeah. A lot. Heavy corrosion areas.
Things are just down there. They're just bad at the time. They're bad.
I'm not bad not bad at the time.
Yeah, I didn't know it. We made light calls,
same light call, we sent the same call.
Sometimes I was sent in a coastal city and then so the one guy,
I know how to analyze it,
that pain over it. Okay. Cause if someone looked pretty, they don't want that
galvanized. Yeah. Good. I
think everything else is good if people like it and others.
. . . And,
uhm,
shimmy. Bye!
.
So
what's going to happen when we change all these categories and we try to
run whole estimates through the area of the donut.
That two or don't have these categories. It's really important of this.
So if we look at all this, then we're going to spell out the
change. Thank you very So, uhm,
second I effect the labor because it will affect the buckets and holes in
the two yap. We're not going to explain that in a minute anyways.
Thanks. We're not changing labor.
I'm curious. We're not changing labor at how we're just redirecting more of that
labor. Yeah. All right. Thank you. It's a great day.
Thank you. It's still going to be there. Yeah. you
Yeah, I hear qrom does, what,
four estimates a week. Yeah.
It's about the number, the other guy. Bye.
Okay, good. Okay, have a voice.
Let's see how we can do that. Okay, have a good day.
Cheers. Thank you.
Alright. Mmm.
Nice. I love the rest of it. I think we can do it this
probably what the, uh,
how much of a piece of board will do. Yeah,
and then, you know, it's probably roll. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I'm not sure,
you know. It may be that the labor operation is a point to one,
and then, that's what the problem only is in the label.
We'll more. You know, we're not seeing the 15 or 16,
so one, one, one. Uh. This one's fine.
All right. It's fine. It's ok.
It's alright. And when you tell
it, I think you can fit it, while you do the video.
And paint. And that's,
that's probably all the wood,
uhh, arts and gear more.
Yeah, that could be something important to you. What,
that would be perfect. Uhh, yeah, I would say so. Okay.
instrumental.
I going to you for We'll see you if we're talking in the house
where he isn't about to see someone talk to him or talk to him.
I, I was just, I was just kind of.
He, he got him and then he would burn his own plate.
And that was gonna be my plug-in' down. So, okay,
I'll make sure I see it. Okay.
Are you here?
Let's take a
look at this. That's gonna get money real good.
really. Yes, for a reason, I see seven torch,
but that's cut time to do it into the detailed environment,
and then it's up to the email. No. The main goal is hope that,
uh, that all of that's gonna be under third.
You gotta find. So,
here. Okay. So,
uh, let's see which one is you.
. . If it's usually good, it's like, it's a mission first.
And again, it's operating. Alright. Yep.
And in operations, I have a lot of them.
And very good. Good. I'm a there. So it's usually a manual part of
the grade. What if that's what you're doing?
I'm, Umm,
get it to, let's say, get a layer of heads and see what you're
doing. Thank you. Play, labor,
codes are used and I'm gonna bet you, see if you'll land here.
No.
Like,
or write bits, and then, like, where can it happen?
That's it. You I always forget that this way,
and I just see you do this every time.
Yeah. Until the end of the- I'm frightened.
Okay, just go to the phone. We'll just have an hover over
that, and then I'll show you the,
uhm, the formula. If thickness is a grip.
. . Uh,
burn manual, son of a coach,
and the, and applying the shear easily exact so.
That's it. So if we report it,
we report the whole thing. Okay.
We'll get back So I guess the question is, do you want to use
a different burner rate for the codes?
And, Umm,
do that. I would definitely say so,
considering the hyperphenoming.
You are going to step operation to be going to run a significantly
faster burn rate than an operator out here with a,
in-torch, so. Yeah. Yeah,
that's good. Alright, okay.
So let's get a look at the burn pattern. Here go.
This is the main rate. It's a burning rate. Thank you very much.
So, problem we're gonna have,
so that's what the plate machine is using.
Yeah. . . Well, that's what the point machine is using right now.
Uhm, which, what it says is that the processor,
uhm. It's like it is 6-3,
so I'm gonna try and hit 6-3,
and then I'm gonna result like that. So I'm gonna turn it off.
And that's one thing we can,
uh, uhm, put it down in this for a few
years. Good. I, you know,
I don't know what you want to do here if you want to.
We could either change the plate to a different earth.
Or we can change the, uhh,
kind of be in a different part of that. Anything,
anything, you know, the biggest, the same. Thank much. I don't know,
all the magic is going to be faster than this. Umm,
get us some of that. Go I'm going
to be at best probably more realistic 3-plate machine.
And get an automatic. I'm having this.
It's like, it's like,
super fast. I love you now.
That might be actual. Show. Uh,
I have to turn it back. Yeah, it might be,
but it doesn't, it can't probably move into the hip before,
before the arch starts, right? It doesn't.
So, is there this would be,
2.
You
So
there's a boxy. Yeah. See ya.
Listen,
we're finally ready. Right. Share some videos that we've been looking for.
I mean, we'll be able to adjust.
Okay. Okay. I mean, I'm assuming that you're interested in it.
So I'm talking and staying engaged. And I'm not just getting in the middle
of the picture. I'm not in the middle of the picture.
I'm just going to get in the middle.
. Well, it's the 18 year.
This is a machine without the boiler. That's good.
Yeah. Yeah. Coria.
Mhm. Yeah, interested to create the E home.
I'm amazing at 75 and then you know what,
working at. It's. It's just burning and it's.
I'm worried that I'm fast because I don't think it's the accounting strategy like
he makes. . It's not, you know, the machine may actually burn that
fast, but it's not time to move the head over here.
you You're here, you're here. Yeah. Well,
I think there's, I mean,
the programs that calculate this take a lot of this.
Thank very much.
When you pick these test speeds, like, when you make a turn. Bye.
Depending on how you program, it slows the speed down as you cut the
arc, and it can cut the volume. Um. Thank much for watching.
Piers times are depending on what you're piercing.
You know, those drive a lot of, uhh.
. A lot of this. What the guy uses for consumables,
nutters, or vots. And see what I've heard.
You know, 10 inches per minute for quarter H.A.K.
That's 550 feet per hour.
And I'll find the most. . . . because people are running at,
they're good to see, but I have to go. I'ma have to sound better
music. Peace for all of us. Like that,
yeah. It's, uh, not gonna eat that.
Look and see what the, what the other machines were for,
for the reach. Thank you so What's the same,
uh, it's 5.5.
What's the same, uh, what do you mean I don't know?
Sure. Sorry.
Umm, but it looks like this or something.
Oh, we're putting in the base parts on it.
Umm, base parts. Umm. you There's plates,
cap plates, stippin'overs,
uhh, regressive plates.
So it looks as small as it's in the back. Yeah. Yeah.
I think it's the last part. I don't know if this is anything over
two-inch. We got it in that stuff. It's the only thing that's got this.
Your boss means it's a lot of nuts.
I don't know. I don't care if I follow those out because they were
too weak. We're learning the 96 by 240 in that table.
Yeah. Meals and plates from a 40 foot,
and they could purchase some with a belt or anything like that.
Yeah. So. I'm coming. It was,
uh, aint trying to find an intimate order plate at
40 foot, but should have a- You
. ehm, you know, we merge our root of the top,
and they are just, we might stop.
Mhm. They don't explain this to you in a second.
Thank you very Someone I'm gonna have to remember something and see if it
has to put pages for that.
Well, that's, that's probably still so longer than what you're really- I don't know,
but right now, maybe a little bit is a lot easier to use over
this, like, super short. So,
uh, at least that's why I'm not what you're saying.
Yeah. Yeah. And we can change our list,
too, right? You know, we can change our list rates.
We can make it match. I don't know if you can give you- I'm
not really sure where you want it to be done here,
but I don't know if you want to like and use the purpose and
say, let me get it. Well, happy- It's from being one quarter,
it's from being one eighth, from being the manager. I don't know if that's
what you want to do or, yeah.
Now- Well done. I mean, this week he gave me.
We came back a little after we started working, and I couldn't even walk.
We got all of this. I had to travel. I to travel.
I had to travel. Yeah, and here we have it.
What do you want to eat, or change your own savour?
But I don't want you to savour it properly.
Oh, my God. I think Sarah has,
at least closer to men and men,
really slow. Oh. They are automatically this.
That's the promise. That's one of the key brides that we can work on
today. So, ehm.
I'm going to send them back to see if you can evolve.
Yeah, and get us at least a lot closer than that.
Yeah. They won't really, uh, they won't really blame you.
No.
Okay, Okay, cool. We'll read from the manual to,
uhh, yeah, the burn. And we'll see
you two more that we keep up with them.
Burn, burn, keep it all up right there.
So you got the manual cover. Perfect. Okay, bye.
Bye.
Yeah. Unless I send it out. Yeah.
She's there the other day. I let the top burn. Thanks having me. We'll
take the manual and we'll form that to where we want to go in
with more of your hand, folks. Bye.
You So
that I would have, like, in case I named all that Spanish or something,
and even though the recreation I might change it as well.
Because that's what shouldn't have done to formulas.
And, uh, that, that way you can know what these rights are,
damn great. Alright. We're gonna have a look at this and,
Where do you change the rating? That's all that's gonna be said in the
name of God. Yeah. Good.
Alright,
so we'll have to do that helping. We gotta get back into the labor
case. We have to be right around here. Who's gonna be- I'm gonna do
the labor case. Change that formula for more,
umm, the cadm. So supporting that.
Yeah. That's similar rate rather than linear rate.
And so uncheck.
I'm gonna leave it, leave it. See if there's one below it.
Just run around and go ahead and hit one. Then we'll see if it's,
It's the same uh,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm. If you want to push more baby,
part of the day. You know,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm.
This one looks like a cat. Yes. Yeah,
so I wanted to create one for Barnes and,
uh, which is not a deal. See you later. I'm gonna go to the
dropout of the top. I'm gonna create this.
And I'm gonna find that for more of a little. I have made one
with five of it and this changed their heads.
See, I have made one with the bottom. Oh.
And then in the added operation formulas,
what you want to do. There. And just so much to
burn man. Get rid of that.
Can you hear me burn man? Bye bye.
I can't get rid of that whole thing there.
Yep, and then- Got operations down here.
Got the drop down. There you go.
Thank you. Get your tables in that operation.
Every good. So now we've got to be in there. So get okay.
While we're- I can hear it. Well that makes up that if you have
house-ended. Umm,
yeah. Yeah, because it's looking at- Yeah,
if we can share, share, they stop and pass it in the everyday room,
then as well as you're ready. So it's my bypass all the way from
you straight to the bar. Don't you? So, okay.
So it doesn't expect an argument after it else.
No. We put it at it,
yes. thank you. After the border was ended.
So, this one, this one, the other statements don't have an else and if
at the end. Bye. Bye, Tim.
It's, it's, it's gonna be good. Okay.
Umm, while we're here,
see the length. Thanks. This is what I was going to do about that
was roll and how it works in my vehicle.
The, the, the length formula- basically I said it's really,
it's really, it's really,
um, so you like that,
so you know. Umm,
yeah, you might need no chain cut or something,
you know, it's not necessarily going to be that same thing,
but, well I'll take the- do yourself a quick seat right there and then
just be time to do it. Put the p-ball as always,
cut the program. Do-do that to p- Yeah,
now I'm going to talk to you.
So then again then.
I love you. Basically the default is cut the print.
Yeah, yeah. Maybe do better to count that spine,
but that default is, Cut the print. Right.
Yeah. I would do the cut again.
But I say out of the box, and then he has work.
I'll bet you don't, I mean, you were saying that this is an isolated
site or use of this and I'm looking at it early and with the
line. No. Yeah, it's the first one to go.
Oh, we're doing it before we're getting base plates and all the small parts
of the garden and they run through it. Yeah,
so that makes sense. You might want to go ahead and change your- another
cheap form of this here. We have time for length. That won't work on
the easy time of the stream as well. Yeah, it's just- because then keep
getting back and we need to stay- I'm just afraid that you'll
get the same thing. good point. When we reach our literal step into our
track again. Yeah.
It should be new. Since April.
Yeah. this. It should be that bad and right dude,
just umm, got that. Okay, so you got both of those, but we added
the one at the bottom, right? But,
if you, if you wanted to- Get that bottom blue.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, I'm sorry. Go get it. Alright, we'll see you
You might not believe that,
that might be, you won't have to struggle when you get a fix,
all this, you know how to change. Thank
Right, care about the most terrible. Uhh,
uhh, uhh,
uhh, uhh, hm, hm, hm, hm,
hm. . . Yeah, you hit me while the labor rate can not be
cheap. Just gonna go
up. Thanks. But you don't want to realize the most sort of union.
I'm sorry if you like that. So you can get in. can't do And
that's I'm that I've been here. Okay, so do it. You
gotta be. You
You gotta be. See you I'm gonna
give you this.
Yeah, that's fine.
Bye-bye. That's true. Let's go. I think.
You don't need one. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you. And
I'm gonna imagine that's still gonna be slow.
But. you There are no more.
Actually, I'm gonna be shaking it down a lot.
All right.
We'll see you bit later. Because it was usually with the like,
at the very slow. Oh, yeah. I don't know what you want.
So I'm gonna sit on that with. Good.
With, um, student, uh, so,
I don't know what I but I mean, I think it's,
I mean, it'll be accurate.
Yeah. Yeah. It's more and more accurate.
Thank you. Don't
you dare- It's
being done. Good.
This
is why I know they're so person aggressive.
I can't always have any of that in my opinion that it's so person
aggressive. Thank you. If
you don't make one system up more easily, you should know.
Yeah. Thank you.
Let
me pull this out and do this. .
Want all the estimates that are,
that have you been there to be what they were when we,
we would need to be able to let it out. You know,
little bit of labor are happy about it.
So, you know, even the labor are happy and Monday or something, so it's
true. Must be a lot. Bye. and after the last
video, I was like,
oh, uhh,
I think, and I think, then,
I don't think this has been as far as, you know, you should be
able to use. I this video.
Have a I'm going to Bye. I'm just looking at it.
So, so that's good.
Oh. Oh, You need to see it right,
and you're doing it all in a little bit from the water filter.
.
Go
ahead and order the vote to shut up.
I'm trying to do this a little bit.
So the farmer makes the cut. Bye. Yeah.
I think she must have said, uh,
on new work habits. Let us know the comments below.
He's really about,
basically saying he said, gospel hatred. Ha ha ha ha ha I
like to drink. What did you tell me to drink?
I didn't. Ah. Uh,
yeah, I was thinking that the database was all only a thing.
I don't have a chance to test it. I won't be able to do
this. Uh. . I'm not trying to mess up with that for.
Obviously, you didn't get any loot, because you used to sell it.
Ah, yep. Now I wish I had a good time serving for everyone.
Eww. I'll pick the hell up.
Eams. See you in a video of that. That'll make you come early and
you'll find me to be lost inside the chicken. Yeah.
Yeah. That's what we are for sittin'
in this. Yes.
Last day of the night, at the facility, the last day of the dispute.
See you next time. Yeah,
so that's what I'm supposed to be doing in this room.
That was like, there's one in the environment, a lot of them. There's the-
environment, a lot of them. But that's a separate term.
Seven. That's why I think Chris is mine.
We have one. the ah, so I was like a secret,
but we had one yard that was a
piece of- Oh, the was digging into something that we were weak on.
He would take that now, you know, they'd rather trim a bit of stuff
than- Just abbreviate to- I don't know.
He's a hot black man. Come on.
Okay, we have to- And I see- And I see- and- Alright,
okay. Come on, I have to- See you guys soon.
And I feel not every one of you that can't even do something unless
you're next already like, why are you doing that?
So I can- You gotta- Don't let me do it. But,
it didn't, it didn't, it didn't repair, it didn't consist.
Why it's been two other extemements.
And I probably changed,
uhm, one of,
one of them is, kind of, for one view,
one is going to purify the appeal. You know, they could,
they could profit change, but. Yeah,
one's other, someone's other.
No. I think it will,
it should be one point to that hours for peace deal and then I
think the other one is- Let's come in front of all the- the bigger
operations that say other. We'll get it
solid and make it one new. Thank you very much. They changed the label
more, so we know which label is which. Alright,
it's alright. Biggest thing in heaven. Good.
Umm,
I swear to you, this, uh,
says that the group certainly leaves. F*** you.
F*** you. I can't have a lot of- Tell me where there was a
woman who couldn't. I think it's something that I actually had a prescription,
which honestly didn't. And,
. It just
in. Yep.
That's fine. Bye.
So it might be the same thing.
I was so very careful. If investigation,
that would be beautiful.
Thank you.
And the other guy didn't increase my height. He increased my height.
He didn't increase my height. So,
yeah. But wasn't he,
uh, he was 140 feet,
uh, where we also had an 18-bit.
Good. Good. So,
which was close to,
uh, close to under that.
Good. Okay.
. started
me.
You
The sun's just got that,
that's pretty sweet and cold and everything.
Okay.
I don't know if you're a super offensive,
or if you can. I what it is is we just figured out that
since we're not pushing our projects over and trying
to sync all of our stuff. Umm, we can now be at the minimum
of planning and still do small asking.
the board . . And proposals and changes and stuff inside of this is
someone that you are using in your system, uhh,
but for a while there is space that- I'm really into some literal state
of church, like, you know, serious cash,
but it's not well in here. I'm scared.
If I didn't use it for us to close it and stuff,
yeah, it was a tackle and get rid of it.
Yeah. So, if you like it.
I began to describe the games here so that I can support it over
the phone. Yes. Yeah.
Yeah.
So I understand what they're facing this out. So if you don't have access
to the local treasury of the system. Oh,
so don't you? Tell me next. So what is the new system,
Joseph? Umm, the new system is to not understanding how you build it.
And it's gonna be, Whether they're in a base in and in a candidate
proposals in general, 100% investigating experience.
It's a cackler, and you can get it in for courses on anything for
games. So, it's not like it's going to be a cackler,
heavy bed, heavy work. Oh.
Oh. Yeah.
Do not want us to be continuing on this,
but, I mean, up until,
like, last week, this awesome revolution,
Nashville. So, they clearly have made changes in here,
and now this is all of them. This is actually reflecting that you can
by generating the whole amount of shows along early in the year,
uh, the tutorials. Just last week when I j- I mean,
the proposal for a day that I submitted, did what I saw.
It was good for you. You can have a good place at the time.
You can add. Yeah. Well, maybe it's every now and then.
Zero, six, zero, nine. What's the difference?
What's the- What's the difference?
What's the
difference? Uhh, okay. I guess it's kind of the same. Similar software that says
a different structure to it. Um,
this was set up with everything.
your name. Being overhead,
structured, built into your numbers.
Heavy is very, overhead. head.
It has its own mind and it's... and broke it out a lot.
Very, each labor I've distracted its own extent.
Thank slide. So a lot more visibility for everything,
not support, whereas this has a lot of unknowns,
one can do this with what we know covers.
So this heavy band is important,
uh, yeah. Yeah,
heavy band is just really, uhm,
they have a little bit of a I need it to do their field
take offs and do all that and stuff in there.
Umm, or you can do something similar in there,
but having it as a lot more of, uh,
all on your tutors and processes. But it's,
it's not, it's not,
it's not step. Okay,
so then it really, it's heavy, dude. You actually.
Yeah. This is important.
Yeah. And since. Yeah,
so I. Bye. Yeah,
this one,
we went in 150 hours. Well, I mean, I still.
You Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Okay. I don't know if it's the same. Thank
you.
Yes. Yeah. So,
and what I plugged in for eight was seventy hours.
We'll see you So,
wings pretty close, and fair,
it is slightly different. We're
helping with people in mind to obtain with,
uhh, what we put in the rate.
Great. without considering the
efficiency. So I can put that at a home really- Thank you,
bye. I can't believe that. You're simply-ish.
So you kinda gotta figure out what to do there.
There. So
efficiency what, docks to, hours or docks to dollars?
dollars. So if it's at 90%
efficiency what it does,
it takes the cap. The calculation of the hours divides by .9 to .9.
So, that's officially
part of the- I don't know where I'm at, it's just going
to be. So, umm, to me, the-the next biggest concern- So.
Yeah, I know the trouble I
always would be in use from here typically if I'm out of a second.
Good, good, But it's telling me where to serve you then.
So we need to do that. We're that distribution when I was in here.
And a lot of times if I'm not completely loaded up or something. I'm
back and start. If they didn't use that one to do it,
I'll have a link around the last minute so that there's something in here.
You that has this breakout. Yeah,
it was of this point. It was all in some independent and general of
the category that they had here. So,
now this has worked out a way that my form is requesting the
information that he gave into me. Yeah. And,
uh, I think it's going to be a fair cause of beneficial.
I think I've heard it yesterday before.
Wait a little bit, it's almost time to be here. . So the ratio
of hearing, I think that's why there is the ratio between fit up and
well, is never right coming out of the tackle.
And you gotta make the adjustments to take it.
Well, it's time to move it to the fit out time.
Yeah, I think I was- I heard something bad, yeah.
Uh, uh, let's have a look right at this,
uh, when I especially in this little situation- Thank you.
I that it's a real worry. And now you can see this change
work program here. If this will stop,
can't even- You I mean, yeah,
he's safer, I have him. Yeah,
I mean work as a field. I think it's their field instructions. Yeah,
thanks for watching. Yeah, Yeah. What are they using? Period.
You say here at the library, we're at this facility,
not involved. Oh. So,
in love, I've got no idea. Oh, no. They're just going to have to
have pensive. Yeah. That's We did it for estimating.
Okay. Just, what, what,
what was the field that occurred in the software?
Umm, yes.
Yes. Just, I'm not sure over there,
everyone's been honest. I've heard of this work,
but I don't know who I heard it from again and we've been meeting
with you this year. I changed so much.
So, uhm. Yeah, so this.
Yes.
This is the ASM in Jackbun. This is what it's about to be your
new strip floor. I'll see you one.
You know, a hundred and fifty hours will be estimated for this originally.
And this was the manual break-up.
That was put together on this. And then,
this is what we have.
So. Thank you. Well,
my question then would be.
you That's right.
And, eh, it's, it's gonna be
fresh. Thank you very If we can adjust it a little
bit, it's just a little bit, what,
what did you grab? Like, are they,
are they, and I'm assuming Mark's uh,
doing this person. Yeah.
it. So, it is that,
um.
It was also a new person. So, But, as you can see,
we can see, well,
as close as it is.
And No, no, no, no. We're going to expose what is
going on. That's, uh, so 20-30.
What's happening? What's happening?
What's happening?
Yeah. That's like, I've never done this to anybody.
I've never done that to anybody. I've never done And even until,
You know, back in you That's it.
That's, ,swips just like that to you.
So you're right. I should see where the differences are again.
I can see the reason you want to, I'm not going 100% because
you're like, well, I'm not going to take speed out.
And then you make the adjustments. Thanks. Thank you.
You run over 75% we want to get that number closer.
But estimating at the lower rate,
that's it. Just adds another tweaking factor in.
So, a little bit closer. Thank you.
But, it will also say, no one reminds a public channel or something.
And the problem is, listen, one day or another.
One day there was a building six lines that were on one day and
they were building a little room. And then over the next day they were
throwing boxes at me and next. And then the next. Thanks. Okay, we're gonna
start from comming with the exit, and in the effort that we like,
we might have said, it officially has to be more.
It's going to help all the work. You know, you don't have a really
good system going, and one thing, you get your thoughts a little bit.
Yeah, thank you. I did 75%.
I can't get way out of here. Looks like he's over
here, Carlos. Release. 8 People,
uh, people are putting on something that's really just meant to be here for
all this discussion. question.
So it looks like you're using the basic breakdown, so I'm already in that.
But he's redistributing fit up and whaling,
redistributing, handling it cut.
Cause the fit up whaling- is essential with it on both the tunnels and
both are essentially the same amount. Yeah.
So it looks like he's redistributing it. I'm going this group,
you mean it? Excuse me? Umm,
I'm going to be it. Let's see what the difference in the word is.
There are a few years to like that. Sixty-one fours you've done for,
uh, no hours. The bottom one in the center.
Mm-hmm. . It's a big life.
It's a life. It's about 120.
Oh. Cause you got 61 and 35.
That's 100. 119.
Told me. We got 40% of the difference in weight.
I'll go and get and go back. I'm doing the power fabric work.
You're up to maintenance, uh,
estimating the weight of maintenance.
And you're up. One-fifth
of the action. One-fifth is the December when we saw the job before.
It was one night scene. And there was that outreach.
That's why I've never seen that do. You're at the Bill and Will manual
quarter hitch. Okay.
To get 6.3. So,
I consider this way that that's why I was looking at 40% of the
difference. I consider this way.
40% is what I usually will see in the right per hour around came
to loyalty. So, the pancake is around 40%.
Uh, uh, 40% difference.
So, uh,
yeah, I'm wondering if we change.
It's not going to stay this up.
Now you're way out of time so it will come down.
Then we'll be in the week and we'll read and share to you. Thank
you. You
guys need to be like all of us. You just change your order next
one and make the other ones go. Yeah,
alright. That, out of the box,
the, the, if you put a, uhm, a field middle or something,
out of the box you just don't control it. I wish you all a
little bit. So,
uhm,
we can change those, those, you and that language and see where it gives
and, yeah, you, you sort of, So,
so let me ask you this, when, when this calculation happens for quarter inch,
they'll run a single pass publicly. Welcome.
Yeah, depending on the type of world,
we hear it corners, we say there are more of compasses.
But, it really is. So,
how does the math go in?
You're just looking at the right. It's not big. . It's gonna be right,
but it's gonna extrapolate against the length. It's gonna hold by and by the
length. So if you put, uh, let's, let's take some,
let's, let's. My rate is five feet per hour for three days.
That's what I don't have to shoot at. I know guys can go faster
than that. But that's just the estimating rate for a three-cast level.
When it's half-inch, you're gonna do six-mass.
We'll the next one. Whatever five minutes.
In the corner each group, I'm used to seeing as Ken put,
and you can wail a whole lot faster than that up.
Go. Honestly, that's one,
that's where the most people are being put in that language for estimating
purposes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Of course, you got to figure out,
you know, what she put in that again. That's a lot of time.
What is, what is that, the system?
What does it do to see her? The machine,
uh, sure, is not going to be an example.
I'm going to take a stakeboard on that paper,
so I'm going to have a similar game. Anyway, good So so. Thank you.
Yeah, so, uhm,
that's an interesting thing about your main book,
right? Do you want yes,
that you're going to make a- I don't know if,
uhm, obviously it's what it would be wanting to be. Okay,
well that's it. Cause like, we could get to see if we're going to
get that something Okay, what's the pattern in the stitch right?
Yeah, it's right. Yeah. That's what it means.
It's just a right. Now I've built stitch for it.
That's what it's going paper patterns. Umm,
but all it is is just a right.
So consider what you want. You have to consider.
I can Good. You have Maybe you'll be,
uh, you have to, uh, for God willing if I wanted to.
I'm just hoping you'll never even want to. I'm not taking the process here.
If. Kind of flip
flat. Okay. Uh,
when you probably won't be on your main shop, cause that's the one that,
that your needs are right. Bye. Uh,
which, which main, uh, I guess,
uh, I was thinking, not clear, I was thinking back.
This is the one that we had last time you were here so that
we could speak numbers.
You can be looking around. Ah,
so, we're back in the answer, we'll be back in a minute.
Yeah, I don't wanna know what to be used to best. Yes, yes, That's
the name. Yeah, me,
that's the one to change.
Thank you. So,
did we want it there? Thank you. I didn't go to, uhm,
three eights, put in your, what did you say? I asked you to say
anything. That's right,
I actually have much slower. or if yeah.
It's just whatever is the standard here.
I'm used to using five feet or no. I did. in you want to
do, like, five, six feet, somewhere in between there,
the calendar. Hey,
jesus. So, take it back and fix the money.
Bye Thanks, too.
Bye. Yeah.
So,
so what happens is, you know, you ask me if I'm not gonna sell
it. But when you guys do these beams,
these built-ups, and now you go from an annual
process, so. Just. A mark. At the estimating state,
would they ever do that, or in the future,
will they do that, or is it gonna have a.
you sub arc, or sub arc is still encapsulated within well.
Cause I know me, right? I'm for data, I'm creating a government.
Are you guys able to- You're going to use them a lot,
and we're going to have to get it down the lane. But I don't
really know what to say. I wouldn't do it yet, so yeah.
If I- I don't really think it, because we know that when we weld
some work on a boom, we know the machine can do 20- inches of
minute. But we know,
uh, and it's a two pass weld for us all the way up to
half inch. Thank much.
Inside, outside, two pass weld are done.
You know. Yeah, and nothing was more of the,
uh. and We don't think I'm gonna date right now to,
because you did one job and you couldn't do it.
But if you start up doing some work welding longer.
Yeah. You need to deal with that,
because that's not something. I'm gonna be sharp most and we'll be laying up
to get you up with what the assembly was.
They were working on the shot done, but they,
they won the shot. Yeah,
I didn't deal with it out there. It's too dandy.
There you go. But they, they, when it came down,
they, they, they, they saw it, and it was the same thing as about
getting it. If, where you got to go? . Like this,
or if you guys were bawling it, like this,
or showing me that. Like this? Yeah. And Yeah,
it's important to bring one way back.
It's important. So, and then we're lagging about.
One and, and meaning,
uhm, evenly, that's a two minute round.
So, uhm, bye.
What do you do? What do you do?
Why do you gotta find everything in the table and see if I can
see.
That's the most terrible thing on the air. In this channel,
it's a kind thing. Yeah. Oh my god.
Cheers. Thank very much.
At least there's four or five of them at all.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, and those ones are uhm,
How many of them have been out for? They've done a little bit.
We've actually got 10 foot, 5, 16,
8, 6. It creates 5 foot.
Then, How about 3, 16, 10,
1, 8? 3, 16, 8, what's with them? 7,
2, 1.
I'm out of 7, 10,
1, 8. Yeah,
and we've got to support him. Yeah,
it was not him. Yeah.
Go ahead.
Oh, I have to check, you know, I guess they should have gotten that
done by speaking to the program. Ah,
but having them do it, or is that going to be better or something?
. And, uh,
creates a half inch. Yeah, you know that way,
so you can come here a little bit, and well, it's later on.
And now, I'm go. You've got to do that, uhm.
And then some people are going to be to get a single vowel and
a double vowel. Yeah. Thank Yeah,
I mean, like I said, you can not be able to touch it any
minute and skip the vowel vowel.
Alright, so leave. Brock the way of demoing down the finger
when you do that. So, the question is how.
And of the video.
Okay, where do we want that to be,
what we're saying?
Good. Just,
uh, and we'll spend everything on this.
Going to feather. We will just. I'll you in the
other one. It's the biggest, easiest thing to do.
Yeah, what we have. and uhh,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm.
. . ,-hm. Yeah,
out between all this. We're kind of in just each level.ized dio sir.
They're facing the port for two percent. Yeah.
No. Wasn't trying to see what it does.
Thanks for watching.
Oh,
oh, oh. I don't understand who's in India.
I haven't been for shots,
education, as many as well,
or just for a few. Um, they have.
They have. It's just,
it's a morn. Always worth their risk,
across the morn. You're different at all, and it's like this,
you know. Good stuff. Well,
mischacement. Yep.
That's not the one I'm just chasing. Jason,
so. You remember how to,
well, I'm not doing this a lot of times here. He may have been
on purpose of material.
Umm, I don't think you remember needing
to, well, wait a minute, I don't think you should remember.
I love it. It's what's going on with fear. Umm,
I guess the bloody outside is going to be on Yes.
This is what I like.
Either, you know, there's a- nay,
I can hear from any more questions at the mouth,
sure. Good. Umm,
ehm, You
Yeah, I'll lay it up and check stuff.
I'm just gonna deal with you being with Ginger. Change.
Let me go over here.
Heh heh. So.
So. Heh,
heh, heh, heh, heh. Thank Bye.
Uhh, uhh, uhh, hmmm,
hmmm. Good luck. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye. I'll
take those. I have one doing this, but it's alright.
Yeah, I think they hate it. I have it.
I'm glad that we'll see on break. Oh,
yeah, it's time for you to learn how much. Yeah,
I think it's all right. See ya. I said no.
Yeah. There's about five bucks at the last time. Yeah, you're doing fine.
Yeah. Yeah. Sir, I'm just kidding.
I thought I meant something. Somebody to change.
Thanks for watching.
And I'll see you I'm so mean.
It's a year old.
Why is that? That's Well,
that's, uhm,
bad at him, you know, he's so bad at me. That's it I'm just
gonna be in the street. Well,
the punch he can be helping him get up. But Mr.
Paul was in the A and that's why I considered it. . .
Am I just a man boy?
Forget about this. I don't know what to do with.
You Yeah, thank you.
I'm a cripple of a lot of calculator.
Heh heh heh. Have a good night.
I'm pretty good at that.
Thank you. . 6.
Why not? You've been pointing for 3 cents,
7, 10 things. Thanks,
Ellen. You're okay. I'm okay.
I'm okay. Thank you. I'm
okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay.
No, no, no. Thank Boosted him to doubt.
The chicken ain't here to get.
Yeah, that's I
don't even know what l- We'll you in
a minute.
Bye Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, we're going kind of against the
Sam. We're looking at one,
and we're going to look at 136.
What's that? Let's see if we have Uuuh,
with 136. space.
Was Mark gonna give me even budget points?
Was Mark gonna give me much jobs? I'm gonna give you
some of them too or not. I- I almost got a half-boy.
You I don't
have to worry more about it. I have to be glad that it shows
that I didn't point it out and I definitely didn't want it to be.
But it'd be okay be honest, like, it looks
alright. I bet she's down.
I bet she's down. Okay, we can get back to my turn.
. You guys are white at one of us here,
if you want to daily, go back to the job today.
We'll see if it comes out. Right?
You get this out of your belly. Every single job,
every single release says your file for the reason.
Yes, we'll get it back in check. Much of it is.
Yeah. See,
by the way, the second you have to check out the two variables because-
I have a feeling that Mark is correct saying,
ehm, you'll be better, because yeah, they're gonna be changed.
That's why they came out of exactly the same. It's a reason to modify
Bye bye. I know, so it's gotta go back up a little. Yeah. Thank
you. We're it Alright.
I'm feeling now, I think, one of the three tech, uh,
we're building into the masterful servers.
Right? Yeah. Thank you.
I'm gonna die. Okay. Thank
Now we're going to just assist,
and just, just shoot. A lot of times,
it takes a lot of time to do this on this community.
Thank
you. It's time to do. Yeah. Yeah.
It's
all good. Good. Hmmm,
hmmm, hmmm, hmmm.
Be giving something harder to do. That's what we got.
We did. Good. I
just gotta give this damn thing a run for two weeks. Look at that.
I'm to avoid We've to do We've got just
to grab a weave. And we're sure like that.
That's it. I'm not company.
It's NASA base at the time.
And I want more of a little
weight loss thing.
It's, okay. All of this,
ah. You have to be single to me. I mean, that's two.
Uh, it's Tuesday. I'd like,
uh, any top bars. Uh. Uh. Cheap here.
That's nice. That's great. Yeah,
it's Paris. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So that's it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Please don't go ahead, I was looking to be glad. If
you're not listening to me, there's a problem where I can respond.
I know what. Umm, yeah, it's over there and everything else.
I it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. My brother-in-law at the Umm,
uhh, shamed family, so he all won't be selected.
You guys, shamed. We'll see you We'll see you in a minute.
Now, we'll even just holler there. I'll tune the spice.
Yeah. Okay. Okay.
Alright. you
That's a lot of pink,
didn't mean to do that. That's a lot of It's a lot of pink.
It's lot of pink. It's a 75% of pink on me,
man, everyone. Thanks.
Thanks.
It's a 75% of the earth,
man. It's done, man. Let's go up one,
aye. Aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, good one. Thank .
Is it because? I don't think anybody runs
behind me standing fishing, and I think, I mean,
I understand what you're-
I don't know what it actually takes, but I get that. Yeah.
If we, if we had time settings and we knew all of these were
real, then I would agree with you that you'd be able to want them.
But, I don't know. I don't know. I don't believe we have the right
time to check. I agree with you.
So until we get to the right steps, it is in my opinion not
to be more likely to know. Yeah, so one of the things I would
do in a lot of times is, let's say my employees were busy.
Yeah, I would start at,
I was having contingency because I knew that other crews were not as fast
in my age. Yeah, I mean, you know. There's so many ways
to- It is. Yeah. It's just one of the main twins in the background.
I think they're actually another one of the kids. Yeah.
Good.
I also could keep the
shot on it on your tire. Uhh,
simply put it 45 and 50. You're official,
yeah. Once we've got over 52 hours a week,
then we're going to drive them off. Then we're going to cover the cones.
you have to stand around wondering where you're at with your
time. That's the crazy. So that's a pretty,
It's really, really good. I encourage you guys to go for a three-user
call. I always work at seven-year-years.
Cheers. We need to try and push back inches out to the shop program
you're purchasing, and the shop works in seventy-eight.
You know, we were always busy,
always ever coming in, you know,
and there's, I mean,
that's the- the nurses are warning shopping,
they work to us supporting the field with anything and everything that they need
it. Always busy.
And now it's, I mean,
it's all changed. It,
I guess, it doesn't, uhh, it doesn't, uhh. you doesn't support us really as
much as they used to. Umm,
most of them are opportunities and you're able to go this week as
the day or when we get it at all.
So what are they going to mean? I hear that they want to keep
our ministers doing what's best to make sure they're waiting.
Yeah. Wait a minute, are they low? Or are we just chasing along when
we're working? Umm, that could be,
that could be- But a lot of the work we're looking at,
we're, I think, so that's our labor rates,
too. You cause they're charging big child rates,
and we don't have big child with it,
and then we end up having to put your own hair.
We could warm our hair into,
which is selling things out in heaven,
and then me trying to get a look off of that in the budget,
and then, And a lot of times I'll detect hours,
because obviously we want it more efficient,
so I'll attack that for my later, and,
reduce my labor hours and take that extra money and put it towards the
sub-application bucket. They're not always considering that.
And so, That's where it is sometimes for work.
And, uhm, but also all of the,
the back of the- the work that we've gotten this year has been stuff
that we even want the video. I mean,
it's a lot of the stuff that we would not get- It's the background
you've said the estimates about it, you know.
Part of the thing that we've got is we've been here since,
before, you've been. I'm the umm, I think they are just
as many as they were, but it's a mixture now because they've got some.
Some of the guys who are going to structure will do an actual estimates
because order inevitably become an electrical company because they're so incredible in that.
then of there. And so,
that, uhm, just feels like they're focused at a completely different
area and they don't get- snew me in the window because there's
so much more over there, there's so much more.
Yeah, that goes into the shot.
No. No. That's gonna be great. So, and that's,
thank you. Are we gonna leave the application or-
ehm. Sound of this land and give the money well for more custom miscellaneous
work that other trades don't want to do.
So, like- It's data science. I got tons of miscellaneous in a business.
We call it more difficult than average miscellaneous. It's not building- We'll see you
the next thing. Draft games and ladders.
You know, it's really custom miscellaneous work at other shops.
They're just afraid to do it. You know.
Yeah, so the sun picked up the skittest.
It was 92 skittest. Yeah.
It was $40 million worth of work. It has the other shops.
Well, there's skitt shops out there now.
They were full. And some of it never goes- But the
cave guys that came over there were used to building skits.
Yeah. So, they went over to the- And all they're
going to be doing is assembling.
Cause they're going to- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. They're going to have some unique weapons. There's
just a supply of that part to the assembly. With all our fusion modeling.
Okay. So, fusion will- I don't know the question.
They're buying you to get out of us.
Hmm. We're done? Yeah. Three points. way right . . Way to work.
Uh.
thank
you a lot. Bye bye. Thank you for what?
We're gonna need to hold the line. Hey guys,
I think it's easier around my- Thank you. Otherwise,
it's a mixed message coming up there. I think we need that.
Yeah. Eh,
I think we'll be possible. Yeah, I think we're almost instructional starting
with a kind of tank, stuff like,
see it, it's gonna like, yeah. Good. I mean,
I'm not in the short field of miscellaneous stuff,
you know, that's my favorite tank. That's what I'm telling,
what I'm kind of saying is, datac- .
Yeah, and the interesting part of datacenter is
actually how they're going to give them power.
Upward. Because you have no power for datacenter,
it's just going to raise a vision bell. So they're trying to converse up,
you know, paper tooling and building copper. To stop datacenter
build out for a year until they figure out how to deal with.
Chirps, power,
and water. Cause the whole country is us,
it's our website. It's on the play,
I think. Yeah.
Later.
And so I think that these data-centered people are a realized data,
but if they don't, you know,
they can't jack up people's order. And they're getting unpopular,
right? I don't know if you guys know this through
power bill. I don't know when I'm 20%.
17 22 18 18 I'm personally, I guess, uh, old,
I bought a house that was a brand-father into the solar
system. Sorry. Oh, there you go. And if I had to re-play,
I had to re-do all the solar panels because it was so old.
But because I was a brand-father in, I got to go- .
So mine haven't got enough. I'm friendly,
so you can be covered by a life disorder and just be a third
person, not to speak again. But if you're not honest.
We'll see you time. Yeah, that is the crew again.
Twenty percent increase in the number. I don't know,
I'm not going to change. Let me... But there is no incorporation of commission,
which regulates that, allowed power companies to increase the raise them up in a
minute. 3-7-6,
without addition. Thank you. But I am not,
not, uh, 3-7, without-7-6.
Okay. I'm doing it. Yeah. But I think- Thanks.
We're not there. We're not there. We've got to go after this.
We'll see. Some parts are going in 3-8.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm still getting my feet wet.
Until it says train last week, train this week.
You have to make the estimates.
I, I, I, I, I actually thought they were gonna leave their balls this
week. Did you do it, okay?
I'm still getting emails. I'll it back.
I'm so grateful. Yeah, I mean, it's,
I'm trying to figure those out. I've to figure a couple of them in
this morning and allow them to determine,
uh, the programs that, like,
every day that I have no idea that I've heard of the program I've
ever used, and so I'm gonna have to learn how to use that,
I guess. Some of them are not giving you access to it because the
license cost is too much. Yeah. Like,
to me, sales for more. You what I would like to solve the opportunities
we're looking at. Yeah. Sorry.
There's a small job that's worth looking at that,
uh, it's probably gonna be one for,
uh, a nine. I'm sorry.
And I get to look at the tackle side of the hand that had
been side of it, cause I'm not really able to advise it if I
was sitting in on it. Oh, yeah. He's like,
you know, he's like, man, change is so fast and I can't even keep
up with him. But he took a few things in the- He's like,
oh, is that real? Didn't seem like he'd move that
much stuff out. Oh.
Yeah,
I didn't sit there.
I didn't work here. Thank you. Thank you. Two years and then he went
out to his office and came back.
I've been here a long time to see all of the G's.
Please. He said he could come and go back and forth so he could
get it from there. All right. Well,
we did play big too, but the angle and the brush.
Thank you very
You're in
here. Yes, yes. I'm cheering you up.
Yeah. Oh please, that's all I was thinking. Yeah, I'm sweet. The bad thing
is, you when you go, they might be evaluated at the site.
Not right there, we need to bump it up a little bit.
Hey, I can't even say it again.
I'll say. I'll say I'll be really good
at adjusting and pushing later. Yeah.
Yeah. Great. Look what you can type.
I can say this. Alright. Pup. What you type is.
Manager advanced application. Manager,
they're not been answered. It's, it's,
it's. You
I
don't see the plan, you know,
where to come back. I think
we'll tell, right? We'll see.
I don't know what I'd like to do, but I just don't think that's
where I'm sitting. Get up with I
understand that it's pretty big, okay?
Well, we're coming out, and they finally got set up,
and it's been looking for, uh, a second.
I'll get to that right in the day tomorrow,
if you'll do it. Must keep? Yeah. Getting in came
from the Sun in the day. Yeah,
I tried to do sales force,
and the sales force was a no. Hello.
It was a nice camera.
Chris Keller is not in trouble,
so he don't. Yeah. You isn't that how to estimate it?
Oh, okay. They send an email to him and say,
uh, request to you, Kevin. Okay. That's it. Okay.
1.14.
The piece they have left me.
You It's just, it's just here.
He's not settled, but he used to, in my mind,
he used to go for it. Alright, see you time. You They're going to
now. Yeah. You know
a lot of people here are going to be obviously with some people.
Yeah. Bye-bye. No. So long, that's made of this week.
Okay. Good. Thank you.
There's one of the things I tried to figure out.
I like, who are the real people in the platforms?
Who's the guy? The information I bought. Yeah.
Thank you.
It
just said that, that's the team that asked him a question that came and
resolved it. Okay. Okay. Well, I, uh, I said,
if you wait for me, but I, uh, have very much.
He sat at my desk for, uh, fifteen nights and a thousand.
Just a bit, just a little bit. Thank
you.
And so Jeff sent it to me and
Jesse Johnson. So Jesse Johnson
wasn't willing to take care of me. It didn't work, I guess. Oh.
Now we're going All All right.
Thank you very much. Thank Okay.
I'm honestly weak to that thing, so.
Yeah, that's fine. I swear if you aren't,
take a little
I don't know, I don't think this text is even,
I don't know if it's in there for like a second.
Yes, Chris, there's more link in the links in the description below.
Uhh, uhh, hm, hm,
hm.
. Umm, uhh, hm.
Umm,
uhh,
hmmm,
hmmm. You
Like, that is the fashion work that is on women's.
Yeah. Which is completely different than the dual image.
Just, uh, and punch it in.
Check the train,
you know, without hearing what she'd say about it.
It might actually, it's pretty on an orphan. It might not have been very
loud.
I didn't give them on. Yeah, and it was based on what they used
for us. So yeah, that's so sad. So, uh,
we just got it. So, no more to the ass. Eh.
Let's go in. Hey, that's fine. Okay,
let's, uh, shut up. And also do that.
Okay. Hey, uh, I don't know how to do it though.
Thank you. It's pretty fun.
Yeah man. Please take 10% off, marginalize and badness and sort of thing.
I'm having a business. Yeah,
man. Do you know it? I think I should keep not having anything.
Yeah, that's the song. So that's the instructional period. Modern.
It's good sense and is well. So,
you know, if you're not a companion, or if you want to stay inside,
I'd like to see you soon as day. Bye for today's episode.
I don't know if anyone people. It's an area. It's part of the food.
I'm sure still that one is too. Thank you.
It's something that we want you to
know. It's a surprise to the guy. Yeah. Okay.
Like, when you go to the internet, you're going to want me to think
about it. Or it was kind of stuck with the port, and then I
hear this in TV. Yeah. So,
when you go to the sky, it's gonna turn you. So,
if you're a woman of family, and you guys, that's what it meant to
be. We have that. So, like, there's no surprise in this picture.
It's got a little bit structure,
but it's still on the inside. And then it's wrapped in the moment.
Scared it. And it's got a thousand. Uhh, uhh, uhh, hmmm,
hmmm. We are actually,
it's something I wanted to do. It's a kind of step on It's super.
If you don't start the Phoenix Convention site,
you die, I know. It's a bit better. It's about nine.
It's about nine. Let's see.
See you. You know, feet are super cool. Mm-hmm.
Start getting in there. It's a bit better. You know, the custom can block
the body and shit. It's a bit like, lots of stuff, you see. I'm
I'm sorry, That wasn't on the space, pulling the knee blades in the side.
I think so, I'll put it.
Oh, you can hide it as long as you can. So come see it.
You it on. Most of the time, we get used to getting ready to
have on the night site, so we get used to it. We have a
thousand pallets, so you can take away your business with, like,
shoving my monster names. put in hands. It's the,
uhm, and then all the other stuff.
But I don't think we can deal with them. We're gonna say it's the
taste that we're almost new to here. Yeah,
something. That's why I think we can see that.
That's
What's better?
Almost sure I don't. I'm in peace.
Thanks. I'm a 41 nurse at 32.44,
I'm trying to be, uh, careful with that for a bit.
I've been here this time. It sounds like I'm really good at it,
I guess. I'm sure my bad lane isn't put out there,
but, uh, yeah. So, uhh, uhh, just cut based
underneath the belt, almost double.
Okay, so double. See you in the end.
Finally. And simply, 15%.
For gingles, this is our another job that we should run this against.
It's just like this. People, uh,
everything you're saying, they're mature. I mean, I know we're working on the scouring
sides of life. Let's see what we just wanted do. I was just wondering
if I told him that other John did you, uh,
uh, which one? So he pulls out of the five. He pulled out the
much larger John. you It's the one that,
but I still don't do you, but I don't belong to John.
I forget the thing, it's bad.
Who was T.S.M.C.M.? There's a lot of KSM's.
You guys have shit in there. Send these animals at Stop
all of it, and please prepare me cleanly. Yeah. Okay. So,
good. So, good. Thank you
so much. I think you're not. You're getting better at it.
I have a chart lines and some, so, uhm,
thank Okay.
I'll take a at the end of the video. Gee, right? I haven't been
dropped for the split. It's,
it's, it's, uhm, it's, uhm, it's, it's.
I mean, it's, it's. It's like.
Uh, I'm going to sit with some package.
Here's one of them in there. Okay.
Draw one of them in there.
Umm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
Umm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm.
I trust I trust you, I just wanted to keep on a total number
of other sections.
There you go. There you go. you go. There go.
There you go. There go. Thanks.
You're working on doing the same thing. Still, you're doing the ground test to
do maximization. You have a very smart job.
You know, I said, I don't Oh yeah. Well,
in the
I, I'm a mock yesterday at the shower yesterday.
I'm here for the most day and I'm interested to buy it out.
And then it's just like I know.
It's like, it's not through ever again. So,
man, I'm gonna be excited. If we get it,
then we're excited because it's not that. That's the song in the middle.
All right. Sorry. You're all Just,
we ought to have a so-and-out rate price.
If only a billion is the type of a woman. Probably,
actually, it's related. So, it might be.
I know, I'll sit and I, I think.
I just walk in the door,
right? So, uh, my step. That's That's it. What I wanted to say is
that you need that,
uhm, uhh, at some point. and and and Yeah.
You know, I know you guys look more like that. You're trying to say,
this is, you know, I have to not do that since I've been.
So, you're- I met him a little bit,
even when he was a little bit like, yeah, I was on the end,
and shimmy, because it's only- .
. I was in charge of the interview team, umm,
so I met him, and I never met a personator,
he was, I met him from my original role.
And he was in charge of the and he was in charge of the
interview team, and he was in charge of interview team.
And we're saying, you know, he's in my office,
uh, while I go there and do something like that.
I'm going to get I really
have to get it. So it's so easy to get it equal here.
Mostly because it's basically about all the- uhh,
uhh, uhh,
Umm, the hour is on.
You're trying to stay in here. I don't even know what you're doing.
Yes, we walked around here. We're getting more.
Uhh,
but what you can do is, if you're driving on a set of penalties,
you're not going to get hurt. I'm assuming you're- I think
you guys will get hurt from some of the private habits,
when you start to do the deals with them. Have a start. but not
So they didn't do that, and it's, you know,
it's true. It's not that hard. It's okay to do.
It's okay. But I think they have it.
Thank you. they have sho-Ive been available.
8 of them-I call them my lawyer.
I don't ever give that to you cause I'm a kid.
I just don't know what they can do here. They can do here. Yeah,
I do. Thank you. Thank you. Umm.
It's the only way to think about it or not.
Yes, I'm in the middle of helping the field install.
Oh. Oh. I just got to make the
new job. They suck it,
too. Thank you. Job. It's good.
Oh, no. I'm not going to get it.
But they want it. They're so,
So, this dog isn't it?
If he didn't feel good, it's kind of a pain. Yeah, it's good.
That's when it is a bit of healing. If you feel out and you
try to help, it's a pain. Get bothered. That's a long amount of trouble.
There's something safe to have. Just seem there to be a lot of it.
You just say. Thank you. Yeah, so I had, again,
my local time was a poo part, so I was having a little bit
of this in a while, how many takes have you been coming
Umm, uhh, uhh, hm,
I wanted to decide, I mean then,
but, but instead of further than the structure of this,
I need to stay. But, I'm into the-
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I can't say it except this one. Oh,
really? That's right. That's all it is.
Yeah. Alright. Alright. Let's get started to the answer.
Peace. Oh, chef.
Okay, let me just rest a little bit.
I want to listen to myself. In the association. Thanks for joining us.
We'll see you All right. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. You want that? You're welcome.
Let me just make a moment of this in touch.
Yeah. Just give it myself. . . Let's go.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. I'm
gonna take the rest of the way back. Good.
I don't think things I would have been around. Ah,
so, there's too many chance to get them to become.
Alright, that's not how that is to be.
It's not how catchy Thank you very much for joining us,
and I will see you in the next video.
Thank you.
Okay, that's fine. Okay, so, um,
how do I say everything?
It's all good. It's kind of smart. I knew it was the,
uh, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm, It's a bit long.
The part with the parts is the same as the interior project.
I figure out if it's a lot of hours, you know, it's a lot
of good days. And I'll probably do the analogy. He's,
he's not that's a lot. That's a lot. I mean,
it's a way of what we're gonna call her to do on the tell.
Maybe she'll find out if it is. She loves going on. I'm sure.
Well.
So,
alright, so that's what we should Yeah,
that'll make a difference. I was gonna say that,
that made a- I'm not- I can't skip the beat but I'm sorry.
I you know, I shouldn't have listened to that.
Okay. That. That's it.
You're
comparing another one then? Yes.
All This is one of the bads.
Okay, good. So
I am
adding one of this 69 with
75. Bye. I felt it was 46 with taking eyes.
One, five, two,
three, four, five, eighteen, one, one,
two, seven, eight, three,
five, five, four, six, eighteen, one,
two, one, two, two, one,
two, one, two, five, five,
five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five,
five, five, five, five, five, five, .
He's following right here in a second. Yeah.
You're going to get your friend that gets an individual job to take.
Yeah. He doesn't know how to operate from the job. Uhh,
uhh,
uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh,
uhh, uhh,
uhhy, uhh, as disciples, but that child gets hurt when you're innocent.
So, ok, that was,
uhm, I'm sure. So, with this one, we were providing it with a total
of honors, and it said, put it right out in the head and come
in. Oh, ok. Focus. Uh,
this piece came from here. I think it was,
yeah, it gave us one last time we set the video out.
They didn't, you know, get it,
okay. Umm, that's what it did.
No, it didn't appear. It's, uh,
what it Umm, yeah, you know, so.
And this was, I didn't trust
that, and this is. . This is one Okay.
Okay.
Now that the guy who worked here,
he said, he said to me, he's dead for a little sleep. Alright, Mark
here. Good! Then go click Hold on.
All right. If see you I'm guessing we should just find some more because
without hearing with them all the time, you know, those are the steps of
Katie, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So, this one, uhm, uhm,
pretty much every single one of these packages, a,
You know, originally made the project at quarter-range process of the order.
We got the button drawn on the set, and all of the weldments.
Switch the 560,
and set it forward. We are up.
So, with all of the things,
we're- re-estimated before we spend a month in the floor,
just out of the seat, to make sure we weren't in a bus,
to get more in a bus than we were in a- trying to get
ahead of it and say, here's what it is going to take us,
and it's over a certain dollar up and you know,
you you can assess the meeting. I don't have word,
check capacity, some, some point.
Um, so that's,
that was kind of the process. This would cost him a he's,
we'd get him in out of the way yesterday,
you know, or they, uh, put out a lot of over,
and then- and then they don't get married to me.
So- So the- the mix between your fit,
the gweld, and other. Bye Is essentially
what a fit and well is over here, but yeah,
it depends on what you're under, it should be.
What about you? You should- Yeah, uhm, but you're essential
to this. Thank very much. I still have,
on that lice, I'm going to shoot it before my death.
that. That is, on that last job, I should have recorded that as well.
Can we get back to where you do that? Look at that,
you know, with that I'm sorry,
I should have, uh,
grabbed it while we were there.
That way we- See
you there.
Okay.
No, no, no,
no, There.
It sounds like Chris is
quantifying and tasked with making sure the numbers are right.
I think, again, it's up here. So, uh,
you can eventually say,
yeah, these are good now. Let's push it out a little bit.
That's it. I like what he said he wants,
he also wants to be a patch of all balance.
You and I both agree with it. Thank you.
Thank you. Very, very good. The whole business has to be on action,
right? Yeah. I want you mad at it and you can start working.
Then just- You know, I'll fix it by training by us.
I'm not a man. Sorry, I had to use this a lot.
Oh. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Yeah, I want it to,
okay. Shh, shh, shh, shh, and .
.
And
me and that, uh, the efficient.
I don't think I'm
feeling it. Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh. Okay.
So, you, you have a step out of that that you just showed of
what the job really-
This is just a description today. Okay. Yes, this one needs to be the
biggest. Okay, week. Umm, the last one we were looking at that,
I can, I can pull up. Ah,
I can pull up. Alright, so this one,
two ninety-nine. You're gonna give
us the actual announcement. relevant. Yeah.
So, it shoots me up a little bit.
We'll see and tell us from this one again.
So, we'll screenshot it. And a second.
3A2's yet.
So, yeah, it was, it was crazy.
Shh, my name. Yeah, we'll get everyone to do that for a reason.
The other one, I can't understand what we have in the county for all
of that. I'm thinking both of the top of the lines.
Okay, so, in v3,
right now, I have some other lines that we're going to be making.
in. 3, 3, 20,
and the, uhm, the, uhm, the original.
So, it's a nice, nice, So, and then,
I go back in here,
and I go. You here,
here, And,
in use,
in the hero. That's,
that's what we've got a lot more on the other speeds that she's in
for the rest of the game. It's actually fun now,
actually. What's that?
I think they're following.
Yeah, they're starting to try and I think they're using heavy vid.
Thank you. This is pure speculation that it's gone.
Because I don't know what you've ever been for ever to get shot and
to get. One that's what I'm curious about is,
Is the, uh, low field shot? Because it's such a mechanical shot.
Yeah. That, I'd be surprised if they don't have a pipe made package.
That's just- So, unless it's very finished with
actions. Thanks for your patience. Totally
finished 10. Just under 10 hours under the original.
It's 299. Umm,
well, we used 86. I guess it is.
and we'll see you
For sure it's gonna be mine.
Uh.
I'll put it just in the stairs,
and we had an inch, and put it in the- Umm,
ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm. I'm I'm going to be sitting on a
71.75 instead of an eight.
Looks perfect to confess. Yes. Umm, ehm,
ehm, ehm,
ehm. 5, 6,
7. We need 7.7.7.5.
So. Okay.
. If I look that up, I'll be looking at the,
uhh, the part of the agency that, the beginning of the video.
I'm if you're interested in that. There.
You're feeding strongly into it.
I think that low, low,
low, then long. Love.
You know stuff? Yeah. I mean,
I don't have the history yet, but I'm not working on getting it.
Okay Yes,
I think Power Fair Techno is going to be everything that's structural
that just drives and. . . You know, that electrical that you're talking about.
. . You know, that That's it. . . What we're Oh,
it's the money! What's your actual on the .
. . 25 0 6 0 9 48?
You have that.
That's
the person. Uhm, that's the second one.
The more we hear that, the more we hear. This one,
uhm, this one was just ready for the production today.
Okay. Okay. See you later. See you later. later. I'm going a good Yeah.
Okay, I'm Dave.
Umm, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm, Ehm,
Ehm, Ehm, Ehm. . . Yeah. Yeah,
I'm gonna see what we got. Or dude,
40, whatever hit it,
the more the better. Later. 7-4-8-4-8,
correct? Thank you much.
And, uh,
techless outwards are total of 58.
8. Budget be in 69.
Uhm. and
We're kind of going all over here.
You No,
they're not, uhm, uhm, as an example,
on the 2407 5-8. Alright, we'll see you fit up and will are
basically right between tech on the budget.
it. Umm,
the last one looked at 25060948.
or eight. It's
pretty close between fit up and the wheel.
Um, it's- There's a little slight difference.
The, uh, uhm, 2-5 this one is- there's a 48%
d- difference between way old and a 20% difference between fit
up. And if we look at handling cut.
That's it. Burn. So just handling.
One job is 8.78, um,
high in tech. there. 30% low on the next job in tech.
20% high on this job.
Thank you very much. Yeah, I think that was 30%
high. I'm the first one, 53%.
Low on the second one, 112% high on the next one.
Burn is 34%.
Thank for your attention. I am lying on the 1st one, 1% high on
the 2nd one, It's
all the same families of jobs, we'd be basically making people with live plates
here, they have different types of jobs. Umm,
this one. And the first one, the area is the one,
the both of them. It's kinda like the first one we're lacking.
I'm gonna be in a middle room. Alright.
Alright. Alright. Alright. Alright. Alright. Alright. That's, uh, um,
the sixth one when we did it in the middle. Uh,
that one, when we did it in actuals is,
a mixture with a lot of structural,
as well as sinusilius,
so it's got angles, cusset, please. Please.
Umm, a bunch of little stuff,
and this is mostly 80-odd.
All right. Yeah, cause I'd say, by the line, if you start mixing hand
rail with music columns, it's a good one.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then,
and some of these are pretty small. I'm just going to see it a
little bit of, uh, while I'm around. Uhm.
Yeah. See you I'm going to see if it's in jail to cut it
under and learn it more. Yeah.
Uhm,
in the hater, it's good. . You can see,
we can keep it on the same scale of the 758 project.
Umm. Come on. Which is structural and
a small amount of misleading is in one package of 7.5.5 1,1,2,4.
Let's see.
I was like, oh, he changed his life,
yes. Yeah. The only thing I saw that I was looking just for that
was we were low on burners. Yeah.
Yep. On, uh,
yeah, let's say short that middle job was about.
Bye-bye. The same, but there's a little round to the lid.
You know, you can't really use that.
Mm-hmm.
And, you know, I-I know, I-I-I-I get us
experiencing-
I didn't consist of it, whereas, you know,
people flip the wrongs and get a general period,
right? And so- I'll go with- if- if-
if I see some slight variation there,
then it is because of his- Yeah,
of course. There you go.
The way, I shouldn't say that the way wind blows is,
I don't know what's going on in that, but he's not looking at You
can take it back with a grain of salt.
Yeah. I mean, I want it. Strike it down.
Okay. Well, you tell me,
but a lot of structure is either the dog or pallet belt or tongue.
A lot of people feel like a pet.
Good, I don't know, I don't like it,
but they do. To me, it's like,
you start out with the hours you think it's really gonna take,
and it costs them to hurt. And then, And then you look at it
and say, oh, okay, about how much money I get for a ton of
compounds. Why is this fun hiring?
better. I use 30 pounds per
minute.
Yeah, I'm working. I've heard what I would call our standard working.
Yeah. And I'll do the same thing. I'll slide it. Okay.
Let's just begin the moment here. Yeah. So,
like, if you see, I don't have to bring that to a minute.
This is great. Yeah,
what it is. It's, But that doesn't
work for instruction. It works for gopting shoots,
authors. We'll see that
other few gets used a lot, so that's kinda gonna bug in this.
Yes, sir. I'm real. So
that's a theatre. Well, the hours on this job.
Yeah, nope. Thanks for having us.
When
I was 16, well, I went 3, 5,
6, 8. So then,
I took the point 6,
and, You And then they say,
oops, that doesn't jime. Is it's
changed? Is it white?
It looks like it ought to be in fit up because,
well, on this job,
Techler was. was. higher on by 38%
and the fit up was. a little bit work.
way under. Probably because using the name and doing the
manual manipulation down there, you don't get fit up.
Yes, uh. So, I would bet that goes in.
In fact, I won't put it in there. Uh,
and the other part is it's, it's awesome. I,
because it's weird. Just in a well rate,
and I calculated these wells.
But essentially, this one's 5-16 well.
Hello. Which is now .6,
whereas of all of it.
You It was .1.2.
Okay. And so now is the piece.
All these 1.2. You know, 0.6.
And either of them are actually cut. Either of them or the other kind
of. Yeah, that's 1.2.
we'll hear. All right, thank you for peace falls into the other hand.
Okay. It's essentially why I was estimated for the exhibit and they gave me
an amen. I didn't need assessment to, uh. I'm sorry,
but I always ride on and calculate all the AP6s.
It's the sound which I need time based upon tablet.
Now I can go in here and globally edit. yeah That's a little bit
more action. A little bit more
action. You But because it's polished to the piece,
are the metrics that we've changed. Yeah,
I've changed that. I've been. Okay. Uhm.
So I just don't think it's skewed. The other categories and skewed with He's
sure. There is.
Thanks. Really
zero patterns. Yeah.
So, like, burn on this one was pretty close.
I mean, right, um. Thank you I was 18.69 versus 18,
whereas burn on the others,
one was 28% under. here.
1% over 34% under.
Um
There is no pattern whatsoever.
Umm. Oh.
I mean,
I think it's gonna be, I mean,
the word hundreds.
I think it's also gonna be the hundreds. Who wants driven by Mark,
the one who's driven by Gilbert, because if you start mixing those,
you're gonna have the left. I don't know.
Yeah. Yeah. I think you're,
you're, well, at all of these it's concerning mirrors.
Cheers. You're, you're, you're,
you're not listening. But it's really the actual,
right? The actual should still be the actual, be the actual.
We going to Well, now let's go back. All this, you know,
the actual one, two, four, six, about eight.
That's what I'm going to do. I'm going to sit there so that the
actual was getting that. And then 566,
that's the baby chart, you're charting it yourself.
Yeah. Okay. You guys have a good job.
Yeah. Okay, good. Yeah. And the 566 was supplied by Gilbert.
So, we were held to their dollar amount to be supplied by that breakout.
I estimated that after, just so that we could see if we would,
uh, us a little over one and a half. How to do? You know,
I guess. We'll make I'm to do Bye for now.
I've got to see you in a second.
Yeah? Historic me and guess we're around f******,
Hey,
what? Do you know what you're saying?
. . Just Okay.
Yes sir. I want to thank you for I don't want to be
a person. I just want this,
you
I mean,
I have a little nature that-
Yes,
sir. Yeah, I really think it started on. Then I'll get me ahead on
my nothing procuring. All right. So,
okay. Alright.
Yeah,
so that particular line is what we're talking about.
Two,
but then we have, One,
the, uhm, it's nice and confusing.
Uh, and then we go in here,
see if it's 3.1. One. And I'll see if it's 3.9.
Two. So I guess,
this is all the- I mean,
well, it's 2.35.
Bye. . That's not the document,
it's uh, handling is zero, but we only have any six plan honestly.
Thanks for being with us. It's something hard to do with that.
Let him go explore for some of the projects that it was.
sentence, please. So,
I think I can, uhm,
just production people still. So,
that. That's five minutes,
moving to base point. She lives plus number five.
Bye bye. Let's see,
if you want to help,
I don't know this. Anytime Umm, 13,
5, 6, 3,
17. So, if there's one bigger child,
then where's your- I think I've ever tasted this one baby bad.
That's what I'm going to do. You I
mean, there's so much data here. I mean, I see 600,
370, 1800.
There's a lot of data. I don't here.
No. It'd be nice to have a little chicken.
Dop it off. In one,
I'll swoop into itself. Well. Yeah.
Like,
those logic numbers don't match well.
So, I don't want to hear
it either.
Who's the Justin's signify? the file. Umm.
Well, they're shaded out of the day, it was like a sassy thing. Let's
see the worst. Okay. That's what I'm saying.
It doesn't match this, but then there's,
I mean, I think three missing base adjustments.
Justin. The plan, right there. Yeah,
see, there's actually an, uhm, an estimated hours.
hours. People go as well,
but playing in this, that's where I was expecting to see this one.
But they were sending, they were using the adjustment of the estimated.
That's about it. So a plant is the sum of adjustment plus base.
Yep. Bye-bye.
Time's right machine,
so I'm just sitting here in the middle. I'm gonna associate that before.
It's dead.
Okay.
I'm going for an all the story to- is it a shuttle?
You're not gonna- Good. If
that Okay.
Subscribe,
send us an e-mail and be like. I can send a spreadsheet and say,
here it is. I would assume that technology may come before.
Well, thanks God. Bye I'm even working.
Let's go out! Lay down some clothes.
Django. I'm still in that typing!
And every week, you know,
just having that as a report, custom in person's actual phone.
Well done. A bunch of tries.
It's,
uh, time shoot. It's-
I
don't know where all of them let you not even say she- Umm,
ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm. You know. I'm also,
uh, these, they said, uh, me and one sheep. It's the same.
Yeah. We'll finish. We feel that we constantly,
we're just keeping things new and age student.
So each of those good jobs are on the bottom.
Alright.
So. The
person is literally like on your, your computer.
No, this lives in Mars.
All the- In the art, that, and shop.
Uh-huh.
This is the way he does this cute thing,
and it's, uh, I put a spicy thing in here.
Yes. That's it.
I'm
used to have Fred Dutton doing this.
. . Of course, and tweet. Think of the 12 reports,
of time, and then it goes through them with you and Shane.
Okay. And then he stopped or came here and went
for it to keep our time connected.
He didn't stop.
My chance of the time. It's,
So, uh,
I think it's a good but I'm really good,
so I think it's a good shot.
Alright.
So much.
Thank you
There's the internet. It was really hard to push, not going to be a
140 South Douglas.
. .
Uhh, uhh, uhh, You
Because
I'm fat, so, uhm,
and, uh.
.
It's being loved as, if you've seen it,
watch any of Parafabs videos,
he's the one with the handy mistake, that's it.
Ah! They, they would like to some input on
what people like about those types of systems.
What they don't like, what you want to see them prove.
I have a feeling they might be looking at doing something with that.
So, yeah. Yeah, I know they're really good at building integration and,
you know, they're really nice if we can mark off something.
You can call it, you can call it, you it a side there,
and then mark it off in that total. Yeah, I'll be able to make
your contact here. I'm gonna leave it before I get up with you.
And that's the doctor. How's your all
of you, Owen? One. Well, you're all going to step in and give
it up for an hour and a half,
and uh. And then it's all the end,
but I have, I have corporate,
uh, environmental here,
due to the area of settings. Yeah. Anyone? Yeah. You know, I have, uhh,
I don't think it's way to think about it.
So, uhh, I have a much more- And you guys.
Uh,
you look like beautiful weather out there.
It's not- going through all this. It's really possible.
Yeah, it's going to be dating in there. It's not bad.
It doesn't even make sense to it. You Is it the same thing as
you think? I heard they're eating a day out of the That's just stupid.
Good. It doesn't,
not, like, put no story on it.
It's like that, it's paper bag for the shipment.
Ok. Thanks. Thank you for this. If you want to think of me,
or if this seems like a good change, then they file it.
Sunday and Monday is supposed to be, Yeah.
I'm singing
enough, I ain't. If
you've been tensed with that, uhm,
you need to listen. Uh. . . .
.
That's it.
This is the end of the session,
the name of the 29000. It's my boy.
It's my kid. It's my baby.
I'm the kid. I'll you next time.
All right. What the f*** are you doing? I'm on the back.
Okay. See you.
You Do you think that held me here at
once, though? I don't. I don't know,
I'm just gonna be. Okay. He haven't responded,
so even see there, he said it couldn't make me let us know and
we'll die of it. So, after you know.
Yeah,
I think you should. Yeah. One more and a second on the right. Yes.
You can follow him. Yeah. Yeah. Bye. Man,
he wants me to serve him for all of this.
It is pretty. Boss didn't.
He didn't. He didn't.
That's in question. Michelle. It's one of you and I'm thinking of telling people
what you think. That's how they start going.
It's right. And as soon as we pass- Yes.
This is how much it's ready. Okay.
Umm,
ehm, ehm, ehm. Okay.
I mean, it looks like they have sports at all. But this is way,
that's no longer right to go. Uh, I don't have so many.
But, uh, it would be the playoffs. We
saw the place of the coach. I was back to,
you know, here we, uh, had a sense of where.
Alright. Alright. It's every install that I actually do.
It's not. You know it.
I can't.
Umm,
ah, hm, hm, hm. What's
the narrative of what switch does, what lower of electrical does,
what uh, revolution electrical does. you guys.
I'm trying to get this, uh,
air sentence. But what are the little lights of air
sentence. . Yeah, because,
um, we have a switch way to go and do the cops.
If we're going to be, please stay. Thank For a lot of power,
at least. We did, like, lighting packages with a thin cell,
and we were kind of like, More orders,
and I'm like, so I'm going to say thank you very much for watching
and making it a little more possible to get it on the bigger,
uhh. They must have been like that.
I don't know if I can tell you that question.
Jenny will be here to have one.
All So I'm thinking, even if you're already felt very bad.
But we're getting very much with the first step.
I can't even go on in the lecture for a minute in our study.
. .
.
yeah,
since I'm going to decide on a big bunch of database,
the permission is set on a sketch. Yes. Yeah.
That's it.
Cause I was good at it. And the video was not.
out. I'm
sorry. What? I like the mask that I like.
Just mince it. I'm not it.
What is it, sir? No, sir. Thank you.
Thank you. I'm better than I am. Better instant damage than it.
Oh, what do you want?
Bye. I wish you'd watch
out, Jimmy.
I don't need to. It's about sporting, it's about a year old.
Yeah, I think I'm a person.
That's the only way I can get into one thing. But, Ha,
thank you for listening. Thank you so much for listening.
It's very, very, It came up with me yesterday,
I was like, Oh, I forgot my stash,
you know. Like, I'm not going to make sure you're switching off.
Thanks. Thanks. And
so, I'm going to go ahead and make- It's a little bit better than
that. I will go look in here and
re-face it and come out to the palm of the ring. Want me to-
I'm not be a person.
I'm person. I'm I'm I'm I'm not not gonna person. I'm not gonna I'm
not I'm not gonna not gonna gonna be I'm not gonna be a person.
I'm person. I'm not gonna I
don't understand what bringing gifts. You didn't say that it was going to pop
in and bring it stuff down. I didn't understand what I was such.
He became a bad guy. He said, oh, I'm your foot.
He said, what's going on? He said,
you know. Bye.
Who else do you think you're
share? He is!
OK? Thank you so much. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank little. Umm. Thank you, OK. Alright. Let's My
I just got to get the right hand. I hand. hand. All right.
Any moment,
have a good day. Have a good day.
Alright, have day. Alright. Ok.
Alright. No,
no, no, no, no, no, I did it.
I did it.
Did you get a phone? No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. and not the good.
Here, if you guys want to know,
it happens. It happens a little bit louder. If you're increasing better than what
they've had, you try out a Yes, sir.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Is that right?
I'm I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh,
look at this. Uh, you're saying all about it.
Yeah. Uh, uh.
What. Do you have travel, at least, was 40,000 weeks out of the year?
I think you have a lot of travel. If my wife will get away
from it. Okay,
yep. Okay, so I'm gonna need to experiment.
Bye, I'll be with you. Yeah. Yum. Good
to be honest.
Three. In here. Right kids. One,
two, three. Good bye. Good bye. And that one was
just born in August. So I'm brand new to you,
you know. And I- That's it.
That's it.
Yeah. Okay.
He's just, uh, three-four months old,
and so, but they's the right question.
Why am I sick? I'll ask him. Okay, cool. Well,
that's why I'm doing this one. Two of my three kids need five of
my glasses. No cheering because- Uh,
they found cataraphic worship. They played a lot more of them to hear it
and see how important it is when it's involved with your practice to cheer
Alright, I'm going back. I'm going back.
I'm going back. I'm going back. I'm You can see it here.
So then I'm going back. Maybe you gotta look at Southern California.
Yeah. Yum. How old are you kids?
Okay.
Do you have minor? 31,
26, 21,
and uh, heh, heh, heh. You Okay,
that's how I was late getting started. Yeah. I've been a,
uh,
19 year old and if you want to help me. Uuh,
uh, uh, huh. Uh,
uh, I was going to run a set of,
uh, organisms designed by him.
Thank you. I mean, it's just,
you know, I don't know what it is. So I'm putting a microphone to
a period where it says we're not having to get it,
we can't afford it. Uuh. Then they got
pregnant right away. Oh, yeah. Oh,
shit. Uh oh,
shit. . . I'm married, but he's a date-m-girl out of serious.
It hasn't, it hasn't been a little bit. He lives in DC,
he lives out. What you're going to contract is a wrap up
really, man. I understand what he does, but, um. I'm not going you.
Something with ArcGIS for the military.
His girlfriend has a real- .
She is our Secret Service in the
White House. Great. Very good.
So she was,
she was telling me back thanksgiving when they were home.
And they were poor.
She left. Really nervous.
She said very much. I'm not going to be able to do another check.
There. So
she, uh, she gave us a question on how to make a, almost, um,
three, but, uh, she learned that. I'm not sure if you can have
the National Guard or something like that.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
She was leading. That was right. Two.
Her ship was done at two or five and that means she's walking you
with power. It's in the car radio and then it's off.
Once it's shot by me,
they'll, when that comes out,
you don't make it, if you're on the ground, you're hitting that I think
we're going to have now, so. And then we're going in and shutting the
white house down and, uhm,
you know, the secret service section of police is outside the white house as
well, okay. So that is actually her own co-workers
that were on the first ones. Right there with the guys.
Bye! That's a lot of real pretty staking up.
Huh. From that, so.
How's it going? Have a good one.
I just visited my daughter at
UNLV. Yep. you And I've stopped for the lunch at
St. George, Utah. Yeah.
As I'm drunk, I'm good to eat. We'll see you next time. I thought,
ah, how much one can sound, it's a little bit extra.
Like, I've never had a car. So,
you do that sport. Uh huh. You know,
come up next to me and if you look at it, that was a
day chart, but you've never seen it. Uh huh.
And, as I did for him,
the traffic was just- . . The complete shit show.
Yeah. I think they were to look at it in part to see what
they could see. Yeah. Yeah.
Definitely. Wow. There's a thing you're trying to find against me.
Yes. But I was all the way. I would go up to the,
I can imagine the one with a cheaper shirt,
and I have to tell you who's the last one.
I haven't been here. You know what? I didn't know this.
She was T.S.A. in Orlando Airport.
And T.S.A. I'm a little .
. I did not know that they were in the same department.
And so, you know, solve this as an opportunity.
with me. Of course you haven't really tried anything like that,
but they accept and earn you. But you don't really order them up to
you, which is really far as to be nice. I'm not,
it's a sign of the point. But is she part of the detective detail
or is she? Mm hmm. Yeah,
she's fully, Checked out,
you know, all the guns and everything.
So, you know, shoot that right in. Alright,
absolutely. She said- Well,
I'm not sure you can get it found. Normally,
they just, it's out because they're on their side.
But, when that happens, they- So I that there isn't looking for any longer
than she said. Yeah, it was quite,
you know. I was going to be looking for three or one to wait.
Good. Good. Okay. Okay. All the way up there.
She took us all the tools. Yeah, my hands. I was talking to my
man. Oh, we don't need them. I don't if that sucks over the street.
It's better than the community here or something. It's not just talking to them
in life. This is God's, You gotta get some everybody finish through the
thing that's talking to you. You gotta get I'm gonna explain to you this
one a little bit. Bye. I got scared and everyone was very sick.
Over the last 28 years he said, I was really like,
Prince sit down and- He
was like, he was like, just thought he'd come through, you know. Uhm,
but it only got a lot of stories. I'm going to shoot. Thank you.
Thank you. Yeah. Being interesting.
question.
I asked them,
I asked them how they've got to learn how to develop this,
hm. . . . ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm.
She said they're actually, they try to not watch a lot of stuff.
Hm. They don't want to be too biased when we leave them because,
They're going to the same thing being,
but, right? Yeah. But she said the flip saw that,
too, is her kind of seeing the movie.
Yeah. You know, hey, I do more than,
uhm, but she said it about, you know,
the news, thanks. Thank So, yeah,
she's like big, very normal people in a very good manner against her.
I don't know,
Okay.
Let's do it. Now, please look. You know what I I
don't know what I mean. Okay. I'll next time.
He just worked the White House for this year to go on these advanced
teams, you know. These people drive.
So. So, The White House is her main focus.
When he travels, then they,
that's, I just volunteers that want to go on a trip with them.
And if they don't get volunteers, then they get volunteers.
So yeah. They should have been a good for 40 cents, you know,
and they should not have thought of driving too much, but they do have
to go a certain amount of trips over to Every Okay.
But, they don't fly on the plane.
What's your commendations right? All that it's right So,
breakage. All right. . They usually follow at Harvard Williams.
They're not flying their horseback. They're not.
They're not. Alright, see you How much
gear are you going to check with you?
Mm hmm. Okay. Let us see. I
can't lose any, I not a doctor. Yeah,
unbelievable. So if you cover.
All right. All right. Here we go.
Sorry, Fred. Mhm. Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm. streets.
Mhm. this is what I like, here was... just that Trump was just after
the Kennedy Center. Which is easy.
They had to take a hold.
In detail later, because she was working
that. But may that be cool because that was,
And a kiss was there,
um, George Street. I'm here to do all this.
Alright, let me see. We'll see you back in the next video.
Bye bye. Bye bye.
So all I know is that I still know.
Okay.
I'd
rather just stay open. Hehehehe. Alright, then,
we'll Can
I help you?
I heard a lot that,
uhh, like a lot of shops barely touched and gave it a delay,
but. But. I mean, I shouldn't,
I shouldn't feel better.
But, um,
yes, in the 60's,
we can more show them the clients I've had for a little bit. As
to make a Two, three, four, five,
and you usually learn historical. It's a bad app.
It's a technology in the slides. We don't probably need users.
We can just add them in the back. Uhh, uhh,
uhh, hm. Uhh,
uhh, ehhh,
uhh, uhh, eh. Uhh,
that's right. Yeah, we got a guy at dinner with last night when it
got full, that's sweet. Too powerful.
Yeah. up. That's right. I think that's where it
I'm and that that's where it was still in theown I have.
And I've got to still. I feel like I'm really old,
I'm thinking that. I will be down a little bit.
That's right. Peace. See you soon. Most of the time the estimators of the
retailers are the same people.
If you really ever said I'm willing to just come and eat it back.
Yeah. So, ah, yeah.
This may be the details we've been saying.
Let's, let's talk about 10 minutes and see if that's- I don't but I
don't see, I don't Thank
you very much. And that,
too, is really nice to me. Alright,
so this is my 100th birthday shop.
I'm gonna get it. So, you know. You're welcome.
I don't know how to
use this.
Thank you. Anyway, with this one project,
project managers feels like all-in-tea and everything,
which I don't understand. Because we're an old child,
if you are a thief. So if you learn to name your project,
that's what's happening to other new projects. I guess,
man. Actually, half my career has to be able to have the project benefit.
So I get to have the opportunity very much.
And I'll really like to get it.
It is, it is weird to have an idea to put it.
You know, that's, that's an, that's an, and I'm sure you have some project
right into it. Or all of a minute. . You know,
if I can stay in the middle of the room,
it's functional soon. And. Hold on.
Keep that in It's
just, it, um. It's just. tax tax base of $1,000.00 $2,000.00 in the $2,000.00
$2,000.00 in,000.00
a So, uhm,
uhm, hm, hm,
hm, hm, hm,
hm.
I hope they have a big money. I'm sorry I'm next to you to
show But you guys are out of the city,
so take a shot of a lot of body that pug. But I'll let
us apply them. I mean,
it's the cheapest way to increase.
Thank you. I mean, you know, the base models are about 300,000.
I think those, you know, performance. friends.
It's like a coasting saw in front of it.
Yeah. They're very, very nice set-ups,
but I think you're gonna leave her and smile.
Don't adjust for the homecoming, but it'd be more simple.
It's about a million bucks for it.
Yeah. We'll see in the I got the baby's shirt on the baby's shirt.
He launched what I'm a taxideric friend of the day, laying in the dress
all up next to you. I'm going to do this out on your plane.
But, yeah, that's not what you've communicated.
Okay. You know what,
I'm surprised when I'm out of the incident,
nobody's laughing. . . That's what you want,
eh, uhm, you can also take a read-by,
uh, email that I have. I'm like,
nah, nah, I'm a station,
I'm not a station. I'm a hundred African-Dawak program.
I'm possibly update this dimension.
I-I had a- I've heard that SBS were going to buy them,
because, you know, they've got to have a strong mission, which is,
uh, got to have a patent suite, and it really- I really don't like
this guy. Yeah, sure. That like button.
Yeah. And it's the best one. That'll be 5 trons.
I'm sure it'll be 5 trons. That. That's the best.
It'll be a test that will be right. I'll have it.
That's good man. Whoops man. I give best ears to the docile.
I know. Yeah. That's me. This is awesome.
I'm one of her dead surgeons. I still have business.
It's an abortion. Mm. You see
her in life. Yeah, I wanted to think these guys had been chasing
as well as a pencil. So Yeah. Problem is it's,
it's a paternal handling job. It's not- It's not a bad job.
Yeah. It's a technical pattern.
It's horrible. It doesn't order choosing until the cows go in.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You But they have, like,
a hundred different designs. So,
have fun. They're all about it, you.
Thank And every week the schedule will move,
because the medical will come and end up with weeks co-authors for the weeks.
Yeah. And if you don't have all the design- Sometimes the pills,
you know, in your system are set up. They're at least thinking it was
part of the- you gotta get set up.
And again, it's 22 days, 22 working days to build one,
and then they pay a premium for 10 days.
Thank you. It's
just a game of managing the logistics of it. You just have to have
10 truck wheels. . . The fourth order sitting out there has got
to happen. And then you need all creates play.
Please. It's,
I've done it three times. I've never made money in the labor,
I know. It's three minutes.
But time you get s- So, Yeah. Well,
you're an enough later to just wrap it down.
Yeah. And, some new management team said,
let's do it again. It's like,
It's not that it feels like the one set of.
It's about. Yeah, it's almost like a fashion brand,
you know, where you need your braille and make your make. It is manufactured.
Yeah, it's absolutely right. Yeah, but it's not a piece and a dual it,
uh, because you're a pester and they're used to it all the time.
Umm, uhh, uhh, uhh,
hm. A
lot of work, you know, you know, and just,
you know, then just squeeze the additions.
Yeah, and then get everything. They're a lot weird.
And then figure out how to go, you know,
it's telling me how to go, maybe, you know,
we're setting up all the jigs, we're setting up, and then kill it.
Most, most, uh, people can't send us to get up with that and then
we'll go. Do more for Jay and I'll go.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Instead, I'm gonna talk to you a little
bit about that. So I think they're an extra chill shot in Kansas City.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. We had a shot back there
in terms of-
Umm, ehm, ehm, ehm. That's why I'm
not pushing this. I'm going to try that.
So we were doing one with the bottom of the car.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, they felt completely capable. Okay, bye. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. listen badly at hunting,
right? You Yeah.
You Let's shut that contract
down on all of a sudden. Yeah, I'll be up. Thank you very
much.
Yeah, it's like, wow. And then,
It's like, oh, it's that.
Multiple people. I don't want it to be,
it's, uh, in the index area.
So, they're going to try to sell strings.
Good, I don't want it to entail,
but either pass those or,
uhm, doin' like the data center.
Yeah, I can imagine this.
If I was told in a pretty specific,
they'd have a lot of features.
issues. Yeah, a lot of curling.
But again, the day you're eating. It's a stop.
Alright. Bye-bye.
If you ever had a chip pad, all the utilities are on this floor,
and all the tools are on this floor. Yeah. Yeah.
So they set these tools on these two of the top tables.
Yeah. When all the people get started, they go negative telling them,
yeah. So they get a speaker. So these,
uh, tables are pretty complicated,
cutouts. Yeah, this is the other one.
I know. Oh I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know if they were being told that I was speech.
Okay. Here is their zone.
Okay. Bye. Yeah,
I know. They're too warm. I want them to.
It's not like they're being huge beer fans.
They're shaking them all over the place.
Thank very much. So it stops.
Now, I appreciate it. And I'm going to throw this out,
because they were just single fans, so I'm going to give them something in
here and move that way. That's bad. Okay. Yeah.
Well, just, you know, not my choice. Yeah,
I'll do it. Alright, I have the freedom to achieve this weather right
here. All right. All right. I'm gonna leave you out for a minute.
It's time to call the group. That is,
You Fifteen on those days,
no, it's a lot. So,
I think that's really well-looking now.
Well, that's a busy dude for you, but you have to look at it.
I have a lot of own new response. Oh, my life,
let's show this attack, my stomach binding, and we'll test it.
to it . That's uh, that's uh,
that's uh,
that's uh.
So, uhm,
a lot of people say it's from the GMOs of the genetically modified foods
we got. But. Bye. My body just can't recognize the,
the brains and all the different things that do to them anymore,
so. It can keep us here and.
Well, that would count as one vice even more today
than it will be. and welcome to this I've never seen so many
more years ago. Yeah. Heh.
Heh. You Heh.
Huh.
Okay.
Second in this shot. Okay. Good. I'm go ahead I'm go ahead There's time
where I can do this. Hehehe. No,
no, they won't speak to me. Go look. All right,
we'll look at that.
But I had that. We were, we were looking at Jamie Bates or none.
Yeah. Signed out and had the bakers go. We'll see You know what I'm
saying? One guy came in and he was like,
he was perfect for working through that collar, and he was like,
oh, it don't pop up. I don't know how it did for all this
time. I'm back.
I don't know how it did. Please consider reaching because I don't know what
was in that. What was that?
You're sure to turn the lead. Yeah. That's bonk,
it's only molding. Thank you.
That's dedication and expiance, you know. Okay.
It's very, very good. Mm-hmm.
And I got two more. Wow. Mm-hmm.
All right. Well, I guess they're certain what they're supplying.
They know that. I'm ready to go. I'm
really thinking that about god or kid.
She's strong, she wants to sing on it, and she's still at home learning
it. You know, machine's all over and out, and where she- Don't in the
next video!
Heh, heh, heh. It's a crazy lot dude.
Here you go. Good. That's what you mean hi.
Bye Yeah,
I'm not- I'm not just sharing.
I spent a little bit . Oh, she's getting lost in for holidays,
so, hmmm.
I was like that. You're gifted as my presence. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm gonna
listen. Probably won't rely on days when we're following the episode.
So, goodbye, so. So,
baby. I'm here.
I'm Everybody's going. The most uncomfortable airplane you have to keep by that.
Thank you. So, I'm going to be flying back
and forth between your days for the last 70 minutes.
I was 15 dollars and 31 cents and I was like,
dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah. You just have to say
it on your f****** tour. You
just say it tour. You just dah, dah, dah,
dah. Bye Like,
uuuh, uuh, uuh, uuh, uuh, uuh, uuh, uuh.
I was like, I don't know if she did that on the two sides,
but it doesn't help her eat. Yeah, yeah. Did you bye?
No. I'm it, but I don't know.
No. I'm not going to going to it.
It's like, I'm going to get it. I'm not going to get it. I'm
not I don't
think you'll think so.
I'm glad it's nice and cheerful. But,
uh, let's do them on a bucket, man. It's,
it's those are large, large things. We need to work the same and they
cancel them and fix it up. Yeah,
don't, uh, hopefully to be honest, you got to take a morning for a
mid-morning flex. I don't think you need flights to have all- and a He's
either delayed or canceled. I never had spent twice and seven months in the
late day, probably fifteen to twenty-nine.
I got to the airport,
and I'm in security. I don't.
Thank you.
Thank you. Your plan is new to that. What are you doing in security?
Well, what the- no, you didn't get to the email?
Yeah. There's my email. Cool, my ride is,
you know, so, uh, girl, what am I gonna do?
I'm gonna talk about a lot of your big,
big cases. We have one house the house. Yeah, that is for you,
that's for you. That's for you.
you. That's for you. Yeah. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go out on the plane. We get down and then reverse the
jacks and everything and the all-place problem. I can take that out of you.
Yeah. Yeah. Totally alright. I might survive this one.
Yeah, I have another orange family so they got up on you.
Uh, too. Good. I've
seen a few, a few fights.
I've caught a player and they've already done, I've just got to show them
the, I've got them started. I know about the very cases they've already showed.
I've got to do it. I've I've got to show them some good shape.
Follow time. Follow up. Oh, yeah. And they're, they're helped out in Minnesota,
so I get a little brush for it. I don't need 30. I don't
need to get to the bugs.
Yeah. My flight was the offensive part from holidays,
and it's getting my two dogs watched here back home.
Bye. I used to boil them south with us,
but I got them done and all of them took it back,
you know. They've changed us in seven or eight or ten years ago.
I wanted to get it. In the prices that have become the same as
America. Yep. Please subscribe to our and we'll see you I just like,
when I go to the American city, I fly American, and I go to
Salt Lake, I fly Delta, and I go to the churches in the fly,
and you die to their settlements.
They wanted you to really nice,
really nice to everyone. I'm funded in a while,
I just, I think. You It's almost
good up here. Yeah.
I need to Delete the number,
whatever it is. I actually got an appointment that I have.
So this year, I have to recoupend that.
So. So I didn't even know if I'd like to play the three games.
So if I did all that before I started doing the front gear things,
that'd be up. I'm glad that I get bumped up from this glass a
lot. And so if I went home over there and I'm going to be
fun. you I've got Travis and all of you.
I'll be like, wait, I'll be up there.
Cheers. Well,
don't come and get you, right? Because all I think I see is going
to find out who's the highest ranked person in,
uh, steerings of who you love.
If I'm not, if I don't get in first class, if I don't get
moved up, then I'll walk my first class and I'll see somebody up there.
If I see a kid or something. I'll there if they should stop.
Uh, oh, let's see. That must be very good.
Let's see. It makes the whole difference.
. Oh, it makes a huge difference.
Especially when you find one side of the necklace.
Yeah. Yeah. You're on your proper nose.
Yeah. Yeah. Blood out of the earth, spoken stuff.
A little bit from where I fly. I don't know if you can show
them. I got first about somebody out of here to get.
Yeah, that's it. That one would fly and make something better.
Most of my life is going to be an hour, so. Yeah,
I'm in here. Yeah, that's it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So again, I've heard some of you saying,
yes, this is one. Okay.
I've got a lot to do, but my childhoods,
the Pacific Northwest are looking at us a little bit.
I'm really looking to see that for a little bit.
So I didn't have my bipartisan scarlet. It was up there.
I'm not. No, I, I'm not.
They're all playing kinda. All this is your turn.
I'm ahead and One, two. He's
holding this watch.
I just created the longest in the Philippines,
uh, living here in three days and look at four days a week.
Yeah. Yeah, it's interesting.
We see each other in one another, so.
Yeah. I hope. If you're not around
in one day. You And, uh,
keep going out of here. Let's move back into some of the gather.
Once in a bit of a little gather. Keep going.
I don't quite like to see that all. I can't afford to hear me.
Yeah. See you for a day or two. It's nice to see you. It
was nice to see you. see you. It was see you. Uh,
some country guys. About three hours,
one minute. and So,
I used to go to Wisconsin a couple times and I went to Chicago
and . I never made it. I always got bogged in Chicago.
I finally said, I drove here,
flew up on a legion to ride.
Yeah, that's what I'm gonna do for now, huh? Yeah. Cause you can't, that
you're not. Yeah,
I've refused to connect through it,
but one that I didn't want to struggle out on the stand. Yeah. I've
gotten discriminated more times so not in that sense.
I hate that, but it's the biggest American.
American. So, I don't know why you're the West Coast.
I'm going to be in the house. I'm going to eat it.
Okay.
Yeah, my dad wanted to be trusted about your reason for a,
you know, almost never combine a connector. in the direction.
So. It doesn't
actually find to bring that land to you.
Yeah. There we go. I
don't want some tea there.
I love Cinque. Cinque is so much stuff.
That's, ah,
and there are completely, you want a bunch of it,
so it's nice and yummy. There's a couple areas there. So that's enough.
. . What I think about CTAC going to know
is, going to security there, going to the camera. Okay.
you Some of those lines,
I mean, the reason I got century used to all the way that shit,
if you don't have a century, hmmm. Oh, I see tax lines to go
to, to fly to Canberra or just, um,
be just, be, be, be there now with,
uh, uhm, last time. I mean,
I guess I was playing. Here, maybe they have a different thing that they
had. Seven different T.S.A.
Check points for one area,
right? And that one gets you to the case A,
B, and C. See you. And, uh,
yeah. I mean, now, you know,
it's this, it's this custom splurge, right?
Now, you have a little entry. It's been a long You don't even almost
need to stop walking. You can just walk right through the face of recognition
issue. Use a spot. I'll see you So,
that's almost that problem,
if you don't have a purchase, now you're getting a V.
They're sold, you know, I don't think that's good.
I don't think any more here a few months ago.
I just had the keys in for a check. I got it. Now I'm
going to get clear, since I sat on the bird for 7 minutes and
days, got this dog. I'm going to get clear so I can get clear.
And it's pretty short.
I'm not going to explain it because Charlotte is a fan of me. I'm
going to show she's going to do right now. You He's showing me,
he gives it that I'll do it. But, heh,
heh. I don't think it's such a freaking hustle. Heh,
heh, heh. Heh,
heh, heh, heh, heh, heh. It's a experience,
good practice. So stay tuned.
10. 10. People in London are going to have to get a sip of
your check. A couple of times there is a law in London about getting
a pointer in the camera. Heh, heh, heh. You better.
I'll see you I hate it because I didn't do it for a bit,
so yeah. So maybe you'll like get that one and share it.
Heh. Yeah,
we must apply that, but I don't like it once, cuz I don't mind.
You're still all trying to get through. Yeah.
Mm-hmm. I hate that I'm a someone on the way to your
work, but I don't really know how to do it. As soon as I
get it, I'm trying to get it structured. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, that'll be a lot.
Lastly, I'll put a soft link to get home and,
I had a riddle, which I hate to be with.
And I actually got no real room here with the client,
so I had- Yeah. About an hour to perform a flight.
And then he said, there are a couple flights I might get on,
so I went on there for a- Bye! That's what you're leaving here at
3.6. We're time to get back for sure.
Good job. It's not really.
So, yeah, not really hard.
Oh, I've been thought later because it's 3.6,
but I'll show you how to go. I'm going to move it. Alright,
nice. Plus, I mean that. Three out.
Yeah. Seven down. Seven. So,
my flight leaves here.
Three forty-one, like,
I landed on thirty-eight. Of course, going back,
it's faster, because you catch the- Okay,
I'll catch the wind. Yeah. Yeah. Umm,
but yeah. Uh,
forty-one at home, so,
yes. Yes. I have to worry about it.
You've been correctly in Charlotte? I've been not done enough in Charlotte.
So, I've been fronting on just,
he moved from Phoenix to Houston. He worked for Dwight for Ferguson.
And I just- All let's get Yeah, do this. Moved back to Raleigh.
Uh, yeah. And, uh,
his wife's family's there and the parents need to care.
Yeah. Yeah. That's about two hours each
so the new thing. Probably as long as I say it in the video.
Yeah. Yeah. I think I'm pretty happy to be able to be used
I'm going to move here. You know,
keep going this way. You know, back and forth.
Talk a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, depends on if they want to build a shop,
if they want to do something, uh, where they want to be with us.
Mm-hm. Mm Mm-hm. Mm Mm It's not.
I can be here. There. I
get the sense that let's hear that the assets we have.
I don't know. But. And try and. Make those more productive.
I get a sense there's some of that. I have to. it.
I mean, there's so much binding work, you know,
sending them on is busy here. But they're so,
hey, the center is starting to understand.
Let's let him. I need work, uh,
in Arizona's mining state. There's so much work,
and I can come here. We're not really set up to do mining scale.
I don't. Are
you very useful? What's your next closest shot?
Good job. Other than this, we had a shot.
Did you hear it like what, Steve? No? No,
no, no, no, no, no, no. To be continued.
In the conversation. 18 18 19 It's just something, a rang-up, you know,
just on the closet. Could you hear the last one?
What is it? How do you drive up there? Thank It's,
uh, pretty small. I mean, I think most of those stuffs,
like, type back and stuff.
That's right. I don't have a lot of The smaller one here.
What's the next closest one after that?
Casper one. I said, Casper only,
they have something Texas too. I'm very glad that at all.
I see it on the back. It was an important thing to do with
Casper. You know? Umm,
that's it. I think you're all paid for some parents,
you know? No. Bye. A lot of them don't cross these things.
I can't stop them. So,
uh, I've got to finish. There's,
My organic shop is supposed to be set up pretty well,
given who likes structural. Anyway,
there's no- I mean, they're important. A percent,
no you're putting around here! Deb, dum. Oooo.
Were we doing a bit by the minute?
Okay. Well, I think there's a very
sparse, it's a very structured shot.
Yeah. Yeah. Really? Mmm.
Hey, no, sir, when I walk your distribution, eh? But I think that's the
thought, couldn't be. But it's,
It's bringing, Oh,
it's bringing it right. Haha.
You got a plastic counter right there. Thank I got it over.
Somebody just got a come out there and gave it a stick.
You know, they got a little tiny pressed right here and a little tiny
shear. . That's the extended extraction,
which is an all-in-a-one, can you be reminded that you just can't.
That's an extended destruction set. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. So,
do you forget to mention that there is only a part of Part 2,
right? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
be heard before. So, I went there, I literally built that and she was
paid for every time I was a local. Now,
you can't even run it, and it's actually looking bad.
You I think it would be impressive if you didn't want us to be
rated so much. So.
And I've had it in 40 years and I don't. What's that?
Okay, we're on. No,
I just did. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Sim. Sim. Yeah, it's,
I don't know if it was a fly part of it. Yeah. But, most
of the- I'm sorry.
It's not like the aim of knowing that it's CPC.
It's not as long as that extra thing will. Yeah. Yeah.
That's, like, the multi-relationship that is.
I will withdraw and then the machine will discount.
No.
Was she not at the end of the day? Well, we're about everything,
but we shouldn't say she's not. We didn't know that the battery wasn't working.
We We didn't have this machine for the, Great.
I mean, barely two years. Why are the batteries working on that?
So. Go. I
mean, it worked out. Yeah. So. Good job.
Hi, I'm You know what I mean?
What's going on here? I kinda know. I think,
at least. And it always has. you It was at least 30 million dollars,
sure. So,
it's contained a little bit. And now,
breathe. We gotta settle. Go. You're about to get an equipment.
Look, dude, good to go. Yeah. Yeah.
It has a third. It just means to me that.
But if I'm, uh, now I'm coughing,
I'm not leaving. For
having this to be a month. I still don't Don't anywhere.
You're not Every just part of the piece,
man. Shut up, man. Go ahead.
I'm working on the name right now.
I even- I don't even I don't I don't even think this is this
job that we're going to use to all the- I
don't know the rest of the video today. That's the feeling that you still
can't help. Okay. With the jobs and actually you need shit wrong at the
end. Okay. This was not my biggest fight.
Somebody didn't like- One less child,
and I think they want it because they didn't do a bridge into child.
But there's no reason that a child went at the plant.
It should be competitive.
Here, here, and just that's up to Phoenix and just North Phoenix and Clarksdale.
See you. But I think
that's what everybody's saying. There's no reason.
Like, I think in the pipeline, we would- Okay,
let's sit in that. I have to say, that's my plan. If they can
sell for a form, you can just farm that out.
Question, go ahead. It's how- I don't think we're ever going to be able
to- That was a strong work.
It's just not going to be a job that fits here and for it.
A lot. I think you see what they do in that one.
Me too. Yeah. It's not going to be a job that's
going to be And back to the bone.
Back to all the difficult customers. You know, everybody's going to forget to dive
in them. Oh, they're brutal. Very documentation.
I look up at it anytime soon. I look up at the drives that
you can go on. See, back to the other. They get,
they get some open worlds. It's not too bad.
No. That's really unusual about it, but it's,
for your evidence, all the typewraps,
it is like, it's called the major.
We'll see minute. Crisis, you know, it's good to forgive you.
But I think it's a tricky job, but I don't think we're set up
here to do it. You get the drawings in November 26th,
and you got to deliver 7,000 times. You said March of 27th.
Yeah, it is. It's, it's,
it's all fun. Ah,
it just means that some day I'm, they're,
they're not even. You I'm not to release it yet, cause they don't,
they didn't have to. What? Yeah,
I see it, I believe in that one of these.
Same way as asking. We have the, tepla,
can we have stuff? The end of the time is pretty fun,
too, it's like, ugh, you're gonna be doing all this size,
and you have a short period of time, again. Thank So
the truth of that, that thing, if you look at the e-mail-
Yeah. And after those,
I couldn't even have worked to see that.
But I think it actually came from some- I mean,
Denver, that hurt about this.
And, uh, I don't think it was here.
I think it was stuck somewhere else. Umm.
You And then they gave her an extension until the twenty-second,
uh, they marked what we think out of the twenty-second to put the bid
in. So how are we-
We're not. It's just a bidding exercise. I think we're going to find out
that back to the shop's weather. Yeah.
And there's gonna be, that's just my guffin.
And that's gonna be the most historical show I've watched in my Because
there's not much out there. Salt Lake City,
much out there. Yeah, it's the beginning. SME.
And that's all I can Yeah,
I haven't told you to look at it.
I mean, they probably aren't responding to them for short. I'll catch you next
time.
So, send them all out there.
Alright? Alright? There's no lady that has another blackboard
Yeah, right. Ah, ah, ah,
hm, hm, hm, hm, hm,
hm, hm.
I don't like it. I like to, uhh,
actually just have that thought. Then I'm into the one unit with that.
After I intake the j- I was already working in Canada.
My community there.
That, uh, was We'll see how it goes. Yes. So I went there to
run that shop and stopped.
I'll see you down in
the panel at the same time. I know you've got to work with people
that are 100-bit okay. See ya.
And I know- I know they have one up here too even then.
I know they've got to, you know, get that shot here.
Thanks for engaging probably. Okay. It's like,
alright, I have two yards.
It's like, I need something like it. Wait up.
Thank you. Now.
You I do not to go in
anyways. There's- Just in,
in Salt Lake, just a little south of Salt Lake,
and it's going to be all these over here.
Alright, so you're going to be with them. I don't want them to manage
their, their, their KSM ski jobs.
I don't want them to drive the KSM ski jobs here.
Yeah. Yeah. These aren't because they're a structural steel and plate that
was ignoring them softly. Yeah,
but I don't know what was last to me.
Umm, they're, they're in the J.T.
Spiel is spurtin' literally about two blocks from S.A.
Okay. I don't I'm really not gonna sit.
So, they need to.
I haven't mentioned anything yet. And I want a little bit of workout,
but these are good. When I was in the first time I got to
talk, I couldn't get it. Yes, but. We need to so much
of this stuff. I'm gonna be sorry. I'm gonna be sorry.
I'm gonna be sorry. What's that?
I'm gonna be sorry. Sorry. I thought,
you know, art is an anime and something to do with it.
Well, yeah, I think that's not gonna be the type of thing that has
to be- . I want to. that did it.
It says, I told them, currently, he became the authorities,
I've arrived. And he said, C.O. C.O. C.O. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Okay.
There you go. I know that's interesting. Okay,
I'm gonna take a few of those. Okay.
I know that's fine.
Bye
.
Let's see if I can read
it and like once because it was done.
you But they want to sell us,
uh, labor that's semi-truck law,
clean up, to re-mittal industries,
really. . . And, you know, maybe one thing,
if we took play, sold it to the job.
Good job. So these heads were once divided
into the edges.
... ... ... that's fine. I don't have time to run
like, I mean. You 896,
240, 4-3, 4-3,
6-8, 8-9. That's,
that's wild. And,
uh, they got a seat in person.
One of you's through, uhh, hmmm.
itzelah. I've got 3316, I think that's the lowest they go.
Uhm, there's only 964,
is that 46, uhh,
said. . . Ah, the limit. And what it's like,
Smith's up, there around 64.
for So that's not the Texas,
alright? They'll deliver it.
Because they got trucks coming into the valley. And then a lot.
And then it's going that way. It's just great.
They just can't judge it by the night. I don't have,
and that's kind of what I'm pushing to get this in the front.
Because if I don't have a solid plate, it'll be close. We'll be right
Alright guys, so Fun, I guess there's some arts that have jobs.
And the track, the usage isn't going to divide a conqueror and skeleton with
everything but- . Then I'm gonna get started.
I've got a good flake inventory. I can pull a cost into and-
. I and then call it out to myself.
Yeah. And and do kind of an intro.
Are we done? That's all, period. Thank you much.
I want to use the word easy, but I don't want to use the-
I don't think this is really, uh,
but it's super, super simple. We'll see you Yeah,
I, I, uhm,
that's one of two types of super quick. So.
Yeah, that'd be our best edit machine.
You Yeah, of all of them. I hear nothing but good things,
and they're like the investors. Yeah.
In the beginning, forget. There go. It's a-it's a-it's a-it's
asound good. You're the music guy and might not want to come and pick
it up cause now Michael trunks down in her and.
Yeah, that's the thing though. He beats everybody's prices here and then like,
well, he's-he's eating them. Oh yeah, this guy.
There's the 26 cents a pound in the infrastructure.
I'm like, okay, I wouldn't have sat. And then I'm just gonna get So
How's that working, exerias? Uhh,
well, they pick up our interior. It'll pick it up there again,
and I'm gonna bring it back. So, I didn't. Just.
. It's really affecting us. But, ah, maybe we have a lot of alpha-9
in it. I think it's stuck across the border,
uh, my issue with the- I don't mean to eliminate the trucks
to get that done. There's times where,
like- I don't get it moving up the bus, because we have the one
extra piece of it, and then there's a bit of all the LITRs.
It's easy to deal with. Okay, by the way, we had two or two
pieces, uhh, because there was an offer to go.
Let's go. Start. So,
I'm talking to the ladies. See the, you know, you should get back to
me. You know, I can't find that stuff,
you know. I've been, you gotta have a couple names,
it's a call. Oscar, and somebody else is like,
it's like, pulling feet in the whole language. If I can look it up.
Yeah, I don't want my head. This is pretty good,
uhm, pretty good. It's back and forth with,
uhm, that's good. I'd say,
uhm, good bo- the operation of all my projects is sure to get off
of this. Really? So, then even,
I mean, next door to materials that I'm still looking for.
So we're also about two months,
but I'm just keeping it in any regard. I love it.
I think it was a really big deal right here. Yeah.
Yeah. That's really good.
I think so. That's what I thought.
Yeah. Very good. Yeah. I Come here.
I think they've been around for forever since our time.
So yeah. So they got that,
that mark. It's making it hurt. Uh, nah.
I heard the little mexico thing. I've never heard that. I think they're what,
are you Mexican? Yeah. Yeah.
You Yeah, Mark. Could you repeat them while I had,
uhm, uhm, could progress all the way down there into the facility.
That'll be mexico. Okay. And that it can sound like a clock,
or they can call the, uh, the keep all the workers,
a, a task force. more. So they can't figure out something
to do. And everything's all,
we're into the team there. Very accordingly.
or anything. I just don't trust the stuff that we can have with somebody
sometimes in this film. I seeing my I love seeing I love this I
love seeing There was a while there we got into the tip of it,
the gravels because they couldn't get in there in front of it.
See ya. Thank Yeah, I was there.
That's an oldie. Uh,
thank you. Thank I didn't expect a 130-25.
Ah, that was a while ago. Hahaha. Hahaha.
Hahaha. The instate's been there,
some of us, uh, probably has talked more bad,
I don't mean. That's including where I've started to occur.
Umm, uhm, post, has taken me from the top of the sector.
Uh, it is an entry into the sport.
The only- The only thing that I also believe is being,
uh, uhm,
approximately I mean, cutting eggs, cutting a lot of all of their materials.
It's been no reason by direction that every body will possibly be less
than a minute. I challenge the first victory on that.
See, oh!
That was pretty close. That's all I'm going to need about 16 grams,
so I'm guessing we'll just stay adding on the, on the habit of this.
thank you. Oh. Or it's copying this one,
I guess, is probably gonna get this order placed tomorrow.
Go some in the- Yeah,
awesome.
You you Yeah.
But, you know,
I don't work. Uh-huh.
Let's do a quick pass and see
if, uh, a king of the industry.
you Thank you to the Port of 307.
So, I know.
Hm, hm.
Bye. I've
had some lessons in the rest. Thanks much.
Uhh,
You know what I You know what I mean.
Come back to your home. Back to your- You know what for
Good.
One thing that I'm questioning
here is that that's about if I direct you down by the right doesn't
end it and direct you. That points
on where the program actually is.
Umm. Okay. I
mean, it couldn't be, like, man, I have both. I don't know about the
words. It's a bad choice. We'll see you So,
which version I wanted to run for that case?
It may be with only one inch force for riding on the base,
but it's just different than mine. So,
ah, okay. There you go.
Let's see. Mmm.
. . Just try to see that.
Um, the P bring in a little bit.
So I
was going to be sitting at home and seeing your reason why it would
be a different thing to be a recipe. to be the first This is
the same service in privacy. Okay. Unless
it's just not uhm, uhm, I mean they can have that.
They can start it, but I mean they can create it and not start
it with the service. That might be the only other thing.
Good. Whilst trying to pull the picture back
there. It's all over.
It's on. You see that? Wow, there's shots over here.
So, usually it's just like, you want to go outside search and you run
that part too. But that was- I remember that once and I don't
know. That was her misquining. She was like,
yeah, that's her name. Great. Just go ahead
and put something in the generations for the work. Okay.
Umm,
yeah, ehm. Thank you.
Um, you can say that there's a moment,
uh, from both sides. Um, you can still go here. Alright.
So. . . Okay.
Seeing a new college should be, uh,
so far. 4 3 No,
no, no, no, no,
no, no, No, no, You've been apparently submitted everything for our games.
This is the only one over Thank you.
That's perfect.
It's been intense. It's been intense. It's been intense. You It's .
Yeah.
you
This is going to be a crunch. That's just the amount that you had
to find in it. Yeah. Here it asks,
can you look where? There.
I think it's that portrait of that on theaters.
purposes.
Uhh,
uhh,
uhh, uhh, uhh, hm.
. . . Okay.
Okay.
Right.
What's the default? Bye bye. Is more often treated with sex?
Ah, I can get it to me the only word that I can Like
it's what gives us a very loud, hard time.
Well,
I don't know. I don't know. It's the opposite one.
It's the kitty peoples. . . It's the same here.
I see. Thank you.
Yeah,
he just likes to go over two and eat some.
Thank you. Bye. Church of London. You
Skips.
Thanks.
Umm, uhh, uhh, hm, hm.
Mercy and I.T.
That's uh,
seems to be the bottom of the- I was used to the loader,
just walking out of the server and eating popcorn. Yeah,
I can eat. I can eat.
Yes, I can eat, okay. Bye Umm,
jimmy, jimmy, jimmy, jimmy,
jimmy, jimmy. Umm,
there's one up up. We move in the name of the photo that we
can. That's chivalrous,
son. Okay,
so I'm gonna show all of
you.
I love the crowd here. But, you
know, I'm loving that you there could be dead. Okay.
Good. All right. All right.
Yeah. Good ball.
And that was a normal blue jewelry. We'll guys in the next one. There's,
uh, one year,
uh,
one year, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm, That's
why I'm going to place a little bit bigger in the yard.
3 4 5 So
they can just go wrong in here. man.?
1 That's fine.
But I don't know why. I don't think that's the way it system. You
know, you share. Ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh. I'm going to go.
Yeah. Yeah, that's my new one.
I heard someone made me want to have it on my second, so he's
been doing a lot of other things. So, happens here. All
right, let's excuse me, ladies and gentlemen. Stop here,
I'm running an official name, Mary. I don't have any team in this room.
Thank you. Oh, okay. I meant the other thing,
but, uh, there's more on the next presentation,
yeah. All right. We're winning,
or I'd use probably every start-out server is where everyone's gonna serve
it, and it should be in, like, land.
Yeah, that's what it is. Our regular one's working just fine.
Uhm, it's just this new port and not having- I saw
it with it, so. But we can
at least go over, uhm, kind of. I'll see you what
I'm here looking for. I'm there. I'm assuming probably pretty similar to that dog.
He is definitely known for wire with me.
It's a place of water broke out in there,
in cages, and the purpose of the lines of the wire,
and then the purchase of the light at least. For,
I guess, five items for a electrical start.
Uhm,
and uh, hopefully it will never happen to the water in the Indian season.
It's been a stressful morning to you all. I remember this one.
Okay. All right.
All right.
But, you know, you normally have, like, hundreds to drop, but yeah, boom. Umm,
um. Bye. I mean,
it's like 47,000 feet, but uhh.
Um, the idea,
the biggest, the biggest concept, um,
is, We're putting a lot of effort to do any bin modeling,
uhm, on the actual side,
but you see just support. The level
of detail we're going to go through for a lot of models. the It
is, I mean, it's an LED 400,
so it's worth the model and that's in washroom.
It's pretty out here,
so. So, if we're putting such a cost into doing this,
I want to be a little leveraged, uhh,
the abilities of- hmm, so that we can actually
run it through,
As this if it were a structural thing,
right? Uhm, and where I'm running- Thanks
for running to is it's where all the assemblies are,
for the most part, unique from a struggling- I'm struggling.
In a rod length, but from the grand scheme of things,
we're only like 10 different types of designs. We're just good at what we're
doing. Umm, and then, But everything's done with that.
So, if I knew just an IFCX for that,
I would use all of my metadata.
So, I don't really know that it's a keep my glasses straight.
I don't know that it's half the brad, it's just a body shape there.
I know. So what I've been working on is within revenue,
I can actually create a VOM that has accept.
Prangers and then. And. and And we can actually create a stencil spreadsheet that
defines what those are. And if we can leverage that I appreciate
where we can bring that in. And technically, technically,
we need to know that it's the exact body from the model standpoint.
We just need to know how to correlate it soon. And
so if we can come up with that system and figure out where to
carry those cut lengths. Thanks.
And just the overall assembly types.
I think we could just treat it as a word of fact.
And we could still do our. Bye.
We can still do our cues, we shippings,
everything like that. And so our budget will pre- We're talking,
I mean, thousands of trapey supports.
We can, you know, do the same thing for it.
Saw, operator. I'm going a little And then you take care of all of
this, uhm, cutless,
that he's been given that day. Yeah. And then go for that.
So that's like a deep picture that's on Of what?
We're trying to accomplish. So I can,
uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm,
see here. Here we go. We can make sure I understand some of the
feedback while I think I understand. Uhm, you're looking- If please the ship in
and have you're working on export without you that say no,
we're getting the right format. Two more of them here than we can do
the best thing before. So, we've been considering a case file,
I think, and I'm not saying on themselves files.
Bye. And it's the easiest thing that we can clearly
define what that material is.
It's from itself. Yeah. Umm,
and then, and then I've developed a little trick.
It's been working so far as my gaming commission on,
like. Bye. Like, uh, uh,
TR1 is a single-tiered,
trippy support, and then it can come up with,
you know. So,
all of it, they're all usually typically rise and then,
like, a B would be, the top definition would be a B in fact.
And, like, a big hatch,
uh, spring down on the other side or something.
Yeah, I can show you how to look at it. better time to do
like this. . . I don't know if shooting it.
But I think . . . I can build a beetle wound .
. within rabbit to You need whatever parameters you need.
Yeah. Well,
it can be easy, uhm, important. Okay.
Well, right. And it had a lot of,
a lot of themes on it, and I'll share the ones that are,
that are required things. Thanks. The next part is what you guys have been
doing with, like, the chair of the database is a special extract.
It's the same thing you did, um, e-go is.
Because here they're gonna have just a standard K-1000 people,
they're running, they're pretty unique shapes,
and then we're talking.
You know, y'all might have seen further cold,
you know, they're not going to stay in this,
but they're not a lot of big, cold that we haven't.
Three. Two
tests fasten in my head, stay in power,
you should see my video. Thank you. I'm not if there's any mess in
that That's true.
My voice plays the word for spinning. So much money in a wholesale,
just engage in a level of detail that in the new R.I.R.
a lot of our bins were required. Okay, bye. So here,
where's the actor
that you Thank you. So we might as well be fabricating it to
that. Yeah.
So what I've done in the past so far is,
like, I would send, uhm,
the, these guys, just a, a list of shots.
Go. Right? Or list of raw things or anything like that.
And they just kind of mainly put it in and we'll be able to
deliver it and go back. Alright. Oh. But I definitely want to take it
a step further on.
Thank you. Yeah, and then I
still think we just have the flexibility during the one-offs,
like, this wire is taking the time. Yeah. And.
Yeah. Because I don't think that's anything we want to build into
our system, as part of the wire lengths,
is what makes it this. and this is the end of That's just kinda
what I want to to deal with.
Or just bring yourself out and have a linear, linear session.
Yeah. Perfect. Yeah, Yeah. BuhThree Yeah, I may say no,
I'm glad you agree with it. You know, it's not a good length,
5 length. It's, it's just only a good length for people.
And then when it's, it's a, And, you know, curse down the,
you know, ask, it's like a sheer nesting. Like, let's be read about,
you know, we don't have, you know, curved cuts on the monitor.
But, yeah, uhm.
Suddenly, you're the best. It's been,
I- I've been on it. I just haven't got to the point of the-
the any more excited. I'm just- I'm just trying to get ours up.
Let's grab it. Friends,
it's a different thought approach on how to build your assemblies here.
It's their family approach to the city.
You have to kind of have a good degree set up beforehand.
And it's not as, to me it's definitely not even- you have useful
in a prefab application, in a type where yes,
umm, but. Bye. It's the industry standard to do an mechanical
design. It's bad.
It's good. It's good. Thank you.
And then all the other
software research on how other,
The actual top, the width,
yep. And they're bringing the rabbit, but then it's very,
it's very cumbersome, compared to the,
Like, one stop, oh, they're technically hard,
guys. Like, they're still doing their part of cues and combining in a separate
area. eeuh, so, not directly from estimating where new they need.
And if you follow me, I'll go over that. I'll go over that.
I'll just go and tell So, would you do at least the trial,
uh, sit for a month? Because, well,
we can't say, and they're stuck in the air out there,
but it's a bit more than There's one thing soft around here
that- that you actually- I
would say combine and extract better.
Yep. And it's only really useful though.
All right. So over here. Oh, okay. We're to go. You're trying to actually
breathe out, like, a face of conduits that,
you know, and then also, like, growling, like an entire room.
You're gonna be, It's got a more suited for that,
but it's not, it's still not producing cutless,
it's still not nesting, it's just treating it like uhh.
Uh, B-O-N, and you know what, you're flying,
I guess, and leads into a shipable. Yeah.
It doesn't, the cover, like I said, the purchasing doesn't cover any- and the
labor tracking doesn't cover it, so it should be able to sleep better.
So, uh, what's happening, like, in one here,
we describe it in the water. Well,
I'm gonna make this work.
And it's, cause it's, our feet have at least a dirt.
And, um, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm. Also 100% adjustment,
sure, easy, it's an basic support. So, a lot of stuff we're doing.
It's, it's single conduit runs, uh,
it's nothing else we need to, to free fabric, like,
a fuel bank and give out the fuel.
I think that- I don't want
to hear that one. It's like, it doesn't invite me to easily implement.
it. you And then, and then move on to the next part of the
studio. I think it's gonna give you a stage box that will lead to
you. I'll say it to you quickly.
You get it all before I do.
It's just like, uhm, let me give you some points and then we can
route it to separate shops. So, I'd say,
yeah, this shops, uhm. . Slow down,
we can route all of our truck processing here.
And we can have a lot of fun with cuss, yeah. It's time to
make you do- final assembly dash shot.
Yeah, vermin. I mean,
cuz we- we did all those silky frames, right?
And that would have been- She kind of leveraged out at the flexor shop,
where we did a done here, we did a done some here,
some there. Um,
but, umm, I'm not sure. Yeah, because that's our lecture shops.
More, more geared towards the higher drawing stuff,
but we got the big. . . Okay, and so.
So, here's a
spreadsheet such as reduced. so far.
.
.ok . I'll send to you now with Ye,
it's- . . It's time to do that this
way. Yeah,
I think it's okay if it does something. I love you. Hm.
Ah. Mercy.
Hm. I sure.
You like, if I ask, there's nothing you have to be able
to see from the end. Or. ,commissioning
your big media of that is almost true,
you can say about the address. So it is really good.
You I said that's supposed to be which important you're in and you just
buy it in. Yeah. Cause it's all set up and you save it.
You know, we're paying it and that can be fine.
updates.
Up
in the teens. Hah. Um,
ehm, ehm, So, it's of our higher volume type products
for, like, the data side. So,
it's definitely an- a lot more of the same assemblies,
but, uh, same concept. I don't know why it's just the,
uh, larvae number of- But uh,
you need some of those verses by your lines.
So go to the last day, Kevin. Bye. And
so, pretty much with, You can set up for the pre-drive guys as you
have. You can go to the lab,
just have some art. Assemble time.
And then it gives you your actual,
you know, parameters of what, the dimensions of what.
And then those kinds of work poorly. Now we can move this chart a
little bit. Try to be soft enough.
Just look at that version. You So the chart is based off of your
tier 1 tracks, and then,
first one on the label, and then your- lane
is into your strut length, it's up to there.
Yup. And then, buy it into a pilot,
so I can- big set it down to- Okay, a few one thousand,
and I can, yeah.
And then, wrong lane,
right side, so. So, So, there's all the pandas are in there,
and we can build this however we need to organize it,
and then I can also relabel. And all that really means for me to
kick off a job to say, hey, these are the, this is how we
can make a look. And that's how we can establish all of our actuals
of sizes to where kind of like our detailed standards of it.
Any . Just to say, p1000 tapping team,
you know, kind of fan. So, uhm.
So, um.
So. I don't see someone like it,
but yeah. Scroll back,
scroll back up to the, uhm,
so that. That's what's, it was in the surrounding,
right? Right. So the T1 EC1,
0, 0, 0. You is the whole same length?
Is that correct? Okay, well,
when you, you were to have not need to,
but if you're not, but if you're And if you can look at where
those are labeled out, we'll see that, that one's able to call it.
Okay. Sound of means that our symphony.
Okay. Okay. And then the components within
that are basically the rods on the happy trails.
on this.
That's it. That's incredible.
There is some instances where you would have three supporters on one strut
link. So. So, Yup. You don't actually see anything on the computer channel.
Sign up for worst days, but. This one really only had some R1 and-
R2, okay, wrong position. Yup.
I actually. Didn't think different.
Yeah. And either. You So basically.
actually like a standard one-inch this
one so basically we would be,
uhm,
you're talking about the, like, um, of that one Utah.
You talk. I'm talking about four simply,
so you got eight rounds out of two foot long.
That was an, uh, uh,
one's an, uh, two. So,
to give that in the tech line,
um. So,
required fields are quantity,
drawing number. We'll see you Made more,
piece more, description,
grade, and length. So.
Hello. That name is Assembly.
I'm thinking we're going to do a,
uhm. out. A
little label. To the strum,
it's instruct type. One of our biggest cereal.
Uhm, is that?
I got, bought it as used as a cut,
as that one is the next cut. That's gotta be cut,
personally. That's for Okay,
so,
uhh.
I'll see what I got in the technical terminology.
I'm thinking about the shortest maintenance,
right? And then you got,
an R learning an R2 as part of us.
But it can't be called an R2 because all of those,
are different, like, bubbles are different, and these are different lights.
Yeah, so, I would be,
ehm, ehm, ehm. And our action is zero,
zero, with your labels, two, zero,
So, uhm,
and then R1, and then 0, 0,
1, yeah, R1, 0,
0, 2, and then- I mean,
if any of you are in the same, same length of a R1 or
2, I guess you can technically change those,
but to keep them in the same way. I didn't believe on that,
I didn't seem to keep them huge per year.
So, technically, with what we have in our database,
we're going to let know what There are five database with the P1000s and
the standard raw. I hope they could be able to run this one.
We'll be happy in here. Yeah.
Yeah. Because while they're searching by ours, I can't.
Because I can create one of these assemblies,
uhh, uhh, better than they call me. I don't have a family for it.
I can't really decide the way that I can go through and combine all
the like links. Thanks. Yeah, to call a new program,
right? So, if, if there's a way within our nesting zone.
So, We can,
we can combine life lengths together.
Even though they'd be unique, we could still have our stuff like a bundle.
I mean, I mean, as you guys well look at,
you know, whatever, the quantities that we show up to go.
Others, they would just know and just say, okay,
I would put all my two foot lengths in on the pile,
and then as the assemblers come,
I'll say, okay, I need to make a T.Y.C.1, make sure the two foot
then ends full out of their R1 with two,
whether you're sending them away. Because what I'm trying to get away from
is, I'm trying to utilize R2.
Oh, I'm just gonna stick out because we have an immense mass.
To be able to round up all of our family lengths,
too. I'm trying to get to, like,
four, I think we're only going to be able to forget the little one.
Just to imagine, you know,
shot guys go. you know, some uh,
fraction marks of nutrition, infractions. Yeah.
Yeah. So, uh, yeah.
Uh, so but that's my..
how do you function? I will do the BLM when we export,
so we shouldn't technically have to deal with any of that,
but. Yes.
Well, the same material is the material type,
like the strut of the same material type of buttons.
Not always, but you're gonna have.
Releasing's are going to be typically done in,
like, by area. So, like,
across the area, so we're going to all be, It's kind of most stainless,
and then once you get into, you know, exterior it'll be galvanized or something
like that. So, will that later be in this table,
or? Is that given globally or somewhere else?
We wouldn't, I would assume that when I define my strut type,
we wouldn't expand it out. So, just keep.
The actual P1000 number.
Okay. And then there would be, like, a P1000.
And that's true. Yeah.
And then that would- I'd be able to find into the debris flowless traps
from all the industry. Correct. Okay. What about the uhh,
uhh, rods? Well, that's Hold on.
They always the same thing or a certain different types of material for the
unit element. You have different grades available.
Okay. That's correct. All right. So,
you know, we're gonna need to be rock, rock that's in there as the
shape, and then create a Just do it.
Shit. . . You should already,
I'll show you. You already security. I'm not talking about We
were doing like, the almost a trade rap. I'm probably gonna be the only
one that is the best. Yeah. Right, so.
And again, it's kind of, we were doing it to your horizons.
I had some that we were designing within Revit,
which the design of the unit of the Revits is very simple.
Everything, all your text pieces are all kind of hard of a handling.
Uhm,
but it was a pain. And we needed these guys to actually propagate them,
and it was kind of uh,
they're treated as a structure component that they're designing.
Yeah, they did. Um,
and so we did a lot. That's where I think the database subscribed.
Pretty messy for those students. Some. you within running and I was doing something
within, you know, uhm, I actually advanced the old majority of the
students once. Alright. Is that some advanced deal with this actual
student? Actually, yeah,
it's uh, it's like, it's actual student.
Yeah,
it uh,
like, well,
with here, here. Spiderality over here,
intro is right over here.
I kind of just stuck it out there and said,
we're not doing anything. We're just going to you know, geez,
they're buying. Exactly. But it's,
it's real. It's, it's just like within,
like, techno structure. You can build families out and do the same thing within
the auto settings. It, it's set up,
right? It works. Straight, but, uh,
they're talking about, uh, and the wiping it and cutting it into a plug-in
for a bit. Yeah. So, that statement.
That's awesome. It's not a long way.
Other issues, uhm, but, You're going to
get 100% It's easy on me.
I said, okay, I'm in here. And they, you know, they're cleaning out so
you just have one specific call off for each.
See ya. Don't. Just because we have,
I mean, one and five eighths back at the back, one and five eighths,
one and five eighths solid, and then one thousand.
And it's P1000,
so. Well, that's, yeah.
That part of our actual kickoff was- you technically they're all always- they're
all very similar in the P1000s,
but you have action unistrattics different than- .
That's Ph.D. Coughles, I come to do their so different manufacturers.
So they're ... they're ... they're ... they're ... someone ever change the world
but also kind of limited with specs. Thanks. But actually,
I definitely, that's something easier to clean up on how we do that.
Yeah. So, it's definitely really good. Thanks for having us figure that out.
We're starting to figure out how to deal with these on the ground.
That's the meaning of it. It's kind of like, it's my time.
Because I've got to figure out on how to do what's available and what
we can leverage from Revit. I think you just need to start it from
what tech will, Except,
yeah, I can build the U.S. into a company.
So, go and see if you can, back around
here to get close to this, and then technically use your system instead of
bottom. And then,
Search for, uh,
excellular work inputs. words.
There may be more to production
control in E.C. See you soon. So,
the- How all of these fields are needed?
You can tell I'm aware of you want to, but don't remember being marked,
peaceful. I don't know. That's not gonna be required.
So, if you get into this format,
Maybe you'll be able to do it where you're shaping the bench,
you're in the same field. I think there's a good form of type for
that. So, if it's not split out of shape with the bench,
it's separate. But, ah,
I guess you're really not in fine shape. In the story,
she gave me my heart, so. No, I mean, those would be fine down
to just, yeah.
Umm, you know, struggle. Umm, or, ah. So,
that's, that's pretty much it that you can use in the other fields that
you want to, like you want in chemicals.
But that, so,
I wouldn't make a mistake.
I have seen the spirit, the drawing and main board piece mark
will be decided. And the strut will be- you know,
I'm going to go and see what it is.
And then your rides will be going down the main board to be the
safest strut. Bye! It's not a case mark of the R1's,
you know, you can bridge it somehow.
It's hard one to actually hear what you want to do with it.
And, ah,
shit, a lot of me. I mean, we can go off here and get
here and just, in,
or in, and see what happens. If that works,
it will go for good. Yeah. Take that.
. . If
you have, uh, an export, then you know,
get me You want to just pick one line on top of that?
Draw them in the middle of the line? Good. Yeah,
like that. P1, c1, uu,
uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh, uhh.
Coming up with, and this might be too much work,
but it was something I was just thinking about. It I think,
possibly. I agree. I don't should say within some
structure I could create a kiss out that would be defined as me.
One of those assemblies, and then create that as
a body and figure out just some way of manipulating my own kiss.
It's fine. Well, essentially with the links and then just using that as just
a single import. Oh, and, uh,
I wasn't worried too much about trying to- Of course,
you get a kiss file. Really, in my mind,
you get a kiss file, and that's it. There's none.
Bye So, if the exhale makes it each year,
then I'll just use the exhale.
Cause once, I think, what's nice to do is- 1 Then we get that
situation where building some sort of a field change,
right? And then we have a, uhm, like, a sort of, uhm,
the blank ordering system, we lift the guys and then spill out,
you know, length, width, height, whatever, and then just send it in to A.
I, you know, Jimmy's script.
. of the design, so I need 30 of these water,
right? And then we can just let it back in here,
and we can type in and export. Squirt. Yeah.
Alright, you're looking to,
Do estimates for this sit here as well?
Um, at this point,
probably no. So the way that,
the way that election was estimated, uhm,
they actually have a pretty,
The field is the kind of way there is main software works.
They just put it on parameters that we can support over 60,
and draw a conduit run. So, but in what would actually
be the long term.
Some of it would be nice, would be from a project management standpoint.
We'd be able to actually, to be able to come up with real estate.
Yeah, so you're not going to blow the load of them.
Yeah, kind of. Maybe not. Bye. So,
uh.
I'm not a man, I'm not a person. So,
if we look at them to create the cut of this,
and what not, we- You
Yeah, almost 100% of the time.
I don't like throwing up with that.
It would be um. So, we'll see you I can believe my look out
of the options. I'm talking about for licensing.
Umm, you can really have one,
sorry. All right. I'm going to go inside,
cover, or share with her.
Yeah, I shouldn't cover I'm going to call it Fortanities in
the airport. Umm,
so I'm going to get to you. I'm leave them on the other edge
side. They're probably a little separate.
Yeah, I'll go separate some now. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. But I believe they're,
they're almost safe. They're operating. All right. I don't think
they would actually know.
No. But if you want two different databases,
then, um, currently get a new,
you're getting signed up there. . . . . this your with radiation can
only point to one of the databases, it can't really be heard or warned.
. . And the dynamics are just another integral that I'm at this standpoint.
. . Um- . . Yeah,
like, I mean, if we want to sit right,
sit right back in all three shots, right? And you want your own leg.
Here's all my job, very good. And that's going to be a totally different
day. I switched to what we were trying to do.
I opened up a lot. And I,
I mean. Thank you. I would say,
I mean, I can't really be feeling the same. You know,
they're all question coordinators, but it would be just- You know,
would be easy to have an electric coordinator operating the same
zone as them, or the same as- 7 and then,
uhh, it's no reason it should be modding either.
Or if we can just send it to these guys.
And then they can produce the cutlets.
And then it just gets, it gets routed to,
you know, they like it with you. Right? And then, uhh, uhh, We kind
of executed her later. Yeah,
it's an essential need to develop all of you to the same server server.
I'm not one of those guys. That's what we're doing in the issues.
I'm nothing. But there's no reason,
especially if the size is defined. spine. We have to create college for all
the jobs and their enemies to find more help from everything.
And. and And then,
you can't be able to more, you can't go less than that.
You can use it over there to access the compost to see if it's
even here. Yeah. Yeah. Just go do it. I can see it here,
but I think it hurts. It is,
it is okay. It's like, but, yeah. It'll come with its own kick up,
so I'm sure. Yeah. But, I mean, I don't know whether it's hurting.
All right. With our current workflow and everything like that,
I would see this. I don't need maybe one towel over it that was
for, and in just, We'll you in me. Yeah, my opponent just have control
over it and he was being dug into the back.
God is his. Teams. As he goes into an outcome team.
Now you want to do umm,
like, ehm. You want to try
other things within the system after cutting your,
uhh, try- I have to shake me a little bit of my heart there.
Ideally, yeah, we'd, we would have to,
you know, cause we're going to break me. We'll see We're going to break
things down into, like, separate work packages,
so you'll have, you know, this, you won't even spread out across,
you know, and settle. And so the guys working,
you know, in area one.
Bye It'll be shipped out as an area of one back.
It'll check for it. I'm trying to keep it bundled to where it,
,directly goes to site and stage to that area. It won't have to shake
everything out. It'll be in a secret,
so it's fast, but it'll be in the end.
And that's kind of how we're setting up.
That's how we're kind of setting up a plane need any way.
We have that work package so, so correlating them backwards from
our, our take-off. Uh-oh. Go.
Go. Cause we're obviously just been learning like what you're doing within
structures and as far as like that. Once it goes,
it gets claimed and kind of builds it. All right,
so we're using that same, they call it acid track,
but it's the same concept that I did. And,
it was. Wouldn't be that when the muscle work back is great and it'll
automatically create something you want to make some of this.
Yeah, we bring, we could bring them in as separate lots.
Bye, guys. And combine them as lots.
Yeah. And then still get the efficiency out,
so it'll be able to track it separately.
Perfectly. So
do you just try to get them in like, uh,
uh, like, ehm, well. you I
keep 20 out of there and went typical that I've been getting in.
Now I'm over to pasta. Thank you. So we gotta set that up in
the, yeah, first of the maintenance and all
of that. We have get the lights in there.
You don't have any bits. The fast ones we have are in order,
yeah. That's Yeah. No.
It's a great,
it's not a good area. Or is that great to use? use.
We've got a number of grades in there.
You get to have down with the bottom of the middle of the middle
of the grade, too. You If you leave that
blank, you're bringing all the grades that are set up.
Sure. Good job. .
I'm I'm going to do. Thank you.
Thank you That's This
actually will work really well. And then
so essentially, everything. There it is. I really wouldn't be predesigned out or
our families weekend.
I can further. and get
it where we're going to get it to wash it once. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So it's
all, you know, what, what, what happens when we,
So, once, what,
the urban urban urban community.
Thank you.
I don't think we had a 40-foot you can comment on it right now.
But it's a 40-foot piece and a 1-8th grand market and- Okay,
someone back up here.
You know, yeah, it's the one thought of the church.
Yeah. Yeah. It's just a small one about who we're bringing
back. Okay, a couple more.
I want to come with you guys and like it to Thank you.
No.
No. No. No. Okay.
Now I'm ready to listen. So I can continue.
You You, you, you said you can write,
uh, uhm, the graphics and you'll get out of this format.
Yeah, the only thing I'm not gonna- Yeah,
and and the worst worst case any end come up with the,
the way the massage the data become.
Well, we'll see from around the next port.
You can just do some pretty basic itself up and then,
yeah, get it into this one now. Yeah,
I'm moving. You can just sort of excuse where you take it.
Uh, you know, AI,
you know, kennel. Or one kennel.
Append those splashing images of the drawing.
Okay, it's.
Yeah, that's, that's probably the,
the easiest of the day. They have this.
But yeah, because- I'm really pleased to know
that. Be in what you want.
Very helpful. I think I'm gonna get the final note,
because that wasn't gonna happen.
Yeah, I'm gonna be great with the differentiate.
So, you know, the same as a hot kit,
you know, the same as your old hands.
That means, So, and I'm sure your simple implicates in the
area. Wait, honestly, I-I feel you don't want to have the touch.
What it comes out of. Yeah,
and I'm gonna have pizza bowl that is, but you can-some
have a five-ringer. . What's the game gonna have
to do that so I don't want it to, yeah.
But, that's it. It's. I don't see that scene.
It should be more easily set up.
I know. Yeah, okay. I don't see.
. I think we didn't listen at all. All
It's really not the only thing you need to try.
I thought it was the pattern of it. And,
shit, you got Well, I would say,
you have the purchase and the first thing you see,
uhm, and then,
yes, cutting. Thank joining me. Cutting,
you know, probably have the same sort of,
you know, uh, QCE.
Yeah, we're having a coating on it. And then,
you know, shipping, you to be one of them.
That receiving field of past arrival,
are some of these? Made here, or there,
or in the field. The assemblage would be made,
uh, at, here, at,
uh, depth and fat shop. With some of those.
I saw you have bean clams for that.
So, the bean clams,
I probably just take this further down.
Um, the way that they do their ordering is,
They just do a vulgar word, sensitive,
beginning, but then the vendor does a min-max kind of thing,
so I would just say, uh, like that. I'm to go ahead that,
uh, as your assembler is pulling all their stuff,
they just know that they're gearing up for this assembly, starting to go. Oh,
no. Well, that's I'm to have a little bit, you know,
I know, I mean, 100 days, I'm gonna pull 400 nuts,
kinda thing, based off of what. But that is so- You I
think you could love it a further. I just don't know if,
yeah, that might be taking a load.
Two. All right. Do you
want, uhh, do you want to try?
All right. How
did he have got a symbol of how did he have not, or just
felt that, yeah, I'm really distracting.
and caring for you. Because we're going to be breaking
the work packages, I think we would want to be tracking told as long
as it's being. Thank you. Don't look at the net spread across.
So you do want to be able to track completion based off of,
uh, air in the lab convention. Thank you very much.
So,
probably right off the page. Yeah,
one more simple company. See you later. Some work.
Yeah. Uhm. And then,
you know, for the walk of the track, the completion of the assembly,
is that a QC? See You know, if you have a station in there,
or a 78, and then you have an inspection,
and then you fill out the inspection, you'll work with it.
It is going to be a, uh,
more efficient job. Yeah, I'm going to just do it in the first article
on the section, and then I'll like, uh, uh, very good.
So, kind of thing, but, uh,
but, and then it's going to globally go through that.
See, uh, yeah, yeah. I'm the, I'm gonna just send a prayer to a
lot like we did for, for cold hands,
cause I'm gonna keep going in the peace track here.
And it's gonna randomly add, complete em. And move back to the weather.
And it's, it's gonna be,
yes, uhm. See I got a good stuff.
That's, that's a good issue, you know. I can say it should be a
yes. Umm, yeah. So, yeah. I'm going a little it's just going to be
getting an impact than the format of getting an impact.
It's only the hardest thing. See you
We, could we create a wrap and we'll just say like,
we just call it electrical assembly or we'll just leave it falling.
I mean, we need to create a wrap and you can have some electrical
stuff. Or we'll just, we'll just, we'll just make more sense just to kind
of create. Thank you. I mean, I mean,
why don't we just fit up and,
yeah. You it's,
we have, these are all of our routes that we have here.
Uh, uhm, uhm, these are all uhm.
I've got, uhm, a bit of a little bit on me,
so, uhm, so we can just tailor one of these.
is a great new one for electrical engineering,
uhm, okay. Okay.
Does
the costing have people all up in a specific way or can you just-
control a lot under company 40 through 700
here at this stage? Uh,
we win. you So, I think you would treat this the
same way that we're kind of doing now is that.
Yeah. We, we would actually do combining and that would
take the electrical repair and then they would just tell us the,
You know that they cut out for that and then it would be out
of the system here in case of it.
I don't know. So at least the way it currently set up is,
is they have an item. I mean,
because it's still, it's all under 40.
Sorry. Um, but it's still,
it's two different divisions. It's kind of a thing.
It just did. And,
even Marvin kissed the caronist ride. Sometimes you probably need to use this.
But then all you have to do is just say, hey, here's the peel
number and it's like the date. I think it's free. And back in that
way. But ideally,
we could get it to where, uh,
I see. As well. Bye All of us.
Unless they have an electrical coordinator in here,
not that they, who and where the purchase from,
but. How about we see this,
this is a map to you at the time. Bye Here,
seven months later. Basically,
cats are on the inside of the beach. We'll be-
But, um, if we want to solve our fit
up triggers the QC inspection,
um, just to-
Well, I guess you can, can do that.
Like, if you haven't taken an inspection, you can still mark it off in
peace track and within the building. Only one,
every ten, so.
Yeah, anything that's in the route here.
You're welcome. They're expected you are another percent of the Right.
So, if you see what,
you know, ten percent of it, then- Thanks.
Right. I mean, he can go through and check out a temper done, right?
And then he still has his own special.
. . . Yeah, and, or, you know,
he can do it this way. He's saying the whole batch has been assembled
and better be Just, you see, basically,
you know, like a whole world-type thing, you can fill up.
There's you can still, just fill out from all the attention.
You can have those records, you know,
that the whole plot. We're talking about the next thing is- There
we There's way of a package of the rest of the parties.
eyes. Search.
Thank much. And, uh,
that's it. Umm, takin' the stock professionally.
Kinda when they cut out the cut, that's the takin' stock,
get more down. So let's proceed. I your Have great evening. Okay, see you
Thank you. I you. The categories will get down. That's the code. See the
code. And then the assembly portion will be straight.
Alright, we'll see you in the end.
That's what we did. Cause there's a few things here where you guys are
going to make packaging.
You make it easier to move them.
They have for, for the long set up that we had.
Bye. And so they're
ideally you load up, um, a card, and that card would have all the-
sater traps, whatever need it, and then that would be more labeled with that
word hack, or something, but with that one, that one,
so. No. No. Umm.
So, you know, that need those parts here, too, is to,
to the imagine those, go to the field, and be able to ask.
Whatever. Yeah, so maybe we'll let them in.
. .
.
I think
we'll need to know that we'll grow down. At least we'll know what's about
it. . I don't know how many parts you need,
but let's say, I mean, this looks like a huge quantity to be.
No. No.
I mean, is it like three carts on
a job? Or is it like fifty carts on a job?
We'd probably- have, uhm,
hope not that we have one e to 30 in rotation,
and then total. the wall. is. I over time break everything like one week
work packages, so if we're the week ahead of the We weeks in
the field and a week's coming back,
yeah, and I always would give you 10, you know,
in the field at the time. Umm, that's here locally.
Okay. What happens if they go to the higher?
That's the highest problem. Okay. Now we are just asking what we've done,
so between the Iowa. Bye bye. And Texas,
they have their own fabshops there,
and so that's their own rotation. So don't worry about that.
We started doing, pre-fap or down seer until they got there,
their pre-fap shot up in there. And then now,
cause that's what we, what we did on that one is,
the pre-fap parts, and we did the first hit-minute while they were getting started,
and then that was their first set of parts that you used to ship
out of the job scene. But, I think the farthest one that we're gonna
have to figure out is New Mexico.
It's probably gonna be the next one where we're gonna have to come up
with some s- sort of plan to be able to ship.
And then ideally not,
uh, we just need a ballot on the power.
Now we're going to get it back and,
in fact, talk about ways of looking at it.
You know, so you just have enough and rotation depending on what you have
on your back. Yeah, and you actually look right on the end of it.
Like, do you, like,
get something back? It goes. Okay folks. The arts, or like,
just do single trips, and then maybe,
really guys, come back, you know, maybe we'd be so- some sort of class,
you know, when the guys come back for, you know,
their family stuff, and they're a couple of meetings,
so we just, you know, have them go right.
And we all, umm,
but in exactly those, it's, as assembly's in your eye,
we have to ship, and then we have to- . I'm ship on soon
thinking better, right. We should feel that they will use a little more.
I don't know. You just leave it with it.
Ehm. It just can get interesting when two shops have any bunch of cars.
It's like a, your chasing those things,
right. Okay. I just care pretty quickly,
too. Uhm.
I'm really kind of long to track this.
Uhm. Chocolate. you like that about a pack of different things.
There's not really a mechanism in which you can do one of them.
And then you can put them along the truck. Well, let's do basically,
uhm,
but that you have to receive them in the field,
right, or else they can constantly show them. I'll never. I'll never. I guess
you could do. I appreciate you doing that.
I'm ahead and do the next step
in the show, return or something like that,
where those incentives, the cost of the show is not returning,
and then once they do get- ... return and check back in,
then you can go to an ownership of the fact that it's just saving
a lot. Okay, yeah. Yeah.
And all of those, you know, those are mine.
Okay, we're just talking. Okay.
Yeah. Just cart of this.
I have to start with these things. Yeah. Well,
I was wondering if we were just,
but then suddenly again, I told you.
Umm, but not really because I'm,
uh, a track disaster that goes back and forth.
But I'm wondering what you're- The only thing here in some of this fashion
is in here is pretty much a long building.
Right. Okay. And I
need to try, I need you to work in as fashion as to,
You Try not to check out,
like, grinders and, ok, I'm gonna do it again.
And when they check, they're not using us. . And
then when they check back here and leave, you know how we were doing
that. We didn't up on the snuck. We didn't follow up on that.
Closest that I have to, you know what I'm saying. So,
that might be a way to get into the way. And
that's something we could probably, uh,
we can leverage them, and I said one or the other.
Or is it the thing that you're adhered,
or something like that? Yeah. Okay.
Or just manage it, like, you know, like,
I have a true asset, right? It might be interesting.
I would build it to be more of a, I'm a innovative person or
a very good candidate. But part of that was,
uh, like the filters we kinda brash and,
. . In the disappear me gone, we never really forgot back about it.
Alright, so we had to do that, because we had to do but they
did this job site. And we got back on the estate and here's what
we did that took it. So if we never saw it come back,
you know, I got that. You grab it so we can get a very
easy lift. Yeah. So I wonder if all the markets just track those cars.
And the what? The tool was going down. Yeah. duration 3rd.
Now, I've got I at the All right! All right. Yeah. I don't
see really.
So we're getting back to getting one to water. That's great.
I wonder if between them and we take
the light. Bye. But, uhm,
the little material that you are, that you're just looking at,
get the whole thing and work. I'm sorry. You could get it to be
important. And then, kind of,
okay, here's a release. Let's walk all the way through and say.
Bye bye. So, one, I can just go ahead and do the next thing.
Forward, or, get on and have this,
and just kind of walk all the way through. I'm going to pick up.
And, and I'll say I'm just going to do it,
then uh, uhm, we're on across
the issues. Thanks. So,
I'm not going to be good if we get that out. Is there a
way to get that electronically relevant to you yet?
Thank much. And that's what, let me see if I can get,
uhm,
about layers. Cheers. I can get,
like, so, one can just release,
uhm, all the way project PDF.
Have a good day. I don't have to, uh, check it with me,
but it really makes no more sense to me.
But it's infeasible,
so I'm not worried. I'm sorry. I don't have to think I did really
kinda underrated, but I used check to do the nesting
on the wire. And, It's utilization down to like,
uhm, I think we got like 15% drop,
uhm, and then, they're ready. And I really would like,
like, uhm, percent if that, and if they would point zero for me,
uhm, that was the way we got it,
you know. No. Really, we're just about how we're gonna take off.
Yeah. Yeah.
And,
uh, what do you know about this, uhm, week? We'll guys in just export
out, sure. And export out the,
uhm. I'm curious how you put it here.
Thank you. Seriously,
did I ask them to or did you just copy them?
Uhh, I would say if that's a bit of an instance and it has
a, I would say to save all the other sizes.
Yeah. And then it'll just be catered to what we have and we can
clear out it as we don't need it. Yeah.
And if it's not, then we can take that export and
push it through. Cause yeah.
Like I guess, considering how many times on the back and forth about the
youngness. Yeah. They have to eat it decent.
Yeah. You have seen instance in a circuit port.
So, if you can say phone and service,
they all have a button, a selected,
they'll just read that. Yeah. Yeah,
let's run this and consider it a matter of fact.
Can you hear it? Um. Come on.
I mean, what's going on with it? Because this is,
and it is incredibly small.
Whoa. You
must keep babies at common. Yes.
Especially that. Okay. I'm on the.
I can't believe this. All the time.
Take care of. Yeah.
Thank you, uhm. You know what,
isn't a can't hold in here with the regular stuff,
but that would also keep itself- So, So, we get,
uhm,
I'll go, I'll go.
I'm a copy of the point that it's,
so, I mean I'm playing with that box that it makes,
uh, if all the- I just wanna say,
I don't wanna have to take the um, do through and wipe out everything
you got in there. Do you wanna get plenty of weakness or slower?
Well, with that there- Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. It hurts. Switch it back out to I.T.E.A.L.S.
and assist me. Yeah. It's not too hard usually.
I mean, it'll be a big ask if I'm sure it'll be interesting when
you know for a lot. Yeah, I'm willing. All in.
All of our jobs. And disabled boy,
all right. I'm going to make you know the signs that I don't need
help that. So. Thank I'm sorry. It's your shoulder bit.
Yeah. So. I think that goes out and that is our red.
So. Thank you. That's, you know, a project that you do.
Yeah. Yeah. But that's all I can do.
No. And then, and then,
bye-bye. Welcome. Once it's in line of the trailer and the files bring in
load, it's the one I didn't click.
Okay. Bruce,
you just dropped it in a
quarter. So, I'm- I was like,
I was like, how much did you take it and I just
like, did I really not grab- I had that one of my favorite customers,
so. You should put a little bit of praise in my eye.
Listen, I want to be out of the realm of my- I to do
Sometimes I'm I want I the ability for me to look at that and
go, I don't mean to. And you get it.
I do. I need it done. So. I'm just kidding.
I don't know. That's the camera just sitting there going through
each drawing. All the way along.
It'll be a lot faster for the important action,
please. Yeah. Thank you.
Ah, you mean you have an older subscriber than those?
Thank you. Umm, why is it on the other screen?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Well, pretty sure it's a big deal,
but I wish you could. I don't know if it's in the action work,
but it's a blast. Oh! More of it.
You don't want to be dead.
I want to be dead.
And That's it.
I'm going to ahead and I'll see you Yeah, that's it. All right.
Thank you.
All right.
Hey,
uhh, uhh, uhh,
uhh, uhh, uhh, we're making cold water cold, so you can, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm. See you. Bye. Bye. And if you're  but you guys you did
you actually regret it? I'm glad I did. You used to do it and
everything quite easily. You should have checked now,
or something. I think it's hard to Okay.
Good. You're on your journey.
See you. Love you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Good morning.
Good morning. Good morning.
Good morning. Okay.
Okay, double check. So, here she is. .
I have a word behind the phrase.
I'm going to do anything to ask, uh, give it up.
Once it's off, it's- Two more.
I'm to write a piece of paper that I just- Are you going to
text us, so as you don't have to name a text that I sent
out anymore? Thank you very much.
Okay, so I want to see how you get your services.
Yeah. That's into
Excel. Right. I can do
All right.
Bye.
Okay.
Umm.
Okay. No,
no, I'll leave your club.
I'll please have a little time. That's fine. Just, can you go the way?
Bye. We've known the sheet section, it's like a classroom that should have,
like, arginarians. Uh,
I'm trying one step, she tried please. Cheers.
It had, like, a full deal in no time.
I'm on.
Umm,
You
ehm, ehm. Thank you.
Alright,
good bye. Good bye.
Bye Bye. Bye, just stay. Umm,
I'm going to show you what I'm going to do.
Yeah, so when I've been waiting. Yeah, I'm sitting first.
. I've been working on it since, uh,
I Yeah, agency, uhm. No.
Uhm, uhhh,
uhm, cold, the wet, the water, the air, and the water, the its, by
itself. Yeah. Thank you. Okay.
So, pretty much this, these,
uh, stretch, we don't have to see if I can.
It doesn't have to be, it doesn't have to be,
it doesn't have to be, this, this. . . I just said the ones
I just mean, so I'm gonna
work on.
Yeah,
you just, just pay this, uhm. Bye.
Just do call a little extra over to your rung.
And then, can you actually call,
uh, are you able to modify?
Bye. These,
tables? Yeah?
Yes sir. Can you? Thank you. People love what ensures what's available.
I want to see if we can add some stuff to the cut.
That's it.
It's a little brighter.
Yeah, do not face it on me. Thank you. Thank you. Mm-hmm.
I'm starting all this happy by the other side of it's just it's
alright. I'm better. Heh.
Good. Alright.
Well, so we are going to do the tour. Good It's
going back, so what if you pull in the- the chart over again?
Yes. So,
what? Oops. Awesome.
Thanks very much. Thank you very So
we'll go back to Oh So,
we have a full label is needed.
It needs to be something exact to order, right? If it's on the store,
I can just free math it.
That's It's not just a, We'll call and we'll look at it for what
to have. Okay, so, flip drawing.
We have hound. Alright. With the count,
it's only really applying to, I
think it's the overall assembly that is going to be a piece marked with
low stride. Alright. Bad.
Bye.
You know, I'm not this side,
but it's right. It's not everyone. It's not everyone.
And then, I think.
I'm creating this key.
We're not assigning grades and they're all as far as,
um. All This on the stride while it was,
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna do something pretty back in.
I'm not sure. So if I wanted
to reach all of us, essentially if I wanted to read a word.
. . I would like this to where, you see how our label,
and then our labels can be described.
And then And I would want another line,
after that, toward the label,
to be The label would read,
like, R1, and then the last three digits of the label.
I'm cool. Okay. Just so I can produce a part for
the Roblins. Thanks.
He's running there. Yeah, so I don't even want it.
So essentially we have all this list of cover.
I heard it. So I don't want the leather.
Another lace, and then a belayable.
. That's it wrong but I didn't have
to in it. So I would wanna add another call.
. .
They're song cloth. synthesized.
synthesized.
But, I can say this very shortly.
I'll have to give you a second. Thank you. One, two, seven, the one.
Shh. That's it.
Just
be proud of us. If you have go ahead.
All of them t-shirt. All
So
you see what we need to do to be brave. So, let's see, So,
we, just, Perfect. Thank A piece marked in the rod that
ties in to what our name,
So I can add first,
T1, C1. I'm sorry.
There. Right. You know,
it was 40 in a shot at a few of thousands.
And then you had. I love Or after straws that are going to be
our, our one,
pre-digits from piece art. That's our. All right.
Let me see how that ties to
the main art. I'm sorry.
Yeah,
I'll have it. I'll have it once. Let's do it.
Can you see if you can manipulate that I saw a spreadsheet?
Oh, I'm sorry. Though, right here went to Kyve.
Clap. Clap. Clap. Clap. Clap.
Clap.
I know a thing for
the girl. Oh, it doesn't look like this. It's, Uhh,
I don't think it's like the least. . Just don't
go in and think, right?
Just don't. . . I'm going to check here. It's whatever,
or anything, or anything. Little problem.
So, let's get it. . It's like, uhm,
because, except, uhm, people don't stand unless you go loose,
kinda. ... ... Okay, so we're just gonna talk to you to give them
a little bit, but, uhm, we're gonna have a little bit of
just run because of that.
Yeah, so what I wanna do is e just,
Just give me the install. So, I'm gonna just have just version one,
and I, I mean, I'm just going to delete it with an excel.
I'm gonna do it with an excel. Thank So,
you're gonna be in back parts, and then,
and then we can work getting with the,
with the, the game to get part of the action,
depending on their opinions, or use the feelings to match.
Thank How
do you submit your opinion on that? Well,
I think I think this is the way to- So I don't write it
for so Okay.
So, that's all. I'd thank you I'm glad to Thank you. Thank you. For
all Thank you. You Don't.
Okay. Umm.
No. No. I
don't wanna be supportive of this. who is a student how have we done
the process of getting, uh, uh, coins,
uh, hear that, so that's all in. So you're gonna be the same.
again. When we're not given any sort of,
like, actual files, you're doing the same Excel import,
or how are we doing that? Yeah.
I don't know, I'm gonna get it. Yeah,
most of the coding's customers have been supplying case files.
house. The,
without, without the case file,
uhm, it can't, it's the need to change the order,
man, it can't. and on the that,
that would be probably the only other way,
could be manual imports and in Excel,
into what's we can do. 4 3 So the brush shot,
you've been getting better, like, at the moment.
As far as? Yeah. Yeah,
especially with the one that's coming up for t- that's very,
very good to be w And then we're going
to stop that they're going to get them working.
That's called an important,
pretty easily in here. So,
I have all that. that. Go .
You know, it doesn't need from the cradle stuff in order to prevent getting
a lot of blood getting just lost.
So. I'm sorry. Are you trying to get PFS
emails on your jumps while you kiss us?
and Because his files aren't going to go the way it's not.
Yeah, very good job, sir.
Yeah, and with them. and uhm,
but then you can do the kids as well as they export out of
their service and then give us their own sex.
Thanks. Umm, but,
yeah, they've been doing kiss calls and then we'll be giving IFCs,
umm, yeah, yeah, and then with birthdays that they're right.
Umm, but I know these seven IFCs that I can upload to me the
trouble from is the day they- like,
we can make updates on it so we can enjoy the IFC every single
week with revisions. Alright,
we're using, uhm, opinions that- uh, all in store.
Uh, nothing for codeings of the documents and stuff,
but, uh,
for files that you- I'm requesting that I'm actually giving IFCs,
uhm, kiss files. They have not supported AFXD file.
Well. And then yeah. So.
But. We don't know how to show it.
It works like part of what we know. So,
there's just gonna be a- Just, yeah, a few next to you,
probably, as you can be, tat it up,
tah, tah, I'm going to detail Detailer
with the end of the mountain. SDS,
you're going to tell me which part of it is.
Thank you again, yeah, a lot of this. All let's do this.
Probably, probably.
Yeah, sometimes it takes a little longer than me.
Yeah, I'm forward to the eye of this off.
. I'll set up in here. I just see that at all the volume
that we added. Uhm, a complex paper.
Uhm, s-uhm, m-m, m-m, m-m.
Thank Uhm,
well, it's adding to this component. Uh,
we've seen- Thank you.
I've seen what we broke out yesterday.
So now, now that we have the ability to track their prep intermediate your
quote, prime and finish. So, for the complex.
And, uhm,
and all the leaves can be marked up in EP and go.
And then we'll- also create an inspection and work more for them for their
service prep in our inspection area.
Period. So that they can do,
uh, and, uh,
more so that they can get away from side dogs.
But. I'm glad to see you. Most of all of his reports can be
read on in here. And then you can go.
So I'm assuming in the future. I'm going show you.
Once we actually get to the website,
that's the link. If you do, umm,
all of that stuff can be transferred in. Thank So,
hm,
hm, hm, hm. So, between three, You We added three different coating types,
so we got the high solids, the steel spark,
and uhm,
Acropoxy. See
So we added
all these in configurably container sizes.
We'll see For what their purchasable units are,
and the cost per gallon, which might be updated if that test changed,
and then their co- average. So estimates when we plug one in
should be pretty up point with exactly what they're looking for.
. . Umm, and for what our estimates will show over
how many gallons they need over the price and the summary.
We'll see in the square footage you suggest.
Does that, does that description carry through a travel interval?
Bye No, it doesn't,
uh, it doesn't best for a travel interval.
So, I did. We did.
You ended up adding into production,
uhm, additional finishes in here.
So, we do have complex. That's it guys. B2 and sp3 and sp6,
as well as simple as a 1-2-6.
So, we'll at least have a prep. right there. We'll have follow up with
the finish and that will show up on the challenge.
Umm, but you can kinda adjust the finishes however we want,
so. So, If we wanted to add the hate spec and the surface prospect
in there, we could. It's just gonna make this again come along.
No, I'm actually not. We have already planted the peach
oil on board with bricks. Spectral,
y'know, out of the sh want to make sure to be
the I also want to make sure we're not.
Possibly. And flitting down.
Yeah. No,
we should be good there. Thank you. Umm, none of that.
All those, I don't know if we were just looking at it or just
on the estimate side. So,
those are the options you can pick. When you're starting a new job,
if you're in here, you can go into your paid system and go
in here. You can move over multiple codes and do custom systems and
then clean systems as well. If you're doing them as people.
If you move them into sp6,
then you can account for the layer for multiple systems for senior systems
and your estimates. So. Hello.
We got that pretty bad with the new spray.
And, and adjusted the labor in there so that it's matching with mose-
and concur leading out for one man or her new spirit foot and one
man or her new spirit foot for prep and prep.
So. So. That's,
that's it.
Today we've come in and messing with. All right.
Umm, adjusting labor.
So we adjusted a couple of the well-done position rates in the air because
they were- so the amount of the box rates.
So we increased some because the rates were really small in there.
So we dialed up. you the, uh,
in these seats a per minute,
per feet per hour. In here for. Thank you for your attention.
I'm going a range of 5,
16, 3, 8s on those basic moments.
And then I'll also learn in the minutes. Thank you very much.
Umm, increase our fit time a little bit.
So our well time, I'm down a little. Bit time,
increase a little. Which is usually,
you know, is So our adjustments on our projects is,
it needs a little bit more involvement as you show it a little over
stuff. So. And we're working to continue
to find that, uhm, looking at historical projects.
Okay, bye. Having gotten to a point where he would have been able to
identify specifically where issues are coming in with play.
So. So, It's been kind of my new adjustments at this point,
uhm, but finally continuing to look at existing
projects and just to- and breakouts, and then the estimates,
and then you can compare the actual versions of the estimated versus supplied.
Alright, we'll see you in the next time we can get our numbers to
all jive, up across the board. Sign here.
So, so the outcome I clean the actual back in.
Okay. Okay. Right. The. One
of the issues that's always been with what's your actual- We'll
see you next It's possible, right? What's your actual linear for what was done,
or what- What you've got to estimate.
Thank you. And so, it's hard to,
you know, if you wait the hours done to when you estimate it,
then it was actually- You don't know me.
And so, we'll get a camera. But wait.
Unless- Once we dig into everything and spend a lot of time processing
the PMST or whatever the import is on it,
we're not gonna come up with that. It's an actual screw.
What was the detail of what was done, right?
You talk about it like I did with my head. It's not a hundred
hours on the basement, but what they want,
that black shirt, should be $600.
I'm saying 78 feet. A well that was estimated based
on all the clips and everything, but in reality,
we did 87 feet of the welding.
Because I was deep down a bit of front floor,
and I just wanted to paint it off right here. Yeah,
it's any one of the estimated versus versus versus,
right? Like. Bye bye. So it's, it's too, I mean,
it's estimated versus, you know, what was assumed,
right? And then, you know, let's say it took about 10 months for that
shirt. It's something like that,
right? Or whatever. Whatever athletic detail that we didn't mean,
it was meant to actually do things or something like that, alright?
So, change. So, that's kind of so special to me.
Well, I mean, I think go on cuts or at least me because those
are- pretty close to all of me and actually,
but, uh, the welts have always been kind of,
uh, ehm, ehm, you don't want to divide it back into what was
estimated. It's a good excuse to have that,
right? Yeah. Um, so,
one more idea. You ehm,
I count for some time in here. It's not an exciting silence.
But when you leave the professional control down back to the estimate,
it can bring those hours over and apply some material that's in production control,
right? Now, what it does is it does- it's not on a hour-supercom
basis, so if it's,
like, okay, they- You You know,
my, uh, base plate sizes have deep roots,
my AMA, yeah. Like we said,
a bunch of pork chicken, right? Mm-hmm. Well. But they,
you get my sideovers and they're because they're having it.
But it's not moving at every age of oil because he doesn't.
The men are there with the reaching control side.
It does look nice and clean so that, right. But,
uhm, that, that helps a lot.
My shots are the same point as boys. They're on the street because they're
like, always put over on haters because you're judging me based on-
the estimated hours and things changed and there's a lot
more work plus all these changes in their young period.
Well, what's that?
What's this production control? It capital is ours.
So, they can't account for some of that,
so. Okay. I don't know the exact size of that. So that,
so once it gets brought up in the production control,
we're essentially re-establishing our labor budget space all of this.
That's actually what the base hours are in that project. is that's how it's
going to go. And what
that does is, it's estimated that I was in the schedule as well.
And it compares to this. Thank you. It's estimated to the base hours.
Let's say we had 500 hours for one,
for one sequence in the estimated hours.
those. . . And the base hours was 575.
It was used for 575 instead of the vibe.
I you. Because it said, yeah, when you say 500 out,
I don't know if on this, but he really got thought they're saving a
lot of money to work. That's what we're using for that. That's what we're
using because base hours aren't doing.
So were you thinking that just the adjustments,
incorrect, that we'll not do it that way,
but whatever. If you're using the estimated hours,
then the adjustment column. But right now,
I don't care what you're saying, adjustment has estimated.
Okay. That's, that's why I see your desire for it.
Umm,
the adjustment is essentially- last week.
We put the adjustment in base and whatever the base hours are showing to
get it to match what we have released tools.
We'll see. So analyze it with the,
and our base hours show that it's, um,
39 and we'll put the difference in the- uhh,
so that our- uhh, this is the source of base hours.
Base hours. Base is based upon production.
Okay, so let's- . . . So, your- your constantly changing the
adjustment again to the how to keep it at the hours you want.
5 8 9 right, you know. So,
if you would put the estimate and estimate card,
you would have to do that. Because it's so light on.
Bye bye. Let's see, the one line that has base out of a 16,
14 to the adjustment. So you got a total plan hours of 30.
Alrighty. See that one right there?
Yeah. Umm, so that one,
if you have 30 hours of estimated.
I'm leaving. With 16 in base,
you enter through the stuff, 14, you're coming,
and you're, and you're playing hours,
you're going to be invited. up. And it's, it's, it's,
it's coming out of the actual time work and how much they've done so
far. It's, it's coming from, it's it's coming it's coming from,
it's coming from, it's . It's, uh, how much for the time is,
you know, more positive than I have seen the piece since I read production
control to get, to get them.
in a second. I appreciate it and complete them. Okay.
Tell me that. I appreciate it. Well, it's, yeah. Yeah,
you're not definitely in that, I think, because we want to do it,
because we have to. Thank you. Yeah, well,
so that doesn't mean we'll meet you. We're not. We're not,
yeah. We're not manipulating the data because we want to.
We're manipulating the data because we have to.
We're not pulling anything over from the original estimate.
Well, why not say this to me? You're doing it because you want that.
. . Yeah,
so if you put the 30 hours of original estimate,
can you, can you add as much as that's got me?
So you can't. You can You,
you can add the hours of original estimate, yeah. Put it in there,
right there, and then get rid of your adjustment.
So- You So the summarize, so the original estimate would be,
so from the PC forum, right? So we'd say,
Hey guys, this is what we budgeted, you know.
Thank you. So it just doesn't even need to be there.
If we'll just throw in the original estimated out of it or the original,
into the estimated out of it. It's all good. It doesn't.
And then it'll take whatever the base out is for and figure out where
to find where it should be. Now, once you're leaving the watch.
The for them is, let's say that that was 100%
that, that particular lot was 100% that.
At least. And you had this situation where original art 30,
but the base, it's, it's, it's, you really only has it, you know, it'll
work. I'm sorry.
But going to But always okay. It's just like, I've done a Hey, that's
all it's good, right? Well, it's never playing 30 here because it
thinks more is coming. So it keeps sh- the 100% released to 100%
that it would use the base hours of 16.
If I were to send and that's what it was.
We want to, we want to be managing to the actuals of what the
work that we're safe and having,
and using. in. essentially, the knowledge of the original being at 30 to know
that you've got 14 hours of contingency. and say, okay,
I'm on the next one. So, good. So, I show that it's 100% realistic
we put a lightning dang. Yeah,
put anything in the light up there in here. Get right up here. I'm
here. Okay, let's move on.
Let's move on to the base. Thank so much.
See,
it's using the web. It still thinks it works kind of,
but if you change it, you'll see it released through a hundred.
Thank The reason is, it calculates the percent release based off of the
average. So, it changes to that because 54 more times.
But if you change the percent release to 100,
it would put your land hours back.
Thanks. That's
It seems like it's adjusting it for whatever will be put in your original
videos, right? I didn't do 100 in the panel of Jess.
Who's the source of original estimate? We got a guy with a,
a dartboard in Dilbert.
Right, that's the figure. Right, right.
Okay, so yeah. So, I would,
I mean, I guess it's probably an art
decision, but to leverage this- correct me,
I would say you would want to- to take whatever your base hours came
out to be, you would- you would want to that into your original estimate
number so that you could manage your percent,
at least, based on- of your base hours that you're updated,
we have zero, so yeah. Can we check our percent,
utilize the comfort? Just, like, look at this. So. So,
We're showing 16 hours, and now I'm showing that I'm in over,
but in reality on this line, I don't think I should've done.
Well, that's what I'm saying. So, the base hours, the original estimate I should
match, and then March should just know that it is actually released.
So, indeed, that's when we have a, I think the rest of the production
needs, and he brings us out. He's gonna have a separate column of bows,
actually. That's gonna be done with this stuff. That's,
showing that category. You're saying base hours need to line up.
Yes. I think so. Do we need to adjust all of it across the
board of men? I would see you. But. We'll in the base hours changes,
don't it? Base hours will change based off,
uh, based off of, uhm.
Important more piece of piece. Base hours will- So if they bring in more
pieces, then it's going to change that piece. But then the estimate is,
they're- I mean. But if we leave- if we- if we bring in more
pieces, but we sequence a lot into a separate sequence,
well, it's just that same sequence. Thanks. So
we bring in more pieces, right? We do another thing for this board.
Now for a step.
Okay.
So if we change it across the board, yeah. Yeah. So design. Base out.
Bye I'm not sure they'll estimate that your percent release here,
percent. Please are all going to flow through well.
So as long as, as long as. The, the,
the PDs that are releasing this stuff are giving you guys the hours before
that sequence in a lot. Then,
and you guys are not. Some of that, then, that this works.
But in a situation where it's like,
you know, hey, this is one out of three canopies.
Here's where I go overall. Oh, but. But then we'll just have to,
uh, we'll just have to make sure that if we pull the accountable and
then, and then march. We'll just need to know what that is.
Well, one more reestimates. So let's say markets.
Okay, so. Something from Gilbert.
He's like, well, yeah, it's not this. He said it's really this.
He says that. Where does that come from?
It's what it is. I'm so alone. It's a s-se-se-se.
Technically, what your base hour of energy is a s-se-se-se-se.
Could I work with me? Thank you. It is being re-estinated,
and that's at your base hours. And so, so the idea was that I'm
quite doing it this way. When we started a job,
we weren't even touchless. We could have a discussion of,
uhm, we're planning to pay for it,
but I didn't get it. We can at least go into that same thing.
What change, can we get a change of work?
I can adjust something, or does it do something like that?
The more dreams, the better. We just need a little treat that says,
oh, this has to be good stuff. It's good stuff, it's stuff,
it's good. So, like, every chance would be perfect,
and then we'll be able to try to go out to the, because we
can get done in four hours, and that's,
that's, uhm, the same. So, uh, you know,
we can get you all soon to think about that.
And in mind that I was actually married to,
I think it's a hard night, but it was just the fun and the
subjective stuff, but you know, you know, right?
But I can know that, y-y-y-y-y stuff, and that's what we're coming in with,
based on what we're saying, the whole world's around.
Uhh, we're just being popular, you know,
we're going to list that, uhh, we're going to be like. I'm hearing two
conversations, I don't have to work down,
keep it track. Bye. I
think it's really important that we agree on what this is because we're having
two summer, he and I are having a discussion,
and you guys are having a discussion. But I think it's,
what is the real answer about do this because,
um,
Alan is right here. See here. That, that 175 and being calculated between
two numbers and you're trying to avoid that from habit.
Good. Good. But, you know, what's your,
what's your gossip? So now, somehow we really need to do that right in
mind, yes, it's just change the 16 to 30.
is
in the plan, based on anything. In our base. Right?
Well. you It's great if the estimator actually estimated 30,
but we've seen some jobs where the estimator estimated right,
right, right, it won't change. But it will change.
We're giving, right, if we're only given 14 hours,
that's where we're adding these original estimated hours,
right? That's what-
So on one side, if base hours are coming in less than
original, right? That's great, right?
But you want more. You don't plan its production accordingly,
then we're talking bigger dollars, right? But you don't want to,
to still, umm, uhh, much of its hours
based off of, you know, having 10 guys busy versus the base hours saying
you're only going to keep 3 guys busy. Alright, I think we need to
show them the community you've collected for the huge jobs and show estimated
base. Show what's really happening. And then everybody kind of looks at what's really
going on, uh, and then have that discussion.
And it's, you know, we make it like, the end of it more like
day. We've been pulling data just to kind of look at it.
So, and, but I guess the base hours that aren't,
uh, you're talking, aren't pulling in. . Well,
it's, it depends on how you do it.
So, feel ready. Better.
Originalist made it. Originalist made it.
That's what we had a blessing, right? Base hours is saying,
this is what you have to do. Actually,
are going to be working for what's,
for what's out here. So,
in base hours is accurate. little bit.
I want that utilization to show you that I'm where,
umm, because if I literally d- n f 16
hours of work in thi 30,
then I want it to be 16. That's w I would be judged on
this decision. 16 not 30.
Now, it's good information that it's like,
okay, cool. Yeah, I believe that I might be a 28.
Yeah. That's awesome.
That's great work under, but it didn't actually be bad because it was really
sick. . I think there was a work that took 28 hours, right?
So, if the base hours are correct,
then I wanted to show that. Good. You know,
son of a, Right. So then it's a constant tweak to get the base
hours as books to web hours that were actually pretty,
Producing it correctly. Yeah. It might be not that because,
let's say, on the estimate, there were 40 gallons,
there, and now I've only got one column.
I don't want the base centers to be purchased.
No, no, no, no, no. What I'm saying is, is what I want is
the base to be with what you're actually going to produce today.
Yeah, yeah. So if it says 16 hours, we should be producing it at
16 hours, right? No. That's what we're shooting for.
Because regardless of the estimate, they gave us 30 hours to ask food,
but we should only need 16. Yeah,
and that's what you should manage for, which is what? And I'll be in
the day, I think, but then the most things may occur that we're getting
good data back. Right, and the way we've been utilizing this is.
is. It's wrong, right? Because what it's going to look at now is
the hours that we're planning, right?
you do it.
So the base hour of the plan is hard to get it.
You gotta give the shot before they don't get the rest.
Uhh, well, originally it was the adjustment,
which is to juggle the hours to fit,
and then that would bring the plan course over.
Right, so if it was 16 hours, we'd have 30,
we would add 2 to that 16 to get the 30 in the plan
hours. But based on- hours, assuming a 100% release of a base hour
fitment frame. If- if it's all- All of it.
Yeah, so if he changes base hours right now,
since it says a 100%, like,
change, uhh.
. ? Right, but if, uh, finally I guess they've done it.
If you change it to 31, see if you change it, but it should
change it to quiet. Yeah. Yeah.
Now, here's,
here's the game there. What,
if you do nothing but just connect the two.
You let's say that hours per ton of the estimate was non-hours of COVID,
right? I got a non-hours of That's where it's going to apply.
Well, let's say that this release had some
stuff that was 25...
I have hours of time in reality because it's higher,
let's say it's rails.
They're gonna be higher hours of the time, right? And some of the stuff
in the release was four hours a ton because they're just spiller beeps,
and they're just getting hollows. So.
Sooo That. Face hours may be whacked
out because I'm applying done when I should be applying to.
So there isn't
a way to do it while this way is going to- Because
the estimates gonna have to use,
predict what's called production case, which I'll just call this a production case.
And so now, pieces in the estimate.
Let's do it.
Are going to have to be designated as part of rails or prima beans,
and the pieces in production control are going to be designated.
It's rails or prima beans in order to apply these separately instead
of just the overall average of none.
So, wait a second. Thanks. Ain't nobody's building that way.
A lot of companies go this route because of this logic here.
What? Bye Most of them end up coming back here because
this is, that's a constant fight.
I'm back. But
your releases are very somewhat true.
Like your releases are columns or you mix work like that. Good. Good. Rails
of the babies, you know, the stairs will be with rails,
but that's, I mean, you know, all columns will be with- ehm,
but it's not. But you're still talking about an overall one,
okay, you're not talking about several releases.
See you But it doesn't put it, it is talking about specific releases though.
For now, it's a little bit later to me get down. Oh, yeah.
We detail. If we. We just make sure we decill everything out based off
of a full rail package.
Yeah, we don't. We don't miss. We don't need to.
We don't need to. It's changing.
But if we're, if we're doing rails and it beats,
then we need to understand that. So technically we need to detail up separately.
You guys can just assign them to different sequence of laws when they're in
the board. And then you can bypass having to keep them separated.
rated. So you guys are just organizing those eight that you actually would produce
them in the shop, right? So you say, okay,
like, I want to mark. Bye When you go to actually fan power level
of the project and say,
okay, we need to call them all out first,
right? So you can break that column and see if it's mine,
and then if he's gonna be it, it's only unique,
and out for time, or that set of columns,
right? And then you can, You know, of where things are there,
but where that's gonna be hard to manage into the overall function of it.
Okay. Get out of that. Uh, uhh, uhh, uhh, the Shilos
that last week, they weren't gonna try to find that panel to
the spruity, uh, or to the button.
I do think what they didn't do, what they didn't do,
didn't do was start happening. It's structural versus miscellaneous.
At the end of the day. Yeah, because if it was which would be
at least go to the integrity. I mean, it's not pretty open.
All All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All
right. One package to the mechanics.
They've already separated. I mean,
it's not. It's the answer. It's the two for a 0-7-5-8.
We have a meeting. There was good mentees. There was massive plates.
There was annual And then there were study comments.
What do you want? . So, uhm, the meeting of the upstairs.
What if you grill? If we give it as a sequence,
uh, and then lock that out, uh,
as far as, like, okay, cool a bit. Good. The WK's are on live,
but it's still a heavy-same sequence with the fitness,
you know, all the correct hours are deep for time.
But the way that we- . If you don't use production pairs,
it's the same number I like. But it would do a per-sequence
analog. Mm-hmm.
But based off of the way that we estimated on G's,
we estimated the pace off of it, meaning a stressful job,
right? So, like, we're not, So,
that's the reason for it. Yeah,
we're, I mean, they're going to go check.
You're may not return overall. Okay. Well,
the way proms really kind of mistake me at all,
as in some of the pieces, but you're not going to mean it separately
separately. We'll see if you're different, how or something like that.
I would say this would be more, like, blue sittin' to where it's over
on this. This would be best. I think it's the better.
You keep structural and this smells like you're saying separate,
and then we could separate out this smell.
That smells based on, like, rails,
stairs, and strangers. Okay, we're about to see,
you know, this one by nine, I'm gonna tell you because,
It may not be less of a material,
but it, or for that disparity like I was talking about,
but it couldn't be that. And the estimate just didn't have the right stuff
in it, right? Because maybe it wasn't leaving it out properly,
or something like that, so. So. Most apps that get into the overall apps
are intended in most cases for structural and general treatment centers.
Yeah, we do. I don't how to get started,
you know. It's, uh, it can be, it can be used in base hours
since they have adjusted actually. That's what we need to be putting in this
straight. More than putting them under adjusted health adjustment,
right? Yeah, please put them underneath.
So, I didn't have- I learned this column activated so originally it was gas
power adjustment, and then it should be a digital and base power.
Thanks. Yeah, what would the existing use for the long run then?
It would just use original and base. So,
we use base hours. dollars. And the adjustment in the work that the violin
is in. So our PC form will add these total
quantities of- I mean, this is our utilization with- So our utilization is
coming so close.
And then- That will give a new flavor
to the utilization for sure.
But, it'll also help you on the opposite scenario
where the hours are packed, the base hours actually come out.
. . More than their visualness made. Well,
that's gonna make you look better because it's like,
I can't, well, we should, uh,
you know, those issues.
It just makes it look bad when I notice that's- when you gotta get
it begun. We'll see guys in the Okay, so the numbers will go somewhere.
Umm, that'd probably be the most question to you,
Mike. It's very very So this is definitely
for LG, or in general. So,
I would say the- up. Uh, it's just the,
uh, it's the common fight of estimate versus production,
right? The estimate or job is funded.
So it's, uh, it's making sure that we're on the same page
to me on. Bye!
When you look back, it's kicked off so that we know,
do we need to really be interested in this and come up with a
way to make this into a, uuh,
as often as job as we can, or do we miss something,
at least establish what our vegetables It's your man,
it's his angle. His angle, his angle,
to make sure the Gilbert guys are getting the Gilbert estimates,
or anything that numbers really well.
All over the world. But your goal that far fixes it,
it marks no pressure really good. I think the,
the, the main goal here to make a lot is.
Cheers. Yeah, it's okay, well, I get that.
The main goal is to, if everyone's using the estimate
in- right, so all the numbers are based off of the unit rates and
the math that's divided into this,
right? So, it- You
Is it, uh, or is it a unit rating of something that we need
to fix, right? And I think that's where large we need to come in.
It's- and It's a
take off thing. I that's a simple thing to say, okay? It's clearly just
four columns and, you know, you only add two.
Right? But if we're trending constantly that I saw,
it is producing at half the rate that we're actually estimating to.
That's a global thing that makes you do a dress with,
you know, women, and it's, and you know, it's actually,
you know, it's a very sophisticated job.
And you go, you know what the original husband is,
before you put it in the shot, somebody looks at it and says,
no, this husband. It's been, over a year, it's 12 hours,
it's supposed to be 60, and they do the next five-hour balance.
It's supposed to be 16, and we're just drilling on it.
Thank you, Steve. And that's what the base column should be used for,
correct? No,
t***. You basically,
uhh,
it basically does. If nobody has to go get it and do it, they
calculate, oh man. Please don't- Love it.
It's time to get me a set up injury or one of them you
gotta ignore. It does, but it takes the adage from the estimate.
The next, uh, yeah, that's, uh, countable.
I wish I could have you go to a place where I can't.
The tournament, yeah, that's all you gotta do. But it matters to worry about,
too. So you have to be willing to enter and make me the best.
Uh, that's, can you try and get it all ready? All right.
All right. If you enter something, it really has to be.
Right? So I was saying, to give it another perspective of what we're talking
about is, this is going to kill us.
Let's just say it to. You're doing% work,
right? And within that estimate, you're doing frame versus structural.
And this base values here,
it's good. Good. Look at it and generalize it as if it's the same
main hours per time as the structure level. But you know it's a more
complex frame system that's going to need more.
So mark from the essence and say, I think we need to put a
fabric on top of that. Let's just add another 20 band on which is
a little bit, right? And I think that's it.
I think that's where you would add that back in the adjustment because the
original estimate, Even though he comes around with barks of action saying that even
though the bass hits really important in as the low range.
He still- back out. That's what we can do,
please. I think that's the end of this event.
The program, uhm, from the early last minute of the base hours,
and then if we think there's a necessity to put in the adjustment,
that's where the arm can put in the edge.
Just, just like, you know, rates in a, a main hour look,
right? It's, it's, it's saying that, you know,
you're at an 80% efficiency, but,
you have an, you know, okay, I know the pipe's looking air.
I'm going to need this this next year to bring the guys back down.
And I think that's, kind of what we're talking about, the adjustment is to
adjust our mean hours per time based on the complexity of the system that
it's going to take place and it's gonna,
I think we've used that adjustment for kind of similar to what you're talking
about or it's, we had some,
not having a report or something, but that on there.
Or that's a change order and there's more happening.
Usually the adjustment is the excuse.
And it's, if there's any adjustment,
there's always a question of what I am assuming.
What is my mind if there's a change order? Good you.
Good your turn. Good for the original estimate is going to be updated as
well. Because you've estimated the change order and your everything.
Based on correctly as increased, umm.
Some people want to keep in that area and let's make it fewer,
but that's why they put it in the south area. Other than that.
I get it, I call it change order one,
change order two, but they're still nice together.
But I think, The factors that we were messing with in
the local system, were trying to make the numbers and- Mostly math,
what production was doing remains.
The problem I've seen is, across three or four jobs,
it wasn't- . uhh,
what's the right word? Linear.
Right? So, you'd think that it would be this factor.
Well, that matters. And this stuff is not that job.
So, there's more going on here that meets the eye.
We probably need a bigger sample set. Got to really figure out.
No. But a 40-hour or a 150-hour job is
very different than a 4,000 job.
There's some things that- I think your, uh,
getting the global factors closer will only help everybody.
Yeah. good. Alright, Peter. That one is...
starting next. That's great. Obviously, at this point, you've got to really take a
look at what the actual is in order to adjust.
Yes. Yes. The rest was in there. We're trying to compare to what we
said the logic was, but I don't know whether that's based on anything.
See you then. Uhh,
that is more gut-driven,
which might be,
a lot, but, uhm,
I could not go on a whole day of check time,
and that's where the- . really
like you're saying, Sam will send it to the larger Trump.
There's that aspect or just going on a few timestamps,
right, actually. Thanks in the next video.
Just messingly saying, but then we have to be cognizant about the timestony
sample that we're doing based off of the rules that we're- to create on
how that, you know. So the way I- the way I perceive it before
is that we know that- for- for example,
it's- we should get the same cut time for everything from,
uh, you know, a W-A that's- you know,
13 pounds into 14 pounds.
So, to do a screw time sample,
we make sure we, uh, take a cut list and buy an- all those,
like, sizes that match the rule that we have,
and then apply that time study to that specific chunk,
and then you validating back. So what that version has many compared to the
next step up of, you know,
everything from a 40 pounder and up.
Now apply it and check that section of it.
But I don't, it's hard because I don't think you can get true data
that you want to manipulate. Like, a rule set based off of just even
large symbols because it's your averaging across angles.
Where are those at? You don't know what's wrong. It's just some things we
were told yet the day before. It's something that's basically fudging the hours
to stay well together. I got everyone to keep in the shot,
but I'm one of them off. We finished this job,
the estimated hours from the 100th.
We only used 60. And now we keep this guy out here working for
the other 40 hours, and we post the hands that go out.
So we already know the isn't reading what you're saying,
all the- the experience is bullshit because we didn't really get back on it.
And that's where- that's where I think evaluating our rules based on the- through
times to agree with you. And then- and then you got out of factors
and everyone agrees saying, okay, like, we did it,
the guy was- he was- you you know,
and then we'd back it up and say, well, the 80% back here is
100% of the- of the- of the impact of the ball.
yeah yeah when you extrapolate data across white flanges Thank you
for watching this. Mm hmm.
Well. you It goes in both directions or just on
what more you need, right? So let's say I need to send it back
to your friends. and W85 whatever.
Because it goes all the way out through to W44.
Yeah, it was processional. We'll be able to get a piece.
If I'm looking at the cut. So if I'm looking at the cut,
it's only the process and when you're the other you're going to be similar
size and then you're going very short. Well, let's say my numbers work kind
of typically saying, for this range, now when I get to that
range. . Yeah. When numbers jerk it down,
that's the end of the side, and at w24,
I put a new factor as a go. Okay.
That direction, too. You can tell at which point you want to get it.
So, when, when I get it, I,
I took one, uhhh, one piece.
Here's what we cut inside and how long until I put it all in
our passenger thing. You I thought that.
Yeah, and what I found was that it was,
it was generally. You know.
You know, it came within our range, and then I had to get a
new range going, like you said later. And then it was like,
eep. Thank you very much.
But I I knew,
I knew what that I'd like to. And it's probably one of the people
on your machinery, too, or, uh, how you're sure that it counts.
As long as you don't have to teach . You throw it all in,
but you know that it's range-driven. Yeah.
I mean, you can paint the range. Wait,
you're gonna have to create- We're going to create a move. You have in
your process that say these are our ranges,
and then on your equipment changes, you have to realize you have to go
next to that. I, I,
I've been got, I've got multiple different samples from
different sizes and all the-
That's the end of that arm measure. And it was like,
how close am I later? Okay, that's working really close,
but I'm good enough. But then the next one didn't get us.
So I'm going to use that running a bit of a lot to the
next one. So, yeah, you, you,
you, you can, you can take part of a range if you want. Now,
that. That was good. And then you got to understand if it's been a
check, it's based off with length or,
uh, weighing back at the entire leader.
Thank you. I'm sorry, but just fine.
I'm sorry. You said it. Let me have a rain if you want.
So, bad question. Wizarding.
So, good. . . He's got this rain. It was so bad.
It so bad. mean,
so whatever. Your channel. Whatever we're cutting on here.
Hey guys! How long is this? How long is this?
I think, right. You're signing off. If they don't start shopping,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna cap this again.
Good. So, if we were going to be having to do it next time.
Right, right. But as we were, would it escape that data and apply
it to, uhm, uhh, ehm,
the data, ehm,
if I'm sharing with you guys, and if I didn't sort of stop on
the, or any of the rules that I'm tracking, Thank having me. And both
of those would hit your share. So you might do the data on the
energy. But it's not necessarily because of that.
We're still going to have to. Someone's going to have to actually interpret and
manipulate that data into this.
And, yeah, to me, I was talking about it not a big change of.
I not going to look at the next job, you know,
uhm, uhm, uhm, eh. Helping us. No, I'm not going to say that.
No, but, you don't want it. it. 7 You want it one, you want
it that for it. Yeah, and you would want to trend the hater consistently,
uh, in this size, consistently not hitting ours.
Thanks having us. Let's figure out why,
and then it's. Yeah, it was way better. I'm gonna buy him 60s.
Another guy buy him 20s,
and he's out in the load. Yeah.
And make sure you know what to make sure, too, because. videos.
Thanks for we need, if you say, tell me how long it takes to
get this, well, are we talking just later,
late running time, or are we talking about,
okay. I've got a, uhm,
it's going to be, uh,
roll it up, ahead of the set,
now cut it and go. I mean, that's good.
Well, yeah. Make sure that you have what you're looking for.
I mean, my brain is, you know, my brain is,
here's a cut, yes. There. There's 23 pieces on it.
Yeah. Start, stop. How many cuts can I get?
That picks all that up. Yeah. Bye.
It means that that start stop means to correlate to how the move is
actually written, right? So it's because technically,
I believe the way that we assumed it originally was that the starting
is when he gets there and the whole start is pointy,
right? The cross does check,
gets it bit up, gets the clamps in,
and starts, because the right thing gets better on it,
and it's, indexing it over. That's your start to stop,
but one cup of meat. Okay?
And one of the things we have along,
a long time ago was, we just had it our basic ASL spreadsheet that
just showed what the process was,
what the rule was. And then it's had a narrative of kind of where
we assumed that that number kind of was coming from,
right? And then so, uh,
scoot it for no-
They would go hand is,
so then there's a lot of overlap that I think is,
right? It could be a problem, but there's a lot of overlap.
Me not, we're handling to go to the next,
to the next station. And does every, I don't know,
it started last week. Because everybody in the shop,
I'm sure there's some trying to be there. Does everybody know those rules?
And that's where I think, right? Thank you for getting asked for years,
understanding exactly what the numbers really mean.
Getting them on board without any- or actually going so you can look for
the whole eyes of it. Okay, yeah. So we're assuming it's this,
but I'm actually making something that's 80s.
So the guy's gonna, I'm gonna have to give him some extra turning,
this is gonna have to walk all the way over there, you know,
walk all the way back, kind of thing, but understanding.
Where those, your parameters live,
or 100% efficiency, and where you should manipulate something going into the next.
Thanks. So, you should think of it as another big one.
Wherever job alignment, uh,
fitting a standard stiffer and a beam work.
I'm going to be basically versus a frame section or a buff bridge
basically. Kind of understanding that that's the main side of the What are you
doing? Well, we're talking about base hours and where do you actually are
tri-ethmated and really adjust your hours.
Thank you very much. And maybe you can
be that with just the overall efficiency, I'm not sure, so that, uh, beginning
estimate part. Perfect. Do you want to globally do that across an entire 1,000
ton project, where you just do it on a couple of parts,
right? I know, I'm sorry. It's a of that domain,
and those rules, uhh,
uhm, yeah, but, internet, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, n
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, n
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, n nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, n nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah Then it's
out It, it, it,
not the pulls it in the original, this one. You, yep. That's what you
look for. It's a manual, you know. Yeah, because. I'll see you next You
should have an estimate. You'll know what a sequence is or what a lot
is. You go a little great now. So you can't interpolate.
So yeah,
put that in. Believe that was our,
uhm, if you did start a stop on the stage.
Thank you very much. If you you're a linear candidate, uhm,
that would be that actual hours coming back in from that start stop on
the stage. So.
That, that's what I was going to say before,
if you were going to do time studies with the start stop on the
stations, that would be the awesome way to do it.
You just gotta watch on your schedule, because then you might want to build
a lot, and you gotta slow the start stop on time jacking,
and then you'll be on the start stop on time. A station is lance,
and it can double up hours. But kind of going back to your sample
approach of how you do it is. . . . You don't worry about
there again. Time study is just one cut,
right? But if we can group them based off of the rule,
and you say, okay, here's your cut. You know,
I'm gonna say two hours with the cutting, right?
We can now backtrack that into, well,
okay, he actually took two hours to- like,
birding cuts, and then you can back down into the bathroom,
based off of the bathroom. Someone's gonna be- he's gonna hit it the first
time, someone- he's gonna have to double check,
because, you know, he burned an inch, forgot about it,
or whatever he's right, so he- he just created- a big enough sample,
but that sample has to match a rule, or else it- it blends.
And so I think we need to really establish what the- rules are,
and then we can spot check.
And what we've done on the floor, too, is we get into bigger packages.
this. We can then take those rules,
and we want to get competitive. We can go do a couple of sets
and say, okay, we know that we're going to be running a bunch of
40 times. Alright, so let's go take one,
let's just run it through, and then,
okay, we can actually fine tune that a little.
you get it and get it and get get it and get it from
somebody. That's where you can use that efficiency back to the set.
I think we are going to be getting that efficiency on your own.
Like the,
the market disappeared with me, but the banish is right. We, we,
sure ran that, that higher efficiency than the market,
or the standard 75% is in there,
because they're 12 I didn't. Yeah. That's right.
That it's, so you should be able to fix your up, and that's a
problem. We've yeah, they're framing,
but we should have, we should have get more efficient as we do.
Because it's well or similar. That's what that is,
right? On user's argument that if you're doing about a thousand,
Different means that you have to treat each one as you mean.
Think you're not good enough. Because they're all different,
right? There's no cheap setup. There's no cheap exactly.
So in terms of quality efficiency,
you should actually bring your own us down based on what your base is
and not that. You haven't touched it in terms of quality.
But, you gotta kind of get base samples based on rules to know where
it actually . . That's what the rules look like.
Oh, there's a sin that's getting right. I think that's where all the rules
are applying. But there's some, there is somebody's head or somebody's paper.
That's what we need to get out of the system. So it needs to
go on. And it's a maintenance,
right? It's where we have it established. It's
been, it's been a while, is it? Yes.
You're just playing in standards.
Uh, we've been speaking to these doctors.
Here. You have to play anything.
So if there were more rules, figure out how to do it.
Yeah, I mean, I need the justice. business. ... I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know what you're saying.
Just, just click on Beings. Don't fit here on that.
Like that. And then sort by Khu. I don't know if this is what
your phone came with. Up at the top,
you have another. More. So, this,
I don't know if this is what you're going to have. There's another load,
which is gettin' off the truck. Let it down in the off.
There's a get piece which will get out of the door and take it
to your machine. I think you should talk about the yesterday that's gonna end
up with end d- Yeah, so very directly by way,
right? So where do we really, where do we really vary by way
on the section, right? Great. But no,
actually, it depends, right? Like, if it's,
if it's this way, then, if it's this way to this way,
then- Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, where can you do the language factor for our
body? Uh,
honey, honey, we messed with both of them.
So, okay. I mean, right there, right there, you're going to cross section.
I know, but we're in the satellite. We were deeper in it than that.
On air than the satellites? Yeah. Good. Not the maintenance,
that's the way you're going to be with some language that it never stands.
. Right,
so, riding here,
we looked at something. Thank you.
The other job is, and we made an adjustment to these minutes
and then ran the job. you I'll see if it could match the job.
On job A, it's like, yep, we're great.
On job B, not so much. Thank much.
On job C, it was a little closer.
So, we were messing with it right here.
So, my question is. Thank you. Is, are there actually rules currently
for these times? So, that, that,
one minute thing. So, yeah. And second. So,
we're happy by five. It's based off of the cross section layer,
right? But then it's, Alright.
It's really the unload. See how that's just engineered?
Well, minutes. Can't tell me that that 3x5 is gonna actually take.
See ya. 12 minutes, right? But what defines,
uhh, 3x5,
what defines 12 minutes? And what I remember is- anything,
any number from 0 pounds to 30 pounds is 12
minutes. So, I think it's 14 feet, it takes 12 minutes.
That's right, and yeah, so that's a, so the 40 foot mark,
but it's, and that's where it, the easiest way I could ever look at
it was, it's all, it's all spread. And you kind of start rooting all
of it, then statements together, and you start defining table,
why is it- uuh, 14 powder takes,
or a 40 footer takes, 15 minutes versus a 39
footer takes. Thanks. Like, whatever, why is that language,
right? And then you start justifying it from there.
Cause if you just had a sheer load of three mic- I was at
her, like, so you had the exact same length on three web eyes,
funnel, right? And you're gonna funnel cut. And.ming.
at All right. right. Good. One of your love together.
You don't want to put it, you know,
it's a big label. Exactly.
And that's where. Under. numbers. Seeing me really where these times would really kind
of compile from a, just a global image that's saying,
well, that's the main standpoint, everything like that.
That's where you want to be able to,
I think, you want to pull a picture, go into where it's going to
be, you know, hours. All right. Welcome, Mr. Michael. And really don't want from
a base hour standpoint, knowing that there's no way where it's going to actually
take us to follow out hours and adjust again from there.
Thank But you have to have a knowledge with an hour from coming soon
to be able to think that it's a film. And that's how good we
go to interview one-on-one and- either and say,
well, how long to move?
How long to do both of the clips, and like,
you'll do it yourself. Thank That's because there's all of these extraneous
factors on the exceptions as well,
right? So, okay. Yep. I'm getting sure to measure that.
That's easy, that's a beautiful, and that's just pretty,
it more de-ins, right? Don't get that.
Fun long thing. I'm getting lean, and I'm getting out of the stuff.
I'm probably going to look at it on the Mac for your job to
get out of places. And I let me get into all of it up
or down, cause otherwise, I'll just be down already.
You know what I'm trying to say? Let's try it. One dot one gear.
So I've done worse. Let's go see that,
balta dot fillet and boron- I've changed that one a lot of the time.
Well, I think I need it, but it's gonna be a little better.
And I think that's knowing where the- Like,
roomings go. I think it's gonna help define how to break those signals and
lots down. So that you can actually come up with a good s- sample
size that doesn't have a lot of other factors into it,
looping to get yourself good and pe with that all time.
If you're kidding, you're, You're an average 25 man on the floor.
But, uhm, but it's understanding kind of where you're given to you for,
I'm if you in the middle section,
I think it's really where you're getting good data.
So at the end of the day, that's, I think, I mean,
take the afternoon, y'all. If you have a good set of data in here
that we really trust, we really know where we can push and where we
can get it. Everything else is just a take off,
right? It's just, you just have your funds to take offs good,
you can really like. I don't understand, but,
uh, if we don't know where we can, we can't provide the staff,
it's, I might as well go back to the dark and think,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, it's gotta be,
uhm, you gotta get really good actual
downback. back. I don't think anybody here really kind
of trusted the actual numbers that we're looking at.
So, eh, it's really gotta be. You gotta make sure there's
hours on the jet motor and leaving this unit.
Alright. And I'll have to make it there. We'll you in You more of
the jet. I don't know what extent perfect that I'm this lot.
I didn't trust him. But, yeah. Trust me. We'll see you very good.
Really good. Last big one.
Well, I think that's the goal. I think that's the thing we're trying to
show. But, yeah, we're really good. Wait. I mean, uh. I'm going go ahead
and in the day, I mean,
let's just take the maintenance from the problem,
really, side of the building. We want good data.
Have a good one. To start getting this accurate,
where we can trust it and condemn it. Thank you.
There's still sales side of it.
No one. . When you can get more money,
and then it'll be competitive. And then there's the management side of where I
think more of a. I believe,
once the door is being able to accurately know how many hours it means
to do something so we can really say. Hey, customer,
we're going to have this too on Tuesday. Yeah.
And really playing out to know I'm overloading on a soft- for the next
six months, right? I need to get another saw,
I need to get two shifts going, another operator instead of those two.
Kinda mean it. I know. I mean, I don't know. I mean,
there's a lot of,
ehm, a job scrub. Take out the something else that's in it,
right? I'm to be in the job job. Supporting the field,
getting stuck on time is, is a huge factor because those guys,
I mean. . . We're burning grains, we're burning fire launches,
like, all sorts of how much we're going to delay some of their stuff
physically. I mean, Mario gets the
vaccine only thought a lot of times because we're finishing up the design.
Bye. It's not always blind and the labor and execution is always
getting pushed up. So he's trying to really fit things in the narrow window.
Bye-bye. While juggling 12 other ones and being able to accurately
say, like, this is really what it's gonna take us.
I- The plan's out until you're gonna get it on- on the stage is
gonna be a big schedule to push.
Yeah, the problem is- I'm just sorry- I mean- that's- even better because that's
kind of what you can tell to you but- 9.10%
from the meeting's very perfect.
And, yeah, I mean, that's, like, the biggest frustration a lot of times when
I feel this not- No. That's when I lost my knowledge because there's the
budgets in bigger things when it comes to this,
but hitting digits.
But yeah, that's a huge.
Yeah, and being able to protest that 7,000s with our production schedule will be
having- and you know, way helpful.
This is the amount we have for this period of work.
We can finally start affording the- range.
And, and make sure that we're able to hit what we got to hit.
So, uh, so how do we move this?
How do we take some of this up and,
and, and, and I'm just thinking out loud here.
But how do we, come up with ways that we can use,
what our family body should be,
to know what we, We can go and check,
right? Like, how do we, where do we really just find some of the
stuff to break it into rails and build our beams?
me. Or cut a list that are up to all channeling to,
you know, 10 pounds to really start getting some.
I'll you in next True. True. Yeah.
Well, let me just say it's from working at what, um.
Hello. If I look at the data that we were looking at on
this one, found out, you know, everybody.
We'll find time for the big answer. But this is it.
So, ladies and gentlemen, look at those three or five jobs.
And these are the jobs that I believe were manipulated now.
So, believe me, they're playing, yeah. That's why they came in.
Why not? Well, what time were they now?
I don't know who it is. No problem.
Yeah. About 30.
And then, for each split out, you split out two different trussles.
Yeah, two different trussles. So we did- what was released on our shop package,
and, you know, the blood in the estimate and the tech glove,
and then, umm, welcome. and have a head for a screenshot after the opening
or tweaks in there to try and fine tune in a little bit.
And, umm, what did- uh, for two, it's not supposed to be anything like
a two or three of well-paced. Like,
all right, I'm going to just look at this here. Uh,
so, here we go. What about the day before you were here on Monday?
Isn't that the day we've had Mark sitting here and he went over three
jobs? Bob's. And those ones came out within an hour.
Yeah, it was. That's the ones that I saw.
And that's because those have been benefited.
So what I,
what I was comparing this to was the budget to what Tackley is.
Because the, the toad. The actual hours just
were too perfect. I don't, I don't know that I would trust them.
But the budget split out as.
the S opposed to tech love is really what I was comparing it to.
Yeah, going forward.
I would be. Like, okay. How long?
I think what I'm doing is going to keep going backwards.
I look at everybody's total hours. I wish.
Compared to the hours that were applied to the job and see if that
actually lines up. That's why I always run against cable.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Just know if it's available.
It truly is. It truly worked out.
Well, that's what it makes it the same time.
So, if you looked at what was, what was the budgeted on that,
that project ever kind of customer to the chamber,
we added money for the process of. Uh,
he, you know, didn't mean last week. And every time he had to include
it, I saw it. Yeah. He came on the way to sell them.
And I said, it's good. Yup. Yup.
That, you know, was prescribed to shoot a good one.
Yeah, that should have gotten to this exact end of it,
I think. I that, uh, the, the,
the, the, the budget, the total, the, the, the session on the back specific
job, I know that one time. That one got scrapped.
Okay. Especially the way that we redesign a lot of connections and things a
lot of more. But I think, so let me change this from estimate to
actual. Marshall. Great. Yeah. Yeah, they,
they answer kind of the profile.
Yeah. So what does Mark estimate off of?
He estimates. That amazing. He gets the shot points he gets for me.
Whereas the estimator now, well,
Mark's checking, right? All right. Like, very long it's actually doing the data.
I'm trying to do an estimate and then,
ehm, we're reviewing, and it's going to look like,
or I didn't estimate enough later.
And then, once we're on the same page, we then take that back.
Go ahead. And in the infants,
within the budgets that we perceive,
that it's good, we push it through. If it's outside of the budgets,
then, Then we raise the flag A,
we think we're gonna have a total return on this one, and that's when
we can be back to the estimating team to say, A,
hmmm. Alright, so we asked him if it was something else,
or are we, are we hiring or dissertion?
Actually, just preplanning so that if we're going to go over a certain amount
of the project, at least letting your team know,
what? Bye. Hold on, participate. Then obviously shoot it for the original
goal and push the guys to maintain the original hours estimated. Thank I will
see you in the next . . We can't change our own and make
up what we're anticipating our own room street.
Are you in the asking room? Are you in Are you in the asking
room? asking room? Right. So,
it depends on the project.
I don't know. Probably not. No, we have to be looking at the designer.
You these guys are going to shut, right? So,
it's a horseback. Yeah. You know. Cause that's where the end of the difference
is, right? Yeah. Cause, design may- Yeah.
Made it easier. Yeah.
Use it all on the end. It's, it's, it's on. It's on.
I'm gonna Anyway,
it's different. I like that. Yeah. Point in it.
And that's, that's me. That's right.
There it is. You Yeah,
it is. It's the real big actual time.
It's, and then fine up front,
right? It's the- I did it here, so I didn't mind if we had
an issue to where we didn't, you know. It's not at the end of
it, we're forecasting. That's the date they did.
We fix it, do something different to save the job.
It is how they did it. Or, or, like them,
like what they're saying, is that it comes in honor and is action.
You know, it's only planned in my production scene point that we're only going
to be three days worth of the word, right?
And that's the right word. Alright, man. The floor tested mass,
I thought it, and not going into it, but thinking that it didn't even
play down or swear. Okay, I didn't,
you know. Don't. Don't. The guys are going to now have,
you know, five days to do it. It should actually push them so they're
three, but I don't have to work on the two guys in the max.
Bye bye.
I don't, I don't want to tell the shot.
How many buzzers do you guys rehab for the next three to six
months? Yeah. And then run it and see what it comes.
It comes out to be and then compare it to the estimated
and adjusted. I trust
I don't know if people are going to come up with the weight each
year. They're going to sit up. Yeah, I'm going to go over on this
channel. So I'm going to take some of those out of me.
I'm going to do a job because I think I'm going to do that.
You can see it in the system too. Yeah. But I bet they do
it either. This here.
And appreciate it. I it. Thank you. And you. I just think tackle is
important. You can make changes.
Yeah. I don't.
you Thank you.
I don't think you're here. . . I don't you're here.
I don't like the
sweet. We think I'm, I'm seeing with what I had here,
but I don't really trust for that. No, I don't think I'd see when
it's bad or hard. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think it's a,
it's a, it's a lot of student business. I mean, it's a couple years
worth of usually I'll be just a group of people on the platform,
so, good. Get a shot, kind of. I always had a relaxing change,
but we both have a challenge, like,
what we do on this fight, and fight by doing it in the,
It's generally not too far out of It was okay to
me, I would just keep running with it, but get some really good data
to come back and change it. Yeah, I agree.
I'm not scared of being a whole child.
I'm gonna be scared to run a bit, but. Okay. Let me,
one of the smaller used calls are going to seem better to use it.
And then. But you, but you, but have one over and that's okay with
these. But there's just,
you do not. Okay, so I, you know, you have consistency.
It's not what we got. So far,
I had to make the decision. . . Like that.
Good.
Well, even with the change,
you know, they're probably located versus five hours,
uh, or day south. With the production,
uhm,
we can inform our leads on base hours.
and so on. Instead of originally estimated,
you can give them the goal below what was actually estimated.
See if they can hit that goal. Inaudible. If they can.
Because right now, we're classing on the big board of the shop.
This is no mercy air for this. It's no mercy air for this.
It's the sound you haven't seen in this. Yeah.
We use it. So we undercut that goal and we're always
shooting for something slightly. okay I'll take I've been bit less than what we
have. As long as we know we've recovered a budget lives with what's estimated,
then it don't matter what we're telling them they have to do it.
Yeah. Mhm. And it didn't make a budget until what they have to do
it again. And then from there it's a set of hunchiever bowlers,
or you can actually. Thank you very much.
Yeah. So, cause that's definitely,
and we can do that on the work
package. Bye. You know, I think at the end of the day,
we take out a good motivation factor,
like this. We,
As, as from, uh,
me and it's the same, like, cap to double what the actual
art is. . Right, like, there's so many times the estimator is being skid,
and you start going through this, like, I have no idea what all this
intensity can see. Like, you start putting this up in,
and you don't have no idea what your true actuals are together.
You have to get some sort of- comparability of what to the shot actually
would be. It's you know, right, you know, at the end of the day,
when we're self-delivered, it's your motivation to to the- .
Or, like, what it is, it'll be happy to be comfortable with what to
the shot actually puts. Okay,
the finish goes into- I mean,
it's a big picture of when, you know,
we're putting it 16,000 times instead of the shot.
So, w- You know what I'm saying? Right. So,
uh, it might keep me actually doing it, right?
Like, do a thousand, you know,
um, so. So. One, like what an effort is going to be comfortable with
it. The sales side,
I mean, that's the easy side. But. We'll see you know,
but then you want to deal with it. But we need you're comfortable with
what we actually didn't do.
Right? Okay. Okay. Let's see. You're sorry. You're sorry.
Bunching beans and getting away from, you know,
what would sell it for us, didn't it? It gets very confusing here.
I need- I want to lose sight of what our being actually
production . .
I'd bet a $16,000 that use working towards them.
I think so. The MCthink is the-ass,
or whatever. They're big.
In, uh, we didn't see you over,
but I didn't see you over to the side then. And it was the
Yeah, they're very important to that.
I guess production means that you can get an else.
And I mean, then besides We have developed one inch points here.
And then we have the dual spices, multiple dual spices to the rear.
Thank you. So, um, have the rooters,
like, 74 feet. So we have the,
uh, the, the goodness of the footer. And you have the bottle too.
Then we have the hookup. You over to the 16th footer and the long
top. And then we have another specific piece.
Break the schedule. I feel, It's about, very looked at.
The schedule was to get drawings in November and to get them to November
and March. Yeah, very good. There's 7,000 tons in March.
Yeah. Okay, I don't even know if they're coded.
If they're coded, they're coded. I don't think they're coded.
I don't have that okay, interesting.
Something that big one would probably aspire for.
I think. So, um. Don't forget to ask them.
The estimator or the GC?
That's good. Uh, I think for answer.
All right. Good. Just, um, yeah. Mm hm.
Probably some of these other instructions, uh,
described a long case of-
Um. Adjustment?
Yeah, that makes sense. Give me that change month.
Give me what you need to- What do I mean here?
Are you leaving here? Umm, I need you to go out here in a
few minutes. I've heard you're buying- You and I should have a quick talk
about the 2020 departure. Watch There's too many people saying it's not my job.
Oh, yeah. I have a feeling you're the decision-maker here.
I'm not gonna see. Ha-ha.
That's the person. That's the question.
Anybody, Jeff has the coupons? Just so you know.
Right. So he's got it. We just didn't do what to do.
So, uh,
yeah. I would say no one's gonna make a decision.
I say we, we pass. All right. I'm actually a prep of the actual
fitment that we're gonna do, which is just a single edge,
right? And then running as a T.G. in cognitive.
That's what the guys are gonna do, okay?
Are they gonna get, I don't want, Are we done with this?
Maybe you and I have a little side, side marker? Yeah. Alright.
Alright. Uh,
what's the local national's? If pervert or tomorrow is not gonna take my athlete's
self spreadsheet, I'm gonna take him to believe that. We'll have to match what
we have on the figure out what we need to
do. So we're gonna finally- do a practicing grip on that.
And obviously, I know that actually I was,
like I said, coming up with some- some- I'm going to back to the
some way that we start gripping these things to get bigger,
because when we- long, long, I'm going to back to the- what are the-
the approach that we had is- is you group a cut list on,
and- and even if you group a cut list,
and you say, okay. Thank It's a good sample to have over it,
or do you talk about it? Just having to get it right on the
paper, and just say, hey, I started out a hoo hoo.
. I started 8.03. I got, uh,
pen 15, right? And then it, it, it,
something I can come back and release some stats of paper,
something can come. And you can have some,
you know, there, you guys are bored, so we've got this all the time.
And then, then you can take, you can buy that out and say that
they don't just tell them. So, there are 75 cases in the guy that
have got any four minutes. You can check it.
So, the, the basic catch. Yeah.
Go ahead. And, and tomorrow or two, whatever you get that wall imported in,
I think it would be kind of careful for us to run it from-
the room, purchase it,
do a cutness, process the cutness,
do the receding, just to make sure there's no other h- .
We can run through that pretty
quickly. How do I expect to be here?
Yeah. Yeah. Everything I've got is gonna be better than stuff. And then it's
all, all the evening, you know. Yeah, it's, it's. David,
thanks. Thanks, David. And wanna thank We'll see And we'll see And we'll be
have some, I think, some of them. It depends on the approach,
but I like that. I think that's it,
David. I think that's it. I'm in jail. I'll see you in the next
I mean, yeah.
It'll fire your fire. If your project's in there,
I know I'm saying no need to go. Sorry, stop.
I can't blame anybody for supporting me. You're just from there,
it's really, you put it in there or I have a new job,
because it only happens when you've gotten invigorated.
Umm, well, it's not the same, but it's definitely the same kind of thing.
We have jobs. Retail companies are very important.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. They're not actually working,
they're all changing. Yeah, yeah. Or yeah,
artisans. And uhh, uhh, uhh, people do it on the board these months.
So, we're doing too least a stack,
right? And so, they're going to listen to a battery and go on and
blow you some champagne. Thank Uhh, let's listen to the units.
Hey, there, there are. I can get familiar with the units back.
So, uh,
I that's easy. Why don't we- That's not something we can be guys trying
to get the schrapping. That's no doubt. Yeah.
Where is the unit on that look? We're headed, Is it-installed?
Is it pre-installed by Mr. Jones? I think it's not even this job.
It's good here. The bar is cutting back and that's the second section.
No, no, no, no, no. Just, uh, just, uh, No, just,
you know, uh, it's, uh, it's real, not just a- not real,
not really. I can't do it- it's just.
. ...I deserve- hmm, you want? It's a second.
I just shut the equipment, it's such fun to be using guns,
you know, it's being guns and just- I think that- Thank you.
I don't know how to say that,
but you can write the funny things that are ignorant,
because they put the relax with that on the inside or on the other
side. It's the consensus to get up,
because it's virtual, because everyone I was seeing is meeting 12th-day images,
and it's going to be third-day at home. And,
uh, And the biggest thing, like, it would just slide in,
and then you got to come up at the end,
and you got to back and forth there, and it's all, it's a thousand
years old. I
don't get it,
because, like, these are how we're resulting. Yeah. I don't even get typed together.
Okay. I'm to see what this is inside.
Cause I'm going to all this. I'm going to need it. He's going to
lay right away. I'm going to go back and battle.
That's going to be forget. Okay, thank you. Uh, I'm going to lay it
in 40 now. I'm going to take a look at this.
So I'm going to take a look at it. So I'm going to show
it to the customer. Well, that's one way.
Now, we have some rows.
I don't know how much you might have made from Genesis. And yes,
it was within 2000. that of. that's what was saying.
I don't know. It's, uh, yeah, two pieces. I'm going take out this one.
I'm going to make a huge list of the guys' walks here in the
dwellers' booth. You have it. If it works,
spin it up. Yeah, so, uh, isn't you running the intake?
Why don't you just say it down to a vote? Well, I don't think
it's always back with me about you. Thank you. Actually,
I've heard that it's, uh, the best measure is still going to pick it
up a sentence. Okay, so, yeah, I just don't have a problem with the
bullet that they've actually put back to.
Umm, ehm, ehm, ehm, ehm. I'm going to break this if you
haven't seen it.
Umm, ehm, ehm, ehm. But I'm a graduate,
I'm a I'm a I'm a It's all I've done since I was born
five years. Nice and late. Umm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, ehm,
ehm.
So, uh, I kind of have to say, right? So, as long as you
have to become 50% everyday out there,
or just like, get this part of somewhere, is That's
one of the
United.
I'm going to go ahead I think I'm in pleasure with the Vietnam time
studies and all that side over there. I'm going to give it an essentially
need to have. Yeah.
That's you know, I don't know not something that I have job,
but it's not something that I can It's not something that I yeah,
I job. It's inside of it, I get shocked, but it's fine with it.
I don't think my name is so. . . I'm sure it stays on
it. You've never kind of lived.
I don't know. They don't get bothered even if they ask about staff.
Okay, that's great. Now I'm nice to wish I But no,
the program you're using, it's almost.
You don't have to go back and forth. Okay,
you'll just send one, uh! I've got,
I didn't even need to compare it to them, so I sexually used to
go to Ben Hall and, uh, and go right in to the inside,
because of the alphabet about labels. I didn't have any of these patterns that
weren't used to me, I should really collect what I think of it all
to me. He's had the theories when he asked me.
I didn't see any of these. I was thinking about it on that table.
Yeah. And I think- You know what, I just think we have done sometimes.
We need to be able to buy it in a little shot. I'm not
going to just buy it in the other way. Yeah. Do you know that
we're going to the Canadian side? Because of all that charity.
It's one group kind of long, eh?
The ones that I expect are- I don't need to be skeptical of the
way. I need to get their own direction inside of the business.
Yeah, all of it. They need to be used to be in case it
was a push to all of the cost. All right, we'll see you week.
Now, we are interested in something that is,
uh, the thing that nobody else can accept from the government to be on
this stuff. Uh, so, they are on a,
Umm, uhh, uhh, hmmm. and the 11th message gave the name.
That, we have the states that we're going to be president if they're not
going to have much love. Maybe you should all know how to do the
program, the excels, and ex-creatives that are planning So,
shut those all in. It's not a big part of the community, it's not
a big part community, it's a big of the community. It's a big part
of the community. It's a big part of It's a big part of the
community. Take this back here,
Tom. It's a part of it.
It's a big part of it. It's a big part of
it. I thing is that you haven't done it for me so I know
they've got some anxiety. If you're not going to be waiting,
especially outerson about you, who screwed it up,
you know. I am, uh,
there are just a lot of feelings in this.
There is a lot of truth.
He's only, I think, presenting. Thank sir.
And there's a lot of reasons why I got to do it.
I think it's one of the things that I know it's going to be
challenging to me. It's going sharp line, so we can get fixed.
I'm just going to, We're in some other, We're thought the laser is going
to be anticipated.
I think that's a lot of reasons to come in here, so I think
it's a good word. with me.
I'm gonna bring this thing out here, and this place is the next place,
the U.S.S.K. All of these same and high states with my own shares.
They're really starting to scratch it out. It does not say it's important,
and we're really good times. It always takes the name of this account saying,
make sure. Alright guys, we hope I don't put it right here in the
time stays, but we're through so much. That's it,
we're starting to put out 50 seconds a day. Great,
so we know- We have an answer,
and the answer is, can you use that, right?
It's a seal though. It's a little different. It's a little different.
It's the way we do it. Yeah.
You're gonna hang me last time. Right. You know, talk to me later. Bring
the laundry on. Thank you. Thank you. Bye. I'm going ahead and I think
that they're alive. Yeah, and Steve's thoughts.
We were deserved to be here.
Thank you. Thank And the job,
Dila, I'm part To ourselves and do more work against us here tonight.
We'll be nice to meet you guys and see you along with them. I'm
part of what I'm doing. We're taking a moment of fighting.
So we're like, I hate flying us on the ground in the work that
they're doing. I hope At least they have a 6-minute event.
And also a great day. I'm telling you, you know,
the girl is definitely a bright community. I just,
I guess, the bottle is due to the- and it's important that it's hanging
apart from the back, which is the exact same thing.
Oh, wow. our friends.
and I'll agree is that when you move this thing, I like to do
it. We got the solids, and and then we have 2,000.
And then this one. It's not,
it's like, if we don't have some various applause,
it's really good. It's, it's a good skill.
It's really good. It's a great very,
very That we don't have to be able to spark around and just finish
like this. Like, the exterior open,
well, I think we should stick with blood. Yeah, it is. It's very good.
I'm coming All right. You're to be in the department of addition.
As soon as it stays later, I want to know when I'm going to
reach the convenience of him. So I'm having this kind of schedule to be
back. You better. That's it. We need to have this similar kind of questions.
At least I'm meeting them next year in the office.
Let's give it a new thing up there. We'll do it forever.
We can, uhm, we're supposed to speak any more.
You can't listen to the parliamentary statement about it.
So we're going to go on the dice, but we're going to think we're
going to, just going to end up wasting the, uhh, the most familiar in
the air is starting the ball. Yeah. So I'm going to ask you,
okay, I'm going to ask you, I mean, if I just,
I'll take it. You better play it. It's going to throw it in.
I don't like trying to call it listen. I want to tell you both
songs. Come on guys. You know, you're better than me.
That's what I said.
. Next morning, we should go to the city. So, uhm,
finally, on the interior, the same way that we created drugs here in Vermont
and Foxport. Yeah, that was the end of the video. It's not to understand.
It's not easy to trust our guys, but, you know, otherwise you need one.
I think it's got fat and anxiety. I don't know.
I don't know. Good night. It's been a couple of days,
but it's a lot of steps to say, you know, let's just do what
the guys can do, and that's where, uh,
my, my, my. Thank you.
I think name I've looked at, uh,
what's the possible office that I've known as? I think it's currently analyzed in
English to me, but I'll see ya. and I mean,
I mean, I want something to do with the design,
I can't just say that that's just a lot of office. I mean, that's
not a lot of, because there's a lot of studio that's focused on that.
Okay, let's. Well, hi. I'm an old-time speaker.
I'm a shoot man, and I'm a dedicated speaker. I mean, just still loves
as much as my animals and stuff like this. Couple of things.
Yeah, same. You get Right. Right. Okay. Thank you. You know, I can dig
everything. I uh, it throws you next to this bolt.
Just that. Let's just put it in the same component. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Mm Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Mm
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
But it's a different person, or if you are in the case,
please send out to me. All selected. Yeah.
So, my point is that,
It's good. And the whole process is not,
And being sure I'm already on the wall because it's having a little bit
of a, And I think we're getting here this way.
You've got to do it down on the ground or something like that.
You know, understanding how,
umm, umm,
umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm,
umm,
umm, umm, umm, umm, umm,
I've been saying black salt or that's what I've just seen. 54 years dont
know if its content right now. Like,
so you have to look from what's here, they got a leech and then,
you know, I think I'm gonna have to bring the lead days to my
seventh night, uh, ass, play, and look, and really hear us,
you know.
Yes, there is no bad plan to change it.
Then I brought them all to us to take a walk.
Man, I know that a hell of a time, Travis. I'm not used by
a virus, excuse me. I don't care. I need you to, like,
damage the player to me. I don't even care if we have to ask
them all if they're innocent and you don't care. Pick a ball,
you can't even use a purpose very much.
You don't get a back hand for that,
but yeah, you don't flick. Yeah,
so it goes, you know. My thing's been rolling.
That's a- I did it when I
was younger and then I got here and then I don't have any- I
got my family out here and I didn't have a lot of friends while
I didn't work here, so I joined the league,
and I saw that team, and I saw that on another team.
And I noticed I was having the best. Oh, there they go.
See, I mean, sorry about the second one here, too.
Uh, and then I ended up summoning the second one here.
Uh, both of my parents said,
go get the 500 horsepower car.
I don't care. Just don't have a motorcycle.
Oh, well that's, I've had a drive-in for a drive-in on a,
I've ridden both. I've had that certainly. Yeah,
I ride a little 250 on the wheel.
Nice. Single track. Uhh,
I'm a p****, so I ride an accident double track,
or, for a certain surroundings I'm gonna be able to single track.
That's not picking up. Yeah, I did single track.
I found one house. I'm gonna be used to the amount of time.
I was back when I moved to the shop. And that was a while
later. I don't know. And then I'll turn up Peter and I'll be able
to see him trying to have him in the morning. And then I'll survive.
And then I'll be to see him and then I'll work out on
the next few things in early twenties.
So, now it's- Thank bye.
Now it's over the dance floor. It's not any bowling.
I don't really feel the dance. I'll say it along with you.
I mean, I think that was the business I was just starting to- I
get my thirties all the way up.
I mean, I still have to raise bicycles for all from college.
I'll let you know. All right.
I got. And,
thank you for that. Yeah. Well, in, like, all I mean,
I guess, all I need to But when I'm holding up my
majority of my friends and majority of people I hold up my parents' age,
it's solid. Love you. I'm like, being out with a bunch of old people
I'm like, I've got school so I can't even have them in the habit
of time and then I don't blame the day. Bye. My teammates,
I've got a picture of my teammates in there,
uh, when we go to Vegas every year,
can. Yeah. And, uh, and they're always okay.
And you're so awesome. I think it's the end.
Okay. Look that. Look at that.
I think I need help. I have to connect.
I need some. That's my wife's. No.
I'm not. I'll see you.
You guys tomorrow. Alright, I'm gonna live on that note.
Uh,
I'm gonna talk a little bit about this field job. Bye bye.
Okay. Thank you.